this is jocko podcast number 332 with
echo charles and me jocko willink good
evening echo good evening
so when
i first started this podcast when we
first started this podcast
i was talking about different
situations how i handled different
situations what i thought about
various subjects
different viewpoints i had concerning
leadership and
really concerning human nature
and almost immediately started getting
feedback and started getting asked
questions and people would say hey
have you studied stoicism or
are you did you do a lot of work you
know looking at at nietzsche
or some other ancient or modern school
of philosophy
and the short answer was that no i
didn't i i didn't do that i mean i left
high school joined the military so there
wasn't this big educational background
for me i'm not an academic of any kind
in fact there was a funny one of the
earliest live events that i did
and it was a relatively cultured
audience
out there
and someone asked you know hey
who's your favorite who's your favorite
philosopher
and i said
lemmy
and no one laughed like i laughed but no
one else laughed and and so i added i
said you know lemmy from from motorhead
and a couple people sort of awkwardly
laughed but not much
and and later on we explored this idea a
little bit more on the podcast and
because
look there's much to be learned from
old philosophers and and old thinkers
and
as it turns out i agree with and i'm
aligned with a lot of what they say no
doubt about it i'm not trying to say
anything negative about
these ancient philosophers and the
theories that they had
but
the fact of the matter is i just didn't
study them i mean like i said i i was a
[ __ ] high school student
i didn't i don't think i read any books
in high school
so
yeah i didn't learn anything about these
things
i just figured these things out through
my own
random trials and tribulations in life
and it was a similar situation with with
jordan peterson
when when he came on the podcast for the
first time it was really obvious that
we had come to many of the same
conclusions
in our views of life
but he got to those conclusions through
a
rigorous academic study
and work as a clinical psychologist and
i got there through my experiences in
life and in the teams
and i've been
very lucky in that regard
very lucky to
kind of stumble into things
been guided in certain situations been
shoved in some directions
made some good decisions along the way
made some bad decisions and been lucky
enough to live through it and learn
learn from it so i've been very very
lucky but i also pay attention to these
kind of things
a lot of times i was paying attention to
these kind of things because i i was
trying to teach them i originally
started paying attention to leadership
because i had to learn it in order to
become a leader so i was paying
attention and i was watching what
leaders were doing
and eventually i was paying attention to
leadership because i was teaching it
and so i saw things and i stumbled into
things
and
you know one of the things i wrote about
leadership strategy and tactics i mean
my first platoon we're we're clearing
gas oil platforms i do a big write-up
about this and in that book but my
platoon ends up on a skirmish line we're
all we're all looking down our weapons
looking to engage targets and no one's
making a call no one's making any kind
of a decision and i
as a new guy
i take a step back
which means i broaden my field of view
i look around so i can see more and i a
nice calm comes over me and now i can
see what we need to do and i make a call
and i started to teach that i started to
teach that to young leaders hey you need
to take a step back you need to broaden
your field of view you need to look
around
and it's going to calm you down and
allow you to make a decision
i also
would tell guys hey you need to take a
breath and i i have some you know i
wasn't saying you need to take some
spiritual transcendent breath you need
to reach deep into your inner soul and
breathe i wasn't saying that
the actual reason i was saying is
because you don't want to sound panicked
when you come up on the radio
you don't want to come up on the radio
and say we need to get everyone over
this building you don't want to do that
you don't want to do it number one
because everyone else is going to now
panic and number two because everyone's
going to make fun of you when you get
back from this operation so you don't
want either one of these so when you
have to make a decision you take a step
back and then you take a breath
you detach you broaden your field of
view and these things will calm you down
and allow you to make better decisions
and recently
i've heard some podcasts
tim ferriss and joe rogan by the way uh
they've had a guy on a couple times
named andrew andrew huberman
and this guy is a doctor
a neuroscientist a professor
[Music]
as i was listening to what he was saying
a lot of the things that i have been
teaching
were aligned with what he was saying
and believe it or not one of the things
was a broad field of vision calms you
down
taking a breath is something that
scientifically calms you down
physiologically calms you down
broadening your field of view
physiologically calms you down and guess
what i know this the calmer you are the
better decisions you're going to make
then there were other things when i
listened to him talk
that i recognized from my own
experiences
cold water
it doesn't feel good when you get in it
but it feels good when you get done
lifting weights fasting things that i
had kind of instinctively or through
trial and error figured out
were now being reinforced by someone
that
actually academically understood the
science behind
my instincts
now my instincts are not always right by
any stretch of the imagination
i i can i should probably write an
entire
litany of books about the dumb things
i've done
but
i'm always looking to see hey if there's
some things i'm doing right why are they
right if there's things i'm doing wrong
why are they wrong and always looking to
increase the understanding that i have
behind the things that i
think i've figured out
which is why
we are fortunate to have dr andrew
huberman here with us tonight to help
explain and explore
what we think
what we think we know what we think we
think
and how we can get better at all of the
above
andrew
thanks for coming down man it's good to
meet you great to be here
did that um
when i was listening to you talk and i
was hearing you talk about how
you're if you're focused on something
small it amps up your adrenaline i was i
was listening i was going oh it was all
these things were coming together all
these dots were getting connected it's
kind of crazy right it's pretty wild i
mean i think some people may know this
many people probably won't was which is
that your eyes are two pieces of your
brain they're the only two pieces of
your brain and yes they are brain for
those of you that want to look it up
they're part of your central nervous
system and they're outside your cranial
vault
and they are there to set the aperture
right the either tunnel vision or the
broad field of view not just on your
vision but on your thinking
which is what you described and widening
your field of view your visual aperture
will allow you to
parse more information
it also changes your perception of time
so the simplest way to put this is that
when you are in a narrow field of view
it's a bit like having a video camera in
slow motion
your frame rate is higher
but in that small aperture you're
looking at minor details as soon as you
hear it you think duh of course
but the opposite is also true when you
broaden your field of view and that
could be by literally moving your head
around but it can also just be by
keeping your head more or less
stationary and just deliberately
broadening your field of view we call it
panoramic vision
you are taking
smaller frame rate
or i should say sorry larger bins of
time but the way the visual system works
is really clever
it actually allows you to sense motion
more quickly so when you run and catch a
ball or when you're walking along and
you blink and a bee hits your eyelid you
didn't see it coming
see in quotes but you're in that
panoramic field of view
and your reaction time is four times
what it is when you're in that narrow
aperture
now i again i just want to reiterate
this and and just clarify this
for like 20 years
i have been teaching
young seal leaders and then you know
other people in the world in the
business world in the in the first
responder world in the military at large
for 20 years i've been saying hey listen
when things start to go
get wild you need to get off your gun
you need to take a step back you need to
broaden your field of view you need to
look around to see what's happening i've
been telling people that for 20 years
only because it just worked for me
and i luckily figured that out
in my very first seal platoon and and it
took me a while to where i said oh
that's something i need to tell other
people to do like i figured it out and
would do it but then once i was a
position where i was teaching these
things so that's just like
wild that there's all these
physiological things that occur
that for me was
i i knew it i knew that you better do
this
because i mean imagine you want to talk
about a field of view imagine what your
field of view is like when you're
staring down the the barrel of your gun
it's tiny your field of view is so
focused and you don't see anything i
mean other than the target right in
front of you you don't see anything and
that's what happens to
when when a young seal is in a
leadership position that's what happens
to them they get they're looking down
their weapon and they don't see anything
that's that's happening they can't make
any decisions because they don't see the
entire picture they see nothing so
that's kind of crazy and that's again
these are just some of the examples that
i pulled from listening to you and
listening to your podcast by the way
hubermann lab
um
before we get down any more rabbit holes
let's let's talk about where you came
from how you ended up in this spot
because i would say you didn't take a
sort of a standard route to end up where
you ended up so let's talk about young
andrew huberman what's going on where
are you born
i was actually born in stanford hospital
oh okay i joke i you know i was born at
stanford hospital i trained at stanford
i work at stanford i'll probably die at
stanford
hopefully a long time from now you know
people say you're gonna die in your
office they're worse place to die than
stanford
how are you born there like why yeah so
my parents worked there so my my dad's
from south america he actually came here
um he was a physicist but he came here
from argentina on a navy scholarship so
the navy paid for my dad to leave
argentina where there were no
opportunities to do science came to the
u.s went to university of pennsylvania
over the years he's worked on various
projects related to government but i
actually don't know a ton about what he
does now
but growing up well he met my mother in
new york city and she's from the east
coast it's from jersey and my
grandfather
went to college on the gi bill so he was
a world war ii vet had my mom while he
was in graduate school and
he was a real physical guy that'll come
up later you know your dad was my
grandmother my grandfather on my mom
okay i got it
um so my dad my mom met moved to
california and had my sister and i and
this was a time i should say when palo
alto is you know no dot com no silicon
valley
in this scope of wealth in the bay area
we were we were middle class we weren't
upper middle class so we single single
story home i mean we didn't we didn't
want for things you know i didn't
imagine about having ferraris or
anything that we didn't but there were
kids in the other high school they're
two high schools in palo alto i went to
the one where all the nerdy kids went
it's actually called gun high school uh
gun and it has a funny reputation not
funny has an infamous reputation it's
the highest suicide rate of any high
school in the united states for reasons
that we can talk about so from the time
i was born
until
about age
13
i had a pretty i would say kind of
magical childhood a bunch of young boys
about my age live down the street their
older sisters they all seem to have
older sisters who are about my sister's
age and so it was biking around and
skateboarding around playing baseball in
the street soccer swimming those are big
sports in the bay area um
and
we ate dinner together every night as a
family
you know we
we just kind of have a great life and
this is so this is like this
until you're around 13. yeah until i was
13 and then uh my parents split up
this was at a time in the 80s when i
think there was only one other kid in
school with divorced parents remember
these times right now it's you know it's
rampant but um and unfortunately they
didn't have the skills to handle it
properly so just imagine the rule book
of all the things parents aren't
supposed to do in a divorce
they basically systematically broke
every one of those my dad moved away um
and was overseas for a bit
and i was at home with my mom and she
struggled with the fracture of our
family in a major way this was right
about the time i hit puberty so it's
like throwing gasoline on fire right and
at the time i was a bit into
skateboarding um this was early days of
the bones brigade and
animal chin videos oh yeah okay so for
those of you that don't know you can
look it up and you get a sense but
um
i quickly got
into the skateboard community
and dropped everything else stopped
playing soccer
um
really stopped doing any kind of
structured school sports and things of
that sort and just got really into
skateboarding and the reason i got into
skateboarding was a you didn't need your
dad to go right soccer all the other
kids had dads there my dad wasn't there
it was kind of embarrassing um my mom
would have gone and i actually she would
have been the one shouting the loudest
and she's from jersey after all she's
got teeth um but uh you know
boy scouts wasn't gonna be my thing i
had some friends that went into eagle
scouts guys were playing lacrosse and
water polo and
skateboarding made a lot more sense um
and so what ended up happening was from
about 13
14 15 i started riding the 7f bus up to
san francisco there was a big gathering
of kids in justin hermann plaza the the
now infamous famous emb crowd the
embarcadero and this was a scene
a very nascent scene at the time of
young feral guys it was almost
exclusively guys
that hung out there all day long none of
them went to school
they drank
40 40 ounces and 40 ounces and
you know people were smoking weed and
drinking and skateboarding and there
were fights and people would rip off
tourists and it was it was it was kind
of a rough scene but there was also some
amazing skateboarding now
i never really liked drugs or alcohol so
i lucked out in that way for me it was
all about the skateboarding
and over the years i you know those
early years of going up there i got to
know a lot of guys
i would say about a third of them have
just to give you a sense of where it
went about a third of them have gone on
to found companies and do really well
i'm fortunate to be friendly with guys
like danny way i talked to you know i we
i remember the young rob dirty coming
through and a lot of guys went on to
create some impressive things
um and did very well about a third are
just living their lives and i don't know
where they are and about a full third of
the guys i knew from back then are dead
or in jail so i saw a lot of fights a
lot drinking a lot of a lot of guys got
their girlfriends pregnant it was a mix
you know
and
i suppose looking back in that time i
was
kind of aimless right i wasn't i wasn't
that good a skateboarder i want to be
really clear because the skateboarding
community is kind of ruthless in terms
of holding accountability uh almost as
much or probably as much as in the teams
right i have a number of friends from
the teams like you want to be very
careful with what what you imply what
one implies and so i don't want to imply
that i was fated to become a danny way
or in that i didn't have the skills
actually my body wasn't developed yet i
kept getting hurt i was skinny i kept
breaking feet and you know getting hurt
doing things that other guys could do
trivially so that was really tough and i
kept feeling like i couldn't keep up but
all my friends were there and um you
know i could throw out a bunch of names
but
i will mention some of the brighter
lights in that scene um you know i got
to see and witness great skateboarding
from a guy named mike carroll who's an
incredible skateboarder
and
his older brother greg carroll was kind
of a big brother to all these
parentless kids
i also learned that going to school was
an option for certain kids in the city
and here i was this kid from palo alto
and i thought well i just won't go
anymore well what ended up happening was
um
someone took notice and that i wasn't in
school and one day when i was back in
high school supposed to be ninth grade i
got called into the office and i was
sitting down and they were talking to me
you know how are things at home how are
things going they start probing there's
this guy sitting in the corner
and at some point i realize i think
they're going to take me away
so
that's what ended up happening you're
like how much school did you skip
yeah i could tell you more about the
curves in the gun high school parking
lot that i can tell you about any
classes i took up until about the 11th
grade
and in the 11th grade as the story goes
the only reason i really went there is
because there was a girl in the 12th
grade who was very beautiful who for
whatever reason had a lapse of judgment
and decided to go out with me and then
ended up being my girlfriend and uh and
i'm grateful to her because as the story
eventually goes you know that was the
reason i went off to college at all
although that didn't go well either um
so i wasn't going much at all and so my
grades were not good
um and your mom was just was she working
at this time what was she doing or she's
like just she was working allowing you
to yeah san francisco and skate all that
yeah allowing me an air quote um i i
remember uh
me and a guy who has gone on to do very
well as a documentary filmmaker jake
rosenberg he actually made the waiting
for lightning documentary about danny
way um and a couple other guys uh took
jacob's parents um
volvo wan vanigan or whatever those
wagons things i forget what those are i
don't know if they saw me those were
pretty cool we piled into that and we
all went to the reno nationals
for a week mid exams you know and just
kind of went out there i think we forged
signatures kids don't do this by the way
i'm a professor now i just want to say
for the record wait to get your tattoos
don't get the pull dear earrings for
reasons that don't even need explanation
and please please stay in school but um
went up there i i had mick managed to
get picked up by a wheel company and a
truck company what truck company thunder
trucks oh yeah and they put me on a
wheel company it was spitfire okay
so you were like
at least riding i would i couldn't
manage and getting free trucks that's
all you were getting wasn't it yeah so
there wasn't any money did they no so so
gosh because somewhere out there the
great jim fibo who owns deluxe which is
real skateboards and all anti-hero and
all that's probably listening thank you
jim he put me on out of sympathy i was
hanging around the factory deluxe so in
san francisco there's an amazing thing
about skateboarding that i'm guessing
most people don't know which was this
guy fausto vitello who started thrasher
magazine
and also independent trucks the great
independent trucks
and then he had a brilliant idea which
was why don't we just make a bunch of
companies thunder
spitfire venture well guess what folks
it's all the same company
and so kids you know you'd say oh i ride
thunders you know i ride in these it's
all irmaco that's where they poured the
stuff so
during those years of high school i
started going up to the factory and
hanging around the factory which is in
hunter's point which is the only truly
dangerous part of san francisco at least
at the time was the only truly dangerous
part
and you had to really watch yourself
there i saw a guy get pushed off a
motorcycle beaten up and his motorcycle
taking had a stop like midday
this is you know this is really rough
blocks and so you know here i was this
14 year old kid from palo alto getting a
pretty quick street education
started getting into fights a little bit
like i said fortunately didn't like
drugs or alcohol because
and you just randomly didn't like drugs
or alcohol was there something in your
parenting that made you feel that way
did you not like the loss of control
you know it was probably the drugs and
alcohol that i was exposed to so alcohol
made me feel kind of sedated as it does
as a forebrain inhibitor as we'd say in
neuroscience and the drugs at the time
people were mostly smoking weed and hash
taken lsd and mushrooms and none of that
really appealed i mean i do have a drug
and it's adrenaline
i love the clarity of mind and the
energy that comes from adrenaline and i
learned early on uh that beautiful but
very
uh dangerous edge where everything
is clear you have immense amounts of
energy and if
you can regulate a bit you're incredibly
calm and yet there's that readiness in
your body i'm sure as i describe this
many people and especially you guys will
know this feeling very well and it's a
very drug-like state right it's as
powerful as being in love and lust
all at once right it just it's that it's
a it's a beautiful tunnel and i fell in
love with it pretty early on and i also
love camaraderie right so my family
quickly became this big group of feral
kids and some older guys that um
really took care of all of us people
like going home at night are you like
squatting somewhere so not sleeping on
the street there were guys that slept in
embarcadero all the time i wasn't one of
those um i would stay at this guy ray
meyer's house he was a skateboarder and
uh but also a computer programmer and um
and this links back to that day where
they were gonna take me away i ended up
leaving to the city i ran away so so i
bolted i messed up your story that was
your freshman year that was that was my
freshman year or maybe early sophomore
year and you think these guys are going
to take me
right in some kind of whatever right so
i took off i went to ray's house i took
the bus up to san francisco i bought it
i think i said i had to use the bathroom
and then they went obviously they
weren't thinking
who they were dealing with
and i went to
rey's house he lived in his parents
attic
he was a computer programmer and also a
professional skateboarder um
one of the more stable people in that in
that world what year is this so this
would be 1989
and you know and i don't look anything
like well i had shaved head and you know
like you know maybe my hair might have
been dyed blue black or something and i
was just excited because
um you know i had whatever new pair of
kicks on and
was oh and the thunder thing if you rode
for thunderback then you got this shirt
that um is in my high school yearbook
and i saw it the other day which says uh
i ride for thunder trucks and all i got
was this lousy t-shirt and they only
made a few of them and
if you have one of those out there i'd
love to love to see it um
but
i went to raise and stayed there for a
bit and at one point he said you know
you can't stay here and i said why not
he said like i live at home with my
parents like this is weird you live in
my house you know you have to go home
so eventually i went back and then it
was no forgiveness they they took me to
a place up the peninsula which was
neither juvenile hall
nor a mental hospital nor jail it was
this kind of truant troubled kids place
and i'll never forget what they told us
they said okay there's an adult ward
over there and they're crazy
and then they're these little kids
younger than you i think it was younger
than 14 in this other building
and they're really disturbed
but you guys
you're normal you just have a lot of
problems and i thought to myself that's
definitely what they're telling the
people in the other buildings
but what happened was i was on a 72-hour
hold you know i hadn't done anything i
hadn't harmed anyone or myself so
and it was on the third day that one of
the counselors there who was a really
good guy you know we sometimes forget
that the people that do that kind of low
income work with kids like me back then
and kids now
probably in graduate school or something
a lot of these people have their own set
of problems and that's what led them
there and he sat down and he said listen
you can get out of here and go right
back to what you were doing
or you can
ask whether or not there's anything here
of value and at the time i was pretty
frightened
i was in this place my roommate
was this guy he looked like richard
ramirez the night stalker be guy if you
haven't seen that documentary on that'll
make you never want to live in los
angeles county
although richard ramirez was happy to
travel to kill you it turned out um
so i remember staying up at night and
being really
frightened i thought i don't know this
guy's going to try and harm me in any
kind of way turned out he was just
another sad story of somebody who was
just really really troubled he was
really oddly he was one of the bigger
more dangerous looking guys in the place
but he was cutting on the bottoms of his
feet so that no one would see
horrible met some good kids in there who
you know had different sets of problems
than me a lot of them drug problems some
of them had been molested fortunately i
never experienced that um
you know and
i was like wow like i'm in trouble right
i'm i'm
this is a long way from home it's also a
long way from embarcadero i called my
team manager i'm going to name him this
time because we're friends now his name
was steve is steve roogie shrugi
um
really good guy team manager from
thunder and
and again they put me on the flow team
out of sympathy thank you steve thanks
shrug and i called him and i said listen
they they got me behind lock and key
i don't know what to do
and he said you called me
and i said yeah and he said
bro you're the most normal guy i know
and i said i know and i'm in here and he
said no including me
i can't help you and i thought
wow
i'm in trouble so what ended up
happening
was i was let out
um
and as a condition of being let back in
school
i had to go to school i had to chart a
certain number of days and i was
assigned to do therapy twice a week
and at the time no one did or if they
did they didn't talk about therapy this
was before good will hunting this was
before
any kind of sense actually as a little
factoid i saw some statistics out of
stanford i think um
it was college-wide statistics in the
u.s that 10 years ago if you ask college
students how many of them go to or are
willing to explore therapy with
something like 14
now it's in excess of 90
we could argue whether or not that
reflects a good or a bad change but
anyway i was assigned to a guy who
was remarkable he really understood what
i was going through which
i have to imagine was just a stroke of
luck he
understood that my home life didn't have
structure that
at the time there was no strong paternal
role even though my dad's a pretty
strong-minded person has strong opinions
argentine after all um
just that i was i was spinning out and
he strongly discouraged me from doing
any drugs because he understood that
that was going to be a risk in my
current configuration
and he understood that i wasn't going to
get excited about school right away i
was always a reader so i was hit going
to tower books and reading about fitness
and reading about i love to read about
fitness i like history and i like to
read about sex so like not the porno
magazines but i would go read a lot like
sexual health i was really curious right
and then yeah young guy i was like oh
you know there's like protocols in here
you know let's learn this and about
fitness lifting weights like the
ellington darden books and the old you
know super slow movement stuff and mike
menser and actually um
what happened was
he said well what do you enjoy doing i
told him what my interests were and he
said well
you should exercise
he swims i think you know you don't
learn much about your therapist if it's
a appropriate therapy relationship so i
started swimming about a mile a night i
would run to this pool and hop the fence
because i'm a skateboarder i'm not going
to pay to go in during the day
fences are there to go over so i'd hop
the fence and i'd swim at night and then
i started running
and i started lifting weights and there
was a teacher at our school his name is
bob peters
big guy football player and he taught me
how to lift weights and then i started
running cross-country and
eventually i got a girlfriend
i'd done dating the skateboard way like
there were girls that would meet a
contest and that kind of thing but um a
really nice
smart
very sweet and kind girl whose dad
actually was a real blue collar guy how
much how much time has passed in this so
now i'm 16 or so i get my get my
driver's license sophomore now yeah
junior junior i'm a junior 16 because i
started school in the fall i'm a fall
baby so i was always the youngest in my
class what do you think how did this
therapist
actually connect to you
because
most of the things i see with kids
yours truly included when i was a kid a
super rebellious kid i didn't listen to
anybody like
that was you know any adult just didn't
know anything and
how did how do you think that person
made a connection with you
that's a great question no one's ever
asked me that
uh three things uh one was completely
non-verbal
uh he was physically fit i looked at him
and i thought
yeah i wouldn't mind looking like that
dude someday you know i was skinny and i
kept getting hurt skateboarding right
and i thought he wasn't really big and
yoked but he was tall and fit he had
good posture and the way he would greet
me was not he was kind i also remember
he had his uh so he was kind of a badass
yeah and he had his initials stitched
into his socks and i was like i guess he
probably makes good money doing this and
but but he wasn't um
there was no aristocracy about him he
just um
yeah he he looked like the kind of
person
i'd might want to be he looked like he
had his life together i also remember
that one day i came in and he said
you're smiling and i said yeah i ollied
the front eight and he said what does
that mean and i said well i'd do this
thing and he said why don't you show me
so we went downstairs i did push push
push i think i fell a few times then i
you know clicked down this front eight
we went upstairs and i was like wow
i think that's the first time that like
a grown man has cared about what i was
doing
um
and so there was that seed there um this
first time i remember that very clearly
now um and then
he i remember falling asleep in his
office a lot you know i must have been
pretty out of it at times
and then
when i met my girlfriend
um she was a year older i was a little
intimidated it's a whole other thing
when you're just traveling and i guess
they call you know you're just hooking
up with girls or whatever but when you
actually like somebody now they've got
something to lose right and
he really encouraged me to
he said
great advice by the way he said
when it comes to decision making ask her
opinion but i think she'll appreciate if
you just make the plans
i'm like all right so i would pick the
restaurant i would restaurant back then
i had no money right but in terms of um
you know so i used to run to my
girlfriend's house and wash her car she
had a bronco so i used to go there while
she was at church on sundays her dad was
a blue collar guy very little education
but had done okay in this country by
buying apartments and then taking care
of them himself one of these guys with i
remember he had a hundred keys on his
camera always a sign that somebody works
hard right um just remembering what all
those keys are too it's a memory task
what are you
what are you listening to for music
right now so as you start talking about
this
and i'm sitting here running through my
life and thinking about well what kind
of people had influence over me and
there was like a one of one guy that i
knew his older brother was a marine
corps was in the marine corps was a
marine corps drill instructor and you
know in my mind when i was like 13 years
old and i saw that i was like okay that
dude looks like he can kick ass and that
seems like a good thing to be able to do
and then you know as i started listening
to hardcore music and all of a sudden
you know
you you know henry rollins
and black flag is like doing push-ups
and you think okay it looks like i need
to start doing some push-ups and
and then other some other hardcore bands
where you know that the guys are working
out and i remember like my friends and
me were like okay well looks like we're
working out why because it's it's
interesting you brought up like the
kind of the posture in the stature
because when you're a kid and you're 13
and you weigh 138 pounds or whatever you
see someone that's like
190 pounds and they kind of look like
like you said that's kind of what i
think i should be doing even though it's
an interesting thing uh i heard i heard
i think it was either rollins or or ian
mackay mckay
and they were talking about seeing hr
from the bad brains
and hr from the bad brains
was like older
you know because they were around in the
in the late 70s but he had been an
athlete hr from the bad brains had been
an athlete in like high school he was
like a
uh a track athlete that's how come he
could do these flips but they like
looked at him and he looked like a man
like a jacked guy and they're like yes
and so that again you see these it's an
interesting thing that little physical
uh stature means something apparently
yeah these uh i guess you know the
psychologist we have to ask jordan you
know these masculine archetypes they you
get a seed going there you know it's in
there are a couple things one important
person that i failed to mention
the guy that sold me my first skateboard
was guy named gary hall
and
ran the skateboard shop and was an
interesting guy because he's very
physically strong plays hockey but also
skateboarded actually was a professional
skateboarder in the kind of late 70s
early 80s
he took early on when he saw me going
off the rails
because i used to skateboard with him a
lot uh he said listen your parents are
going through a lot
whatever you do do not mess your life up
by not going to school not getting a job
doing all these things so i didn't
follow his advice as well as i could
have but gary and i have remained close
friends for kind i can't even count the
years now more than 35 years
a little little story here he uh he's
actually the operations manager for my
laboratory at stanford and he's a very
put-together guy if you walk by pass him
on the street you won't even know he
skateboards um
but he was very into
you know for instance i've never seen a
leaf on his front lawn
it's edged perfectly my laboratory i'm
very proud to say and thank you gary has
passed every single inspection with 100
percent
nobody does that
like they're they're gonna find
something and he makes sure they don't
and you know so there were examples of
people like that or my therapist but
that
that i thought wow i would love to be
like that person but i somehow couldn't
find the internal organization to do it
uh you asked about music
one thing that was just terrible about
the early 90s about skateboarding it was
the era of little wheels and people
wearing really baggy clothes with you
know bright colors with like fruit salad
on the front
and it would be a few years before the
danny ways and those guys would come in
like blasting slayer and ac dc and
jumping over the great wall of china and
really bringing it was like it was
almost like we hadn't everyone it was
like a pre-pubertal phase of
skateboarding which then eventually went
through puberty and some incredible
stuff happened
um so the music at the time that kids in
my high school were listening to was
also to me was just dreadful no
disrespect to anybody but i mean people
were like hacky sacking and listening to
fish
and
they are you know
sure the grateful dead would play at
frosty amphitheater at stanford and we'd
go over there for other reasons you know
but it just patoolly smell and like none
of that stuff resonated for me
and then
what happened was i was 14 and jim thibo
of deluxe and
has great fame and
he's a very quiet humble guy but he's
he's sort of the secret parent of all
skateboarding you can look him up he's a
very important figure still to this day
and a great person i was up at
spitfire thunder place was called deluxe
low warehouse
and he gave me a tape
and it was a band called crimp shrine
which is an east bay punk band
and
that led me to the discovery of the
great operation ivy
then operation ivy was featured in the
first h street video the entire album of
27 songs and operation ivy jesse
michaels and tim armstrong which is now
of rancid fame and transplants with
travis barker okay and on and on and on
so
when i heard operation ivy
i was like wow
i mean i can still feel it in my body
now just the i'm not going to try and
sing it but jesse was like you know i
got no it was just so the energy was so
much like that's me
that that that's me it's like seeing
someone on the street that looks just
like you and it's a feeling inside you
that's me and then operation i me ivy i
went to gym and i said what where where
can i get more of this and you know if
you like that stiff little fingers and i
was like stiff little fingers yeah it
was good
unfortunately operation iv one album
yeah so that they had that energy ep
that was really long yeah they broke up
because they were a bunch of teenagers
touring and they had this huge success
now fortunately that led to the great i
mean my favorite band of all time and
tremendous respect and love and
admiration and appreciation for rancid
so if you were in my mind if you were
going to design
a punk band or a band of any kind you'd
have a bullet belted mohawk guy up front
that's tim with a lift pin like he
actually is missing you know that front
tooth
and then you'd have an amazing bass
player like matt freeman who's like a
big
you know
car car guy and then you'd have a
drummer like brett reed who actually
used to skateboard with us at the
embarcadero i remember thinking like no
one had tattoos back then it was what we
call the autoclave days now they use
disposable needles back then it was
actually dangerous because you weren't
sure if they actually ran the autoclave
or if they were sober while they did it
and he had a huge spider tattoo on his
chest and we were like whoa that's a
commitment
and um and then you'd have lars
fredrickson an oy guy
right from the south bay from san jose
and i remember the first time i heard
rancid which was first a three-piece and
then when they added lars and i thought
this is like operation ivy graduated
and went to college which none of those
guys did they they get what i'm talking
about but just so much energy like the
albums would open with
and
once again i thought and i was maturing
right i'd gone through i was going
through puberty and i thought
this
this is this is it and actually i have
to say that throughout my entire life
every rancid album has tracked to a
particular five-year phase of my life
and i could go on and on about this and
i won't but i own every b track
every outtake ever i mean
i've even got a song by ransom called
the sentence which nobody knows which is
queued up in my phone so that if i'm on
a plane it starts to go down as much as
i love the people in my life i'm
plugging in and i'm going down listening
to the sentence so that was all during
those years and
and then the fitness thing really took
off because of this
my guy uh football coach
bob peters and then
because my girlfriend at the time she
was a year older she had dated a guy
that someone showed me a picture of him
he was this big football player from the
other high school and i was you know six
foot tall at that time 150 pounds i oh
my goodness like she must think i'm a
dental floss right so i started doing my
sit-ups and my push-ups and then i
started lifting cans of soup like
classic thing and then i saw an ad from
mike menser in a magazine and i paid
i
i was working at the time so i started
working at a cafe
you know bussing tables and things like
that and i got a program from mike
menser and got on the phone with him and
he said listen he got on the phone with
mike i paid him yeah oh i paid him and
he
explained high intensity training and
bringing muscles to failure and so i
started doing this thing of training
once every day how much did that cost
it's probably about a hundred bucks at
the time that's crazy it's been a huge
investment mike that's a huge investment
for me um
how many people did he do that for that
was this is indiscriminate i remember i
had to go get a um i had to go to
western union and send him western union
no one that's not it was great
and my mother i remember when he called
she's like why is this grown man calling
you um
and i started doing the you know once
ever
train rest two days train rest two days
and my body just responded like crazy to
that so i was eating and training and
just growing like a weed and as most
people know when you're untrained and
you start training even
a slight you know training hard you just
grow and when you're how old i was so
that was 17 19. your body's just
seething with testosterone yeah so from
hgh or whatever everything i mean from
and uh
from the 16 until i guess when i started
i eventually followed that high school
girlfriend off to college i went from
150 pounds to 215 in a period of about
you know three three years or so
um it wasn't all solid but it was solid
enough i still had the baby fat the
round round dish face but um and i was
sprinting and lifting and then basically
and are you now back in school are you
paying attention in school so here
here's the irony um
uh
i got a girlfriend i dyed my hair back
to a normal color
i started wearing flannels instead of
the skateboard gear
oh wait you dressed like a skateboarder
in the in the 90s like you were wearing
those big jeans and stuff there are
photos of those out there there are a
few videos i know
i didn't wear the super baggy stuff i i
got out before that you're danger
clothes that was dangerous i was danger
close it's true very
embarrassing
garb which is coming back like for me in
like i guess i was a generation before
that right because i guess i'm five
years older six years older than you so
like when i got thrasher magazine it was
like nothing but like hardcore
and metal and matter of fact my name
with my subscription to thrasher
magazine
for whatever reason the way i wrote my
name when i mailed in the thing
they sent it to volco willing
the way i wrote my videos so
somewhere they got files on me at
thrasher magazine they used to send the
magazine to volca willing but there
would know
it was like
hardcore and
that was it man it was it was total
rebellion it was absolute rebellion and
that's the way and
that's where you discovered music yeah
that's where i got that's where i picked
up a lot of music and
started seeing that and to having that
attitude and that rebellious attitude
has suited me very well for my whole
life um
most most of the time it's worked out
alright sometimes been a little bit much
but
but yeah then then wait so i joined the
navy
and that's when you know unfortunately
for you you got roped into big baggy
pants
there was
it was pretty bad the um
yeah well and i stopped skateboarding
and started working out and i got into
muay thai okay uh started actually
opening the doors on this muay thai
place so they
let me train there for free i was in san
jose i think it still exists at muay
thai academy and it was interesting
there were a lot of cops that trained
there and bodyguard training they had
some weapons training so now i'm hanging
around with a different group of guys um
still liked fighting still had a lot of
aggression but i was i wasn't
skateboarding i was hanging out with my
girlfriend you ever get your ass beat in
these fights um you know i'm lucky that
over the years i've never been knocked
down or knocked out but i've definitely
taken hits
and um you know there's that i always
say the amazing thing about adrenaline
is that
when you get in a fight it's amazing how
little it hurts during the fight and how
much it hurts afterward
so definitely experience the clarity of
getting hit and feeling ultra clear and
again i don't recommend it to people
especially as you've pointed out many
times on your podcast and i appreciate
that you do this you know you can hit
someone just right and it's all fair and
square and they can you know plug and
kill you or the person next to you and
or
and this i'll tell a story
that uh that unfortunately happened you
know when i went off basically i went
off to college because the girlfriend
went to college
she went to uc santa barbara and i was
going down there my senior year
literally sleeping in my car in the
parking lot she was my family wait so
your senior year of high school yeah so
she's already in college you know so
what happened was she was a year ahead
of me so in my junior year i started
hanging out with her you asked if i was
going to school i was going i was
dressing the part more of a normal
person but
unfortunately i was still
really challenged in school i didn't
have the skills i hadn't barely barely
gone in the early years so i was reading
and i was smart enough to kind of get by
but i wasn't doing very well
and i thought what am i going to do with
myself and she's going to college soon
i'm sure and i decided to take fire
science classes down at mission college
become a firefighter i like hanging out
with a bunch of dudes and lifting
weights and i love the camaraderie and i
want to make a living and um you know
she's the one drives the bronco i don't
even have a car how am i going to get a
car or truck you know i mean how am i
going to live and so i started thinking
about my future a bit but that was as
far as i was thinking out
then i somehow managed to graduate
don't ask me how um and i and she went
off to college and so in that year where
she was a year ahead of me and i was a
senior i was going down to santa barbara
to visit her quite a lot sleeping in the
parking lot getting into mischief of
various kinds but basically just want to
be as close to her as i could
and then i decided i would apply to
college and the reason was there was a
counselor admission who said well you
know you can go into the fire service
without a college degree but if you have
a college degree there are some
opportunities that open up for you in
there that you wouldn't have otherwise
so i was still in therapy talked to my
therapist i think it'd be a good idea
you seem to have a mind that wants to
consume a lot of knowledge
so
i took the sat and by some stroke of
luck i
you know i
broke a thousand which you know for gun
high school would be considered like the
low end because everyone there is like
you know perfect this is the only score
that was acceptable and then there was
me you know and i wrote my college
entrance essay saying that i'd like to
run a station house someday and become a
firefighter i told a little bit of my
story it wasn't a sob story or this and
that you know i just told my story and i
got in
so i go to uc santa barbara uh she's now
living off campus i'm staying with her i
think i had her bed in the dorms i show
up with wait you got into uc santa
barbara i did okay sweet yeah which at
the time i think the standards for
getting in were were lower than they are
now it's super competitive all ucs now
but got in
and it was a total disaster uh
getting in fights i got the lifting
weights part down um i would go for runs
i was training at muay thai gym downtown
found someone who would hold bags for me
and would spar with me a little bit
even made some money teaching some
self-defense classes on campus and
things like that
you know and the girlfriend and i are
now starting to fracture mostly because
i was like wow there are a lot of other
attractive women here and not good i
will say this guys if there's a woman
who is really beautiful dedicated sweet
and kind and it's early it is worth
investing in those early relationships
and going through some developmental
milestones together if you think you'd
have to break up just to explore think
twice talk to me first because
she would have been a great choice but i
was distracted
and then i started i got thrown out of
the dorms for fighting i had a guy
you're not you don't drink still
i drank a little bit the first year and
then you know i
not so much for me it was i've never
really needed to drink so if i go out
listen to music i was still going to
punk rock shows always always always um
and i'd go to parties and you know it
was fun you know people were drinking
and having a good time but i wasn't
really into drinking and
uh i could say whatever i wanted to say
without it i think i just always had
that kind of wild side in me that i
didn't need to drink in order to you're
still getting in fights even though
you're not drinking because drinking
leads to a lot of fighting yeah so i
don't have that excuse um
the
yeah guy
pulled a fire alarm in our building
because he was done with finals and he
was celebrating i remember wake jumping
out of bed because i needed my sleep
because you grow when you sleep right
running out there and grabbing him and
hitting him those kinds of that kind of
stupidity he stuck a key through my
cheek it was actually this cheek i
remember thinking someone said you have
blood on your face i said he's got his
blood on my face no you're bleeding this
kind of thing just young stupidity 19
years old or 18 years old
and then uh what happened was
that summer she moved home
and i decided to stay in that little
town of isla vista
and
i didn't pay rent i just that
skateboarder just these none of these
houses are locked just stay in one so i
was staying in one i was delivering
bagels for the bagel cafe driving the
little truck and then 4 30 in the
morning come home sleep get up and go
find a barbecue and and hang out
skateboard
do whatever work out and it was fourth
of july 1994 remember this very well
and we went to go the store to pick up
some stakes we were driving back and
there were some guys coming out of the
house with a bunch of stuff surfboards
skateboards and one of the guys in our
car
said the usual thing he said oh let's
get him let's beat him up and i was like
no no that's not how you do it right if
you just say i'm going to beat you up
this is the bad tactics right here i'm
talking to you guys about fighting this
is amusing it also is the first podcast
i've ever been in except the one with
joe ring where i'm the smallest person
in the room
joe's a big guys you know he's thick so
um
so
what ended up happening is there was a
big fight between a bunch of guys and us
and the whole thing and it was like
knives and bottles and it worked out in
the sense that no one got cut or killed
the police showed up and i'll never
forget this the cop came up to me and he
said um
a big crowded assembled and people were
and i'd done wait were these guys when
they were walking were they were they
jacking stuff yeah they were stealing
okay so they were stealing they were
stealing stuff and you know and i hit a
guy in the whole thing and like and i
ended up on my feet and then it was a
huge crowd and a couple guys i was with
ran away he was like let's get them but
then when they come out with bottles and
knives it's like
out of town and so
um police showed up and i'll never
forget this the cop said um good job
and i remember feeling
just the worst sunken feeling in my
stomach i thought like good job i mean
first i just it all kind of
fell into place it's like i'm 19.
girlfriend's gone
i don't have a job i'm not doing well in
school i'm getting i'd actually been
thrown out of the dorms for fighting
um and some other just stupidity
and you know i'm getting in fights
i could have cut someone someone could
cut me i could be i could be dead or in
jail it could be like one of the the
stories from embarcadero over the guys
that didn't make it that didn't
skateboard they just hung out drinking
and partying and fighting all day right
and
i remember going back to my place that
night and thinking this is it like this
is the line i need to do something i'm
basically a loser and i was i was a
total loser
and i thought what am i going to do well
i had gotten c minuses and d's in all my
classes up until then at santa barbara
barely finished high school
and so i decided to take a leave of
absence i did not drop out i took a
leave of absence i moved home
and i went to foothill college community
college and i didn't talk to any of my
old friends from the skateboarding world
it was just too familiar with a bunch of
things
i
didn't talk to my family
i lived in a little apartment and i just
started
studying i thought
what am i good at okay i can remember
things pretty well i like to read
this is it and i remember thinking my
dad's an academic so i thought you know
i'm not going to do this that'll just
validate you know what he does and his
choices i thought well that's stupid
right so
i started working and i did okay in my
courses took art history took biology
took psychology
then i went back to santa barbara
and
i had this reputation in santa barbara
at that time as a guy that was fun to
have at parties because something fun
was going to happen you know something
wild was going to happen or there'd be a
big fight you know you're the guy
getting nosed up to the front to take
the damage or do the damage
for entertain other people's
entertainment
so i went back and i lived in the studio
plaza apartments i still have a photo of
that door because it has great meaning
for me i lived in the corner there i
lifted weights
i studied like a maniac and i did not
drink or party except once a month i'd
allow myself to go out and
and i would really you know
i would just stay out all night partying
but over time what i realized is i
didn't like it because then it made the
rest of the week that much harder
so in those years i discovered a guy an
amazing person his name was harry
carlisle former navy guy incidentally
ran a laboratory and he and taught
classes and he was teaching
about at the time there was no
neuroscience he was teaching about
psychology and biology they called it
biopsychology and about how depression
was based on these things called
neurotransmitters and schizophrenia
which i'd seen some of in this you know
in my years
wait
neuroscience didn't exist at this time
there was no field of neuroscience there
was neurochemistry physiology but so
this is the mid-90s now okay
94 95 or so
and he was teaching about the brain and
how it works and then he was talking
about thermal regulation and he was
talking about why people die at raves he
said i heard of these things called
raves and the people taking this drug
and he break down the structure of mdma
ecstasy and explain how it would disrupt
the hypothalamus in one's perception of
how hot it was and this is why people
would overheat even if they were pouring
water on themselves as a little
scientific factoid when you're
overheating in the desert or while
training you might think i'll put a cold
towel over my head or the back of my
neck well that's like putting a cold
towel on a thermostat because you have a
thermostat in your brain what happens
when you put a coal towel on the
thermostat the thermostat turns on the
heat that's how you overheat and die
turns out the best way to dump heat is
through the palms of your hands and the
bottoms of your feet you have a special
venous portal called avas where you can
dump heat so if you want to cool off
fast in fact you can save your life by
getting your the bottoms of your bare
feet or the palms of your hands into
cool water we can talk about how this
can be leveraged for training because
there's some amazing research on this
so i was learning about thermal
regulation and i was learning about
drugs of abuse and
why some of my friends were addicts
probably was these pathways related to
dopamine and etc etc i thought
well who is this guy so i started
talking to him and he drove a black
truck
and he was in shape
and i thought i want to be like this guy
and so i started hanging around his lab
and he would drink black coffee
and
he let me listen to whatever music i
wanted after hours and we started doing
experiments i started working in a
laboratory and he pulled me aside at one
point and he said you know you seem to
have some proficiency for this
you know if you go to graduate school
they'll pay you
i thought they pay you to do this and he
said yeah they'll pay you to do it he
didn't tell me how much they pay you
but basically what happened was make a
long story short no more fighting was
never into the drugs or alcohol as i
mentioned did not get back together with
a girlfriend
but i went from a cd student to a
straight a student i got a b plus my
senior year and it still pisses me off
but that was in neuroanatomy which is
now what i teach to medical students it
became my favorite topic i went on to
take multiple courses and that's always
that one thing that didn't quite get you
i think dan gable talks about this in
wrestling it's the one guy that i think
in his word gum beat out and then pinned
him or beat him by points it's that one
guy that teaches you the most
right so i became a straight a student
went on to you know graduate with honors
went to graduate school first at
berkeley and then did my phd and then my
postdoc at stanford and so on and so
forth i will say over the years i kept
in touch with various people in the
skateboard community
and then when i was a post-doc which is
kind of like a residency between your
phd and professorship
i was at stanford and i was working
extremely hard i've always had a
capacity to to work long hours actually
i have a hope the insurance companies
don't mind me saying this but it would
only hurt me i have a mutation
in a an adrenal related gene so i
probably make a little bit i probably
have the capacity to make a little bit
more adrenaline than most i can get by
on very little sleep at least for a
couple nights i'm guessing a lot of team
guys might have this it's a pretty
common mutation about 12 percent of
males have it so i can do fine with one
night no sleep second night i'm kind of
falling apart a bit
but if i need to take a one hour nap and
bounce right back in i'm good i don't
recommend it i try and get my good sleep
now but um so i was just work work work
lift lift lift run run run
just repeat
so you so you graduate from
from santa barbara yeah that's right and
then you go from there to berkeley i go
to berkeley and the first week at
berkeley rance is playing at the greek
theater oh how are you so i'm there and
i'm still doing that i'm still in it but
i'm not but i'm the guy now on the side
you know sidelines just happy to be
there and um and then eventually i did
my phd my grad advisor moved so i went
up to davis
and i worked for an incredible woman up
there who was just a really really good
scientist
she was just extremely rigorous gave me
a lab and some keys to the lab showed me
where things were and said listen i'm
going to have a couple kids in the next
few years and the best thing i can do
for you is to be available when you need
me but figure it out don't burn the lab
down don't kill yourself go for it and
so it's like you're kidding me this is
there was no one else in there i thought
and this was perfect
tin foil on the windows locked the doors
ranted blasting all day ignore the
knocks on the door and just do
experiments experiments experiments we
published 10 papers together what kind
of experiments okay so give me an
example so at the time i'm thinking like
eighth grade i was putting like hydrogen
peroxide yeah something
yeah a little disclaimer now my
laboratory mainly focuses on humans but
the time we're using animal models at
the time and listen i have mixed
feelings about this was the time we were
doing experiments on
carnivores in
including cats and ferrets because they
have a visual system that's very
immature so we were studying
neuroplasticity which is the brain's
ability to change in response to
experience really trying to define
fundamental principles that do carry
over to humans
and
we were i was also there's a primate
center at davis we're doing work on
non-human primates macaque monkeys
big dangerous monkeys that you wouldn't
want to be left alone with but i was
working trying to understand embryonic
development so working on fetal macaques
so getting to do surgeries on fetal
macaques and and i loved it i loved
working with my hands i also discovered
something in science which sitting and
learning from books is great but i have
a lot of energy and i need to put that
someplace
and
doing careful dissections for hours and
hours was a great way to chan i learned
how to take all that energy that
normally would go into big movements and
just channel it into total focus i could
spend
eight hours down the microscope just
doing dissections and listening to music
and doing dissections in fact i used to
play this game where i try and get as
ramped up and alert as possible by
listening to music and drinking coffee
and then just do my dissections as
slowly as possible
as to all this crazy stuff
and
in those years i was still going to
shows there was a place up in um in
sacramento rough place
and i started going to see roger murray
in the disasters play
and uh you know as you know he's the
agnostic front roger it's only fair to
call him the great roger murray i'd go
to these shows where i was legitimately
afraid
you know
at that point last thing i wanna do is
get into a fight i'm just legitimately
afraid of what's gonna happen um this
was at a place called the boardwalk and
there was a place up on broadway the
colonial theater and they would do
mexican wrestling one night with the
hands dipped in glass
and then they would do punk rock shows i
got to see the transplants which is tim
armstrong travis barker and bands like
that play in a little tiny theater and i
thought
life is so good i'm working on my phd
we're publishing papers i still have
arms in this world although i didn't
know any of the characters
and then eventually i graduated
i got my phd and went and did a postdoc
at stanford and that was a problem i was
back in the early location there's this
thing in neuroscience called condition
place preference where something really
good happens for you someplace you
really like it and good and your body
goes into a great state when you're
there there's also condition place
aversion and here i am back in palo alto
and think gosh like this was a kind of a
dark place for me forget the
well-trimmed lawns and everything this
place is not i'm i'm starting to get
depressed so i moved to san francisco
and
one day i got this idea i thought wait a
second thrasher is right over the hill
why aren't i there so i have a friend
that was at a sibling magazine to
thrasher which is slap magazine it's now
closed up but a guy named mark whiteley
that i grew up with who now works for
apple called up mark and said hey you
know what
can i do some work for you guys he said
sure so do you know how to take photos
and i said sure that's not true but i
said i know how to take a photo so
um
so he said well you can always do music
stuff
so i started going to shows and taking
pictures and doing write-ups and
traveling a little bit for that for some
extra cash what year is this
2005-2010 so damn so there's some
publications in thrasher people can you
might be able to find them i don't know
so i covered moraine the disasters
bouncing souls love those guys
um i remember when roger murray went to
jail in the i don't forget what year it
was but i remember going to they would
have like benefit shows to raise money
to get because i don't know
him
i was down for the call so i can tell
you that much well the thing about
rogers that's really interesting and i
don't even know if you'd remember who i
was i became friendly with i think it
was his bass player rhys there's a um
disaster is a great band by the way i
love the band like the janey hawk song
and some of those are just amazing songs
and i remember um
you seeing moray when i was a kid
and his neck
was like i used to have a bulldog
mastiff a few years ago costillons and
costello never lifted weights right but
roger's neck is huge right and this is a
guy that probably didn't lift weights
it's just huge because he's just born
that way
um i think you know it's like you guys
are big dudes it's like there's certain
people that your wrists are thick neck
is big
and i've been letting murray and like
murray could sing happy birthday and
he'll be like
you know it's just his voice it just
comes from so deep inside his body just
it's just
beautiful and amazing to see what he can
do
and the physicality of it and so i did a
thing for thrasher on murray in the
disaster did some transplant stuff
bouncing souls was going to shows
getting 500 to a thousand bucks per
article which at the time as a postdoc
feel pretty good because i you know life
was expensive and when you're a postdoc
or graduate student you're not making
much money and this is because at this
time you're also at stanford you said
that's right doing what
it's a post-doc so when you finish your
phd you typically do five years where
it's just pure research before you go
get hopefully get a professorship so i
would go to shows stay up most of the
night then come back to stanford
sleep under my bench wake up and start
doing experiments
and um
shower at the gym
and so and this is the thing you know
those old habits die hard you said a lot
of those are as you mentioned a lot of
those early years the decision making
and the habits um carry over and
fortunately i was able to to move the
the good ones forward the good habits
that is so when i was a phd student i
thought why pay rent
there's a building here with a shower it
was a cage wash shower for the monkeys
but they never used it so i would shower
in there or at the gym i'd brush my
teeth in the sink and i'd sleep there i
did that also
as a postdoc and i confess even
eventually what happened was i finished
my postdoc i was hired as a
what they call pre-tenure professor
assistant professor at uc san diego i
got a house because at the time when
houses down here were it was in normal
heights and it was relatively
inexpensive
so went from no responsibility no
property no nothing i had a house a
bulldog and a laboratory of my own
but and this was at uc san diego uc san
diego so this would be 2011 and i
thought well
the commute from normal heights to uc
san diego is pretty far so let me just
put a couch in my office the dog was
fine there's a field outside where i can
take him out and so i would sleep in lab
you know two nights a week
and then eventually and i did well there
my lab i'm proud to say and this the
credit really goes to the people very
hard working published good papers had
grants and my career really took off in
neuroscience and
then eventually i was recruited back to
stanford as a tenured professor which is
where i've been now for about seven
years and even then when i got back i
thought
well why
the housing in the bay area is crazy i
looked at costello my bulldog was like
how do we move back into the lab so i
stayed there until someone finally came
along and said this sends the wrong
message i said well it actually sends
the message that there should be better
housing for faculty but um
i saved some money that way so that i
was able to eventually buy a small home
so over the years it's been consistently
the same themes
work hard
train
keep out of
any kind of mischief
which is easy to do now i value so many
things in my life i wouldn't want to do
that but
and then just try and bring the spirit
of skateboarding and punk rock music to
the whole thing uh of science and then
the the piece of that where it kind of
wraps around is that
a few years ago i decided uh i'd write a
book but then i decided i didn't want to
write a book and so i started going on
podcasts joe and ferris and and the
others and
you know there was this
guy lex friedman of course and he said
maybe we should start a podcast so i
started the podcast and
when i did it i looked to a couple of
communities i thought who can just put
things together really well that really
understand aesthetics and the diy
you know do-it-yourself kind of mantra
and get it right and so i looked to a
guy named rob moore who produces the
fight podcast with teddy atlas
and who comes from the world of
pr but also um knows a lot about the
fight world
and i went to mike blaiback who's a
famous skateboard photographer took the
pictures of danny wage jump in the great
wall of china dc shoes nike
skateboarding and mike just knows how to
do the kind of photographs that i like
which are black and white and very
you know look there's a there's a common
theme
and
so that's the the podcast and um you
know people always ask why do you always
wear a black shirt and you know i've
been wearing a black shirt to work for
25 years this isn't a costume
for the podcast i've just always
addressed this way done it this way and
the wonderful thing about social media
is you get in touch with people like you
um and i should say for me it's a real
honor to be here because we're not 2015
20 15 16
um i was living with my girlfriend at
the time we met in san diego
my ex-girlfriend now but we're in good
terms so i can tell this story and there
was a kind of weird navy seal theme in
our household because the guy she had
been with before was a team guy uh-oh
right
and so it was like i'm back in high
school again you know this guy's i won't
say who it is but he seems like a really
nice guy but
team guy and she was doing crossfit with
a bunch of team guys and stuff here i am
like the dweeby scientist you know i
lift weights and do all that but you
know our first part her first party or
gathering where all these guys come over
i'm like once again i'm the smallest
person in the room i'm a scientist i'm
used to being the biggest guy in the
room smallest guy in the room real good
guys as you as you all are
um
but what ended up happening was
i was a avid tim ferriss podcast
listener and i remember looking at the
picture
and it was your
your grill looking at me and i showed
her and i said uh i said
this guy it was just on tim ferriss and
he goes well if you were going to draw a
team guy that's the guy you'd draw
and i thought well there's a lot behind
that statement let's not i'm not going
to ask why um so in any case uh
i love that podcast and it was you know
when i lived here in san diego i was
involved a little bit in
fitness and martial arts at a real
superficial level and you guys would
come in and um you know beat everybody
up and uh and then go go off laughing
and smiling and uh leave the rest of us
mere mortals to think about what just
happened no just kidding basically what
you guys would do would come in and take
over bars well that's yeah um and uh
and so i learned which bars not to drink
at not because i was gonna get into any
mischief with anybody i know you know
but because um you know they're only uh
so
how do i say this correctly
it's a it's a uh
resource allocation issue
so
so anyway i've been running my lab for a
long time now the podcast is a newer
thing we've had about a year and a half
but the themes of skateboarding punk
rock music they they are not just part
of it they're i think this will make
sense to you guys is it uh they're
they're in me right that they're they're
wired into my nervous system and i'm
feel really honored that to be here and
also that the skateboard community has
kind of uh re-embraced me with open arms
and in touch with a lot of those guys
tony hawk danny way mike blayback and
there's so many names and and people and
um
it's an amazing community because
skateboarding and punk rock music i
don't know about other things because
that's only what i know but
odd
but really special communities because
you can be nine years old and hanging
out with people in their 30s
and so you can learn a lot for better
for worse but it's also a community that
especially more and more is really
starting to they take care of each other
in a way that i think
is probably not present in other
communities it can be harsh too i mean
if you screw up they're gonna let
everybody know
so maybe some parallels with the teams
yeah yeah
uh
so that kind of brings us through your
sort of educational system and what
you've been learning along the way and
um
i would i want to grab some of that
knowledge you know of of what you've
learned about
you know how to be better how to be
smarter how to be stronger how to be
faster how to be more healthy
because all those things are things that
you know
i've been trying to do my whole life as
well
and uh obviously not done it on a
academic level but really through trial
and error and and also being surrounded
by a bunch of people that were always
you know had that had that same kind of
mindset we were very lucky in the seal
teams we had guys
that would go way down the rabbit hole
on some random form of exercise or some
random diet or what you some random
thing that it would get spread and and
then we really i would say around maybe
2005 2006 we started really bringing in
professionals actually it was earlier
than that we'd always bring in
professionals but so we'd bring in
professionals that were really good at
their designated field so i feel like i
got very lucky with some of that as well
but um obviously you're you're a living
experiment on this stuff and then you
have the academics to back it up so
let's talk about some of this stuff um
and i've listened to a bunch of your
stuff like you know and and anyone that
wants to go deep on this
trust me you can go deep listening to
your podcast i mean you can go
real deep yeah i always say if nothing
else will cure insomnia because
you listen to it you might not nod out
but um yeah we do go detailed i've had
the great fortune of of working with
some units in special operations doing
uh talking about physiology and using
physiology
yeah these are tools that over the years
i've used but
most of what we cover on the podcast and
what we can talk about now
are things that come from other
laboratories this is one thing i truly
enjoy is talking about my own work in
research but a lot of what has been
wonderful for me is bringing on expert
guests and connecting with people who
are experts say in thermal regulation
something is i mean the ability to
adjust one's temperature through some
dedicated actions
is the difference between being able to
do more work or no more work
physically and mentally we talk about
that
but in terms of
things that really enhance performance
we can talk about the what i there are
two ways to think about biology one are
modulators and the others are mediators
so there are some things that you can do
that will strongly modulate your ability
to do lots of other things let's just
give an example if i sleep deprive echo
for two days his ability to focus is
going to be diminished relative to what
it would be if he had slept well for for
for two nights
why well
sleep and its various outputs modulate
attention but it doesn't mediate to
tension
you can't really use sleep in in real
time to enhance attention okay a fire
alarm will modulate my attention but it
doesn't mediate it so we can talk about
modulators and mediators and the
important thing to understand is that
there are certain foundational behaviors
do's and don'ts that set the stage for
you to be better at everything so a lot
of times people say how can i lift more
focus better
remember things better say well let's
think about the foundation of that and
that's always going to come back to two
elements
and that's sleep and what i call
non-sleep deep rest
so sleep is the fundamental
practice or part of our 24 hour cycle
where if you don't get it on a
consistent basis you
are down regulating your ability to do
everything right metabolism is screwed
up immune system is screwed up etc etc
however
it is not the case if you get a one
night's bad sleep or that if you're not
sleeping perfectly that you can't
perform well but let's talk about sleep
and just because i think it's important
the goal for most people unless you're
pulling vampire shifts on on deployment
or you're a shift worker and thank you
shift workers we'll talk about shift
work
you should try and get really good sleep
eighty percent of the time eight percent
of the nights of your life the other
twenty percent i hope you're not getting
good sleep for good reasons that you
enjoy
but the point is that there are a couple
things that you can do first of all
every cell in your body has a circadian
rhythm meaning every cell has a 24
24-hour circadian clock that's regulated
by genes think of these your body as a
bunch of millions of clocks and need to
align those clocks to a single time this
is why when you travel overseas your gut
goes off or it's more easy
you more easily you get sick or your
thinking isn't quite right that the
clocks aren't in alignment they're not
entrained as we say
number one practice for everything sleep
especially is try and get some natural
light in your eyes within an hour of
waking up if you wake up before the sun
turn on a bunch of bright lights and
then get sunlight in your eyes once it
comes out if there's dense cloud cover
there are still more photons light
energy coming through that cloud cover
than there are coming from artificial
lights so try and get five to ten
minutes without sunglasses outside in
the morning once the sun is out
most days if not all days this has an
outsized effect on a number of things
first of all it modulates the timing of
what's called the cortisol pulse once
every 24 hours you're going to get a
boost in cortisol big spike in cortisol
it's a healthy boost it sets your
temperature rhythm in motion sets your
level of alertness your level of focus
and your mood you want that cortisol
pulse to happen as early in the day as
once what's triggering the cortisol
pulse the cortisol pulse is naturally
entrained by these genetic programs to
happen once every 24 hours but light
will
anchor it to the period where you see
bright light got it a late-shifted
cortisol pulse so imagine the kid that
wakes up and spends the morning in bed
or you're spending the morning bedding
you're texting or you're indoors and
you're typing on the computer that's not
enough light to accomplish what i'm
talking about and then you go outside
around noon or one you're in what's
called the circadian dead zone which is
the time in which light arriving at the
eyes can do certain things but it can't
time this pulse that means that cortisol
pulse is going to come in the afternoon
which means that your temperature rhythm
is going to be shifted late and that's
actually a signature of depression and
anxiety and
difficulty falling asleep these are from
studies done by the great robert
sapolsky and david spiegel my colleagues
at stanford
so you want that
increase in
cortisol to happen early in the day
basically you wake up because your
temperature goes up so let me ask you
this i have a sense for you what time do
you wake up
typically
generally between
well between 4 15 and 4 30. okay so for
most people it's gonna be a little bit
later
probably but for you that means so
you're waking up
if it's because of an alarm it's because
of an alarm but you're if that's your
natural wake-up time now without an
alarm that means that
your temperature is starting to rise at
that time that's why you wake up that
temperature increase triggers that
cortisol release
now
and that's why some people wake up right
before their alarm clock it's this
cortisol pulse okay and
two hours before that so for you
approximately 2 30 in the morning is
what we call your temperature minimum
it's when your temperature is
lowest that it's ever going to be in the
24-hour cycle
if you view light within the four hours
after that temperature minimum it will
tend to wake you up and will keep you in
entrained to the normal cycle however if
you were to wake up at 1 30 in the
morning and see very bright light it
would delay your circadian clock it
would make it so that the next night
you'd want to go to bed later and wake
up later
and the way it does that is by changing
your core body temperature so the way it
works is you wake up because of an
increase in core body temperature that
increase in core body temperature
triggers that increase in cortisol and
by viewing light at that time you
entrain you you ensure that it happens
at the same time the next day wait if i
woke up at two o'clock in the morning
and saw bright light
that would delay your clock
so what you want so when you wake up at
4 30 in the morning it's because your
clock is in your the clocks of your body
are entrained they're matched to this
cortisol pulse
so viewing bright light in the morning
anchors it when we say and trained it it
tel through a circuit that involves
cells in the eye and cells in the
hypothalamus which then talk to the rest
of the cells of the body through a
signal a peptide that's released make
sure that the temperature starts rising
goes up up up up up and sometime around
two or three in the afternoon you're
gonna hit your temperature maximum
you might feel a little sleepy at that
time but that's actually the time in
which your gut your all your systems are
kind of revving at the maximum capacity
and then it's going to start to drop and
start to drop drop drop now that drop in
temperature eventually will be a full
one to three degrees below
what your temperature maximum and that's
when you're going to get sleepy and fall
asleep this is why it's important to
keep the room cool at night to fall
asleep
why keep the room cool well you can
always put warm blankets on and put your
hand out or your foot out because you
actually dump heat through the palms of
your hands and the bottoms of your feet
but if you're in a hot room you'd have
to have like an ice bath next to you to
put your hand in that's not feasible
i guess i i live in a luxurious scenario
i can't imagine that there's like what
kind of person is in a situation where
they don't see the sun oh so that's
horrible well
i'll
play my last being on a submarine
that's horrible being on a ship
sometimes you get stuck down below decks
and i remember this is interesting i
remember i would have like the urge to
go out
and go outside like we would we would we
you know being a seal platoon on a ship
you don't actually have a job on the
ship you're just kind of riding the ship
so you'd have this urge to go outside
we'd go outside in pt we'd go outside
believe it or not we'd go outside and
hack your sack one of my plates we
played hacky
[Music]
i'm going to tell you we played so much
hacky sack that i kind of hurt one of my
knees it's kind of getting through
what's that weird
inward rotation of the hip but we wanted
to be outside i remember having a
distinct urge to want to get outside so
it's really sad if people are in
scenarios where they aren't seeing the
sun for four hours upon wake up that's
kind of crazy or just not getting enough
light period a lot of people think for
instance they can get the sunlight
through the car windshield or through
the window
car windshields and windows have uv
filtration yeah every blue light has
been demonized and we can talk about
light later in the evening because you
don't want to get too much bright light
in your eyes later in the evening if you
want to improve sleep but
it does not work as well or as quickly
through a window or through a windshield
or through sunglasses eyeglasses and
contacts are fine if you think about
what those do they actually focus light
to the retina so that's why they're
there they'll help you even if there's
uvb
protection many people are waking up and
they're just spending time indoors and
they're putting on sunglasses getting in
their car and driving or there's cloud
cover and they think there's no sun out
i don't mean that you actually have to
stare at the sun never stare at any
light so bright it's going to damage you
please don't and blink as necessary but
the indirect rays from the from sun
trigger these cells in the eyes called
melanopsin ganglion cells
these ganglion cells these are our
neurons they send a signal to your
hypothalamus they also then the
hypothalamus releases this peptide which
is a wake up signal for your whole brain
and body and sets a timer for the onset
of melatonin release 16 hours later
melatonin being the hormone that makes
you sleepy and makes you want to go to
sleep
so you can imagine what happens if you
don't get that light until a few hours
later everything shifted
and then you want to go to st you don't
know why you're wide awake at 11 30 or
12 and everything's messed up
the other thing is that
you can get bright light from
electronic devices early in the day but
it's not enough
you need photons from sunlight now if
you live in scandinavia in the depths of
winter if you're up in like you know
trondheim or ohus or something like okay
fine
don't buy an expensive daytime simulator
get one of these led uh light boxes for
drawing they're very inexpensive
in comparison you find them on amazon i
don't have a relationship to any of
these brands but they're easy to find 20
30 bucks put that on your desk and just
look at that thing for a few minutes in
the morning not as good but better than
being in the darkness then when the
sun's out get outside
now
this is a
huge huge effect for the following
reason the signal that arrives from the
eyes to the hypothalamus also triggers
the release of the neuromodulator
dopamine we hear about dopamine as a
feel-good molecule dopamine dopamine
dopamine dopamine hits but dopamine's
main role in the brain and body is to
drive motivation craving and pursuit it
is not the molecule of pleasure it is
the molecule of drive
it is
life force and we'll talk later about
how dopamine and
testosterone have a close relationship
dopamine is actually the molecule from
which adrenaline epinephrine is
manufactured
and you may notice you said we crave sun
it also does make you feel good here's
why if you think about seasonally
breeding animals let's think about the
arctic fox well the arctic fox in winter
is white
but in the summertime has darker pellets
it actually there's a pathway going from
sunlight to dopamine to melanin
production in the skin and fur so
animals that transition from light color
to dark color that's all mediated by
dopamine guess what else happens the
gonads grow
there are animals that i've worked on in
the laboratory and that also in humans
it's now been shown in a beautiful study
that people who get 20 to 30 minutes of
light on their skin this was a study
done in israel so they wear an
appropriate amount of clothing but
they're sleeveless no hat no sunglasses
they were told to go outside 20 or 30
minutes three times a week just in the
sunshine ideally they were shorts also
they measure testosterone and estrogen
in men and women
significant increases in both
and
all the associated things of increased
passion blah blah blah that's what they
measured in the study
why well it turns out that light to the
eyes but also light to the skin the skin
is an endocrine organ it's not just
something to tattoo and hang earrings
from and put clothing on it actually
there's a pathway involving a molecule
called p53 and the keratinocytes are
these skin cells that when sunlight when
uvb ultraviolet blue light penetrates
the skin because it can penetrate the
skin superficially triggers these
keratinocytes to stimulate a pathway
that releases dopamine in the brain and
body so you feel better when you're
getting light in your eyes and on your
skin and you're increasing testosterone
and epinephrine and dopamine increase
that's why you feel good in the summer
months people in scandinavia know this
it's this kind of spring fever in the
winter months you want to go through
every bit of effort to double or triple
the amount of time that you're spending
outside in the morning so instead of 10
minutes make it 30 minutes you can read
outside you can do you could could even
be on your phone but we'll talk about
why that might not be optimal in
addition to that there's a study
done out of china now tens of thousands
of subjects looking at the incidence of
myopia nearsightedness
in kids but now this is also true in
adults when you look at things up close
the eyeball actually starts to elongate
over time and the image then focuses in
front of the the neural part of the eye
and things are blurry that's why they
call it nearsighted it's actually fall
it's not it's not farsighted would be
the image falls behind so it's just pure
optics it's falling in front
becoming myopic spending time outside
and getting uvb exposure during the day
can offset in some cases reverse myopia
so all these kids are spending time
indoors on screens and you know reading
on books but not getting any outdoor
time serious problem and now adults are
doing this too the pandemic was
there was also a pandemic of myopia and
depression that was simply because
people were indoors too much
so get that sunlight early on they shut
down the freaking beaches in san diego
i mean it was crazy hey i went to
college i was an english major and there
were some it was one one semester i took
five english classes five english
classes it was a dumb move but whenever
i'm trying to plot out my my uh classes
so that i could go to jiu jitsu for like
three four hours a day so anyways i
ended up taking five
classes and so i was reading
like on the weekends i would read like
eight ten hours a day
and
yeah that's when i realized oh if you
don't stop and take a break you're like
i'd get done and i'd walk out you know
walk outside and my my vision would be
blurry and
because i was just working at that close
range for five six seven eight hours
horrible yeah you definitely want to get
a horizon view every once in a while is
when you look at a horizon unless you're
tracking something on the horizon you
naturally go into panoramic vision
this is a great way to learn how to do
panoramic vision we were talking about
before in an environment like this where
it's you know close quarters
i can look at you and then i can dilate
my gaze consciously and you don't know
i'm doing it this
as we talked about earlier it calms the
nervous system the nice thing is it's
also covert you can be doing public
speaking you can be meeting somebody
where you're starting to feel a little
tense or whatever and you can dilate
your gaze or you can learn to i think
it's a great skill to be able to dilate
and um and contract the aperture of
vision
and a horizon will teach you kind of the
feeling of having dilated vision and
then you can kind of accomplish that
without looking at horizons so yes if
you're looking at things up close they
say for about every 45 minutes of doing
that you want 20 minutes of long
distance viewing that's very hard for
most people to get in this kind of work
environment
so one thing that works really well to
reset the eyes and the nervous system
throughout the day is
walks are great and jogs are great why
well it turns out that self-generated
optic flow so
not a peloton sorry won't work not a
treadmill sorry but walking or running
or cycling or something where visual
images are going by you on all sides
while you're in effort
some beautiful papers now five papers
showing that
when we are in self-generated optic flow
the amygdala site in the brain that's
commonly associated with fear but it's
mainly a site of threat detection and
anxiety is the activity in the amygdala
is suppressed
i think about this a lot when i uh read
your book and hear stories from the
teams of you know this notion of having
a forward center of mass
and how it's often harder to stay still
right i know you guys don't have a
retreat button but it's harder to stay
still than it is sometimes to move
forward that forward movement can
actually calm us and so a lot of people
there on the precipice of something
scary or challenging will retreat or
pause but
forward movement actually suppresses the
activity of the amygdala this again has
been shown in humans and non-human
primates and in small animal models and
it makes really good sense because
forward ambulation forward movement is
incompatible with the
fear response in many ways and so one of
the big discoveries in our field of
neuroscience the last few years was
laboratories not exploring the topic of
fear at all they were actually looking
at eye movements and and motor movements
found when they did brain wide imaging
that there are these sites in the brain
that quiet down when animals or people
are moving forward and the fear centers
shut down so if you find yourself afraid
this is i imagine that you know the kid
who i mean handrails are always
dangerous you can you can end your your
family lineage with handrails i've seen
people do that
i won't name names so there's a guy we
grew up with who unfortunately you know
hopefully he successfully reproduced at
some point but he's seen some hard
stacks on handrails it's not pretty but
it's always going to be harder to sit up
there at the top of the ramp thinking
about dropping in stop i'm dropping in
got to go when i was a kid gary hall the
guy i mentioned earlier said i'm gonna
you put your tail down on the deck i'm
in the top of the ramp that is i'm gonna
escape from one end of the deck to the
other and if i come back the third time
and you haven't dropped in i'm pushing
you in and i saw a lot of kids get
pushed in now a dad did that to his kid
on youtube and i think was punished for
child abuse
so nowadays the rules have changed but
back then you were dropping in because
you didn't want to get pushed in in any
case it's always easier to drop in than
stand there and wait what do i do what
do i do and that's the suppression of
the amygdala when you go into forward
action the fear centers of the brain
shut down so this is like another little
connection of the dots and echoes
because he's heard me talk about this a
million times it's like hey when you're
waiting to do something you're going to
be more scared you're getting it build
up you need to step forward you need to
start taking action taking action as a
way to overcome the feeling of
hesitation and fear that you have in
your body so now i have another
physiological backup to my instincts
that's good so
we got up in the morning
we got some light yes this is
interesting because i i wake up early
morning i work out uh but
i go for a run by the time i'm going for
a run the sun's out perfect i never and
the sun might not be fully i was gonna
ask like does it need to be hit in my
skin or can it be kind of below the
horizon are we good
on a day on a cloudless day it can be
anywhere
on a day with more clouds you probably
want to try and orient toward where the
sun might be and get out of the shade a
little bit just so you don't have to be
out there for more than five ten minutes
okay well i'm going on you know half an
hour 45 minute run great uh
so we got some light
and by the way interestingly i don't
i wear sunglasses a lot and maybe that's
bad i wear sunglasses actually almost
all the time if i'm in the sun but when
i go for a run in the morning i never
wear sunglasses because of sweat and all
this other stuff and you have a lot of
sun here in san diego so you're getting
a lot of photons all day long
so there are a couple things about your
practice that are perfectly designed one
is
you're there are a few things let's
let's just make it really simple for
people the goal here is to increase body
temperature in order to be awake and to
decrease body temperature in order to be
asleep if we stay with those themes a
lot of this will just fall into bins
so you wake up getting sunlight in your
eyes will
enhance the or bright artificial lights
and then sunlight if you're up before
the sun comes out turn on bright
artificial lights if you want to be
awake right
we'll enhance the cortisol pulse
cortisol is going to further increase in
body temperature exercising will
increase body temperature
somewhat paradoxically
getting into a cold shower or cold water
everyone says well it must make you cold
right well if you stay in there a long
time to become hypothermic right but
let's remember the thermostat example
you have a little area in your brain
called the medial pre-optic area
and if you make the surface of your body
cold guess what happens core body
temperature goes up
so getting into so if you're going to do
ice baths or cold showers you can do i
would say do them sometime better than
not at all
and there's the whole thing relative to
training we talk about but
early in the day would be better okay so
i get back from my run
and i'm going in the ice perfect so by
the way five to seven minutes in the ice
bath that's a good long nice bath but
you guys are you guys are weaned in cold
water yeah you guys what's i swim with a
guy from the teams but dos it and we
sometimes
for me it was a long swim like a one
mile no wetsuit swim in the pacific for
me around the santa monica pier and then
and then run back for me you know i'm
quaking like an alcoholic with delirium
tremendous by time i get to the coffee
shop we go in there sometimes quaking
like this and i'm convinced they think
that we're all have delirium tremens
um
you know that's a cold swim for me and i
don't do it very much anymore i should
do it more often but what's interesting
is he sees the water you guys like you
see the white and it's like you want to
get in the thing for me there's a 10
minute break-in period where i'm like oh
my god i can't believe it and then you
have the triathletes on the beach and
their wetsuits going are you really
going to go in without with without
wetsuits and i was like i didn't realize
people go in with wetsuits
but
i just go numb when i hit the water but
i never crave it i always think all
right i'm gonna do this
because here i am and like if i don't go
in i don't feel bad about myself and
that kind of thing you're doing some
serious negotiations yeah i know right
yeah we all know how i will say i i
think about like for for my uh for my
ice bath in the morning i've i always
think like i feel so good when i get
done that it's worth the little shock of
when you get in and actually you
legitimately do get used to the
sh the quote shock of getting in like if
i go on a trip for a week
and i come back and wherever i am
there's no there's no ice which is
pretty normal there's not normal ice
baths around the world but when i come
back that first day maybe even the
second day it's a little bit more of a
little bit of a i'm having some freaking
andrew huberman conversations with
myself oh my god now now now now um
now deliberation
over hard work because it has a name
this is uh thank you
i deserve it you're absolutely right um
yeah duds not buds for me but the uh so
well i'm glad you mentioned the mood
enhancing effects so there's a beautiful
paper published in the european journal
physiology in the year 2000 which took
people and had them sit they actually
had them on lawn chairs in water a pool
is a great way to run an experiment
i always say people ask about cold
showers they're not a lot of experiments
on cold showers because think about it's
very hard to control is everyone under
the shower the same way et cetera you
put someone up in water up to their neck
it is you know what you're doing so it's
experimental rigor that drives that but
they had people get into reasonably cool
water 60 degrees fahrenheit so it's not
that cool but they had them stand for an
hour
or they've had people get into very cold
water
something like 40 degrees for just 20
seconds now here's what's really
interesting that shock that you referred
to is an adrenaline also called
epinephrine and it is released from the
adrenals obviously but also from a site
in the brain called locus ceruleus a
little area of the brain stem that then
sprinklers the rest of the brain with
epinephrine and wakes up the rest of the
brain so that shock occurs in the brain
and the body and actually the stuff in
the body doesn't cross the blood-brain
barrier so you're a two-part system we
talk about this later because when those
two systems are aligned it's beautiful
when those two systems are out of
alignment that's not good
so you get into cold water that's the
shock for the first 30 seconds for most
people who are untrained your forebrain
which is controlling decision making
is basically suppressed in its activity
and other areas are ramped up so just
know that
exact panic just understand that passes
then what happens is when you get out of
the cold whether or not it's a longer
period at 60 degrees or a short period i
would hate to hear that people are only
doing 20 seconds but maybe a minute to
three minutes at 45 degrees or something
there's a long arc release of dopamine
and epinephrine that's what was shown in
the study in humans because people
always go well it's just in mice no
in humans and that long arc of dopamine
leads to a near doubling or more of
dopamine and epinephrine in my colleague
anna lemke's book called dopamine nation
she works on addiction runs our dual
diagnosis addiction clinic at stanford
she talked about a patient of hers that
basically helped himself get over
cocaine addiction by doing cold baths
because it was the only thing that would
give him the kind of dopamine release
that even slightly mimicked his cocaine
addiction and allowed himself to wean
himself off with a healthier behavior
now i'm not saying it's the equivalent
of a drug like cocaine but i am saying
that it's a better decision than than a
drug like cocaine
for obvious reasons so that
mood-enhancing effect that you feel
afterwards it's real
it's based on a real neurochemical
effect and that dopamine and epinephrine
will combine with
the temperature increase from cortisol
plus light plus exercise all things that
increase core body temperature now
you've got increased core body
temperature you created a dopamine
release epinephrine you've created a
summer month
inside your body in the in i don't care
if you live in minneapolis in the depths
of winter or someplace even as cold as
new hampshire you are
you are creating summer in your body by
doing that now if you live in san diego
or los angeles or arizona and it's the
summer and you're staying indoors and
you're on your phone and you're not
doing any movement until the afternoon
which is fine exercise in the afternoon
i realize there's some important
benefits of that
and you're
laying in bed or you're just walking
around the kitchen and putting on
sunglasses and driving to work guess
what you're creating
a colorado winter inside of your body
despite the fact that the sun is out so
if you're wondering why you're slightly
depressed your metabolism is lower your
testosterone output is slightly lower
than maybe you'd like it to be there
could be other reasons too of course but
again we're talking about modulators i'm
not saying getting sun in your eyes in
the morning is going to make your
testosterone perfect
what i'm saying is you're you're setting
an internal milieu
through things that increase core body
temperature dopamine epinephrine etc
and that should be done relatively early
in the day
now we could
sort of skip to something about
temperature just to benefit people
kind of bookend the the opposite end of
the day as the evening comes around oh
i'm sorry you asked a question i want to
close the hatch on this about um sun low
in the sky you do not need to see the
sun rise across the horizon however
what we're the cells in the eye that
trigger all this the so-called melanops
and ganglion cells respond best a yellow
blue
contrast the next time you see a sunrise
or a sunset you will see the yellow blue
contrast i'm referring to and what it's
associated with is a low solar angle
sunlight so if the sun is directly
overhead that yellow blue contrast isn't
there take a picture with your phone and
everyone will see what i'm talking about
so you don't have to see the sunrise
you're not getting up as early as jocko
that's fine but around let's say you get
up at 8 30 and you're outside by nine
and the sun is low in the sky it's
certainly not overhead you're still
getting that yellow blue contrast that
triggers the optimal activity of these
cells
ideally you would also see get some
sunlight in your eyes in the afternoon
because it it turns out you don't have
one circadian clock one master clocking
brain you have two oscillators this gets
a little bit tricky in the biophysics
but you have a morning oscillator and an
evening oscillator for people that think
about oscillators
and geeks out there two oscillators can
predict many more things it's not it's
one plus one equals eight in this case
having two oscillators allows you to do
a number of computations in the brain
including timing the onset of sleep
metabolism etc so try and get some
sunlight in your eyes in the evening as
well here's why
even though i said early in the day
you need sunlight and a lot of light to
trigger these pathways late in the day
retinal sensitivity goes up so if you
see bright light in the evening and
you're viewing too many screens and too
much bright light in the evening it's
very easy to wake your system up again
so you want to really dim the lights in
the evening you don't necessarily have
to wear blue blockers in fact if you're
wearing blue blockers and the light is
still too bright it won't make a
difference because it's broad spectrum
light will trigger these pathways so dim
the lights in the evening lower the
temperature in your home or in the room
that you sleep
and
evening would be or afternoon would be a
great time to i don't know get in a
sauna take a hot shower take a hot bath
why well if you stay in a long long time
of course you'll heat up but again if
you heat up the external part of the
body your core body temperature will
drop after you get out of that sauna
after you get out of that bath and when
it comes to sauna dr ronda patrick's
really the more proficient one here but
we've talked about this literature
there are a couple ways to use sauna
i'll just mention in hot baths work also
really well
the studies showing enormous increases
in growth hormone were done the
following way they had people get into a
hot sauna for 30 minutes then get out
for five minutes 30 minutes then five
minutes out 30 minutes to five minutes
out for a total of two hours in the
sauna between 175 and 210 degrees sauna
how often once a week okay if they did
it more often the amount of growth
hormone release went from a sixteen fold
increase which is pretty mega down to a
two or three folding it got worse
got worse because you become heat
adapted
and you can also become cold adapted so
we could talk about cold and how to use
cold but
remember the more comfortable you get
with a stimulus the less of an
adaptation effect you're getting just
like weights or running or anything else
now it is true that the more often that
people did 20 minutes of sauna
at 174 to 210 degrees fahrenheit i think
that's 80 to 100 degrees celsius if i
recall
the more often they did that two or
three times a week turned out to be
better than one and five to seven times
turned out to be better than two or
three for lowering all-cause mortality
and death to cardiovascular events so
we're talking about growth hormone
release you want to do it every once in
a while for many hours with breaks in
the middle for
improved overall health getting blood
flow you're talking doing it every night
would be great so it depends on what
your goal is the same thing with the
water if you want to build resilience
well make the stimulus as terrible as
possible and here's an easy way to do it
i like to kind of poke fun at the tough
guys on the internet who get into the
ice bath and sit there really stoic well
guess what there's this thing called a
thermal layer
that builds up around you and we're
sitting there really stoic you're not
making it as cold as you could be guys
and gals
sift your body around a little bit now
it's cold get those hands under get
those feet under and pedal those while
keeping your mind calm it is
considerably colder because you're
breaking up that thermal layer it sucks
hence the waves on uh
out there on coronado right yeah it
sucks when you because i at my ice bath
well i i have like the little jet mine
has a little jet
on the side you know it's ionizing the
water or whatever so it's shooting in
and like that side is super cold because
it's flowing past your body my other
side i've got it perfectly still i got a
thermo layer just you know keeping me
all toasty warm on that right side well
i would say um
you know it's
it's fun to play with the ice bath
because you can what you're doing is you
can play with your relationship to
adrenaline so the way i think about ice
baths and cold showers and things like
that i think of it as a series of walls
when you get into the shock that you
described that's a pulse of adrenaline
in your brain and body but then you know
you might ask yourself this question you
know if you can withstand something for
a second why not a minute and if a
minute why not three hours well the
reason is is that adrenaline is released
in pulsatile fashion and they it
compounds so one wave then another wave
so it's you're building it's like an
upward spiral of adrenaline it's not one
then down to zero one it's one down to
0.5 2.5 so it's building on itself in
the brain and body and as it circulates
it gets more and more painful until you
go numb and then it gets easier as you
know so one thing to do is to just
imagine and actually learn to sense the
waves of adrenaline so maybe the first
wave is just getting in the damn thing
maybe climbing i think of that as one
wall you climbed over that wall now
you're in
then you could say well i'm going to go
30 seconds and then maybe at 20 seconds
you'll feel that wall you thought 30 but
that wall comes climb that wall what
you'll start to notice is the walls
actually start getting further and
further apart because adrenaline has
this incredible anti-inflammatory
numbing quality to it so the walls
actually get lower as time goes on
but they start off very high that's the
way that i think about the ice path and
that maps to the way that adrenaline
physiology actually functions
so again it's that first those first
steps are the hardest i think about this
when i wake up in the morning and i
don't want to do something i often see
your watch staring at me on my phone i
do and i think ah like this is a big
wall and i think okay but the walls are
going to be diminishing over time
even if it gets harder adrenaline
bolsters you in that way it's a magical
molecule
so
toward evening heat is going to be
beneficial
the other thing is dim the lights
obviously because lights are serving as
a wake-up signal and then you know a lot
of people have this problem that they go
to sleep and then they wake up at three
in the morning or two in the morning
they can't fall back asleep and so i
said the two major modulators are sleep
and non-sleep deep rest and non-sleep
deep breast or nsdr
is a phrase that
to be
direct i coined to encompass a lot of
behaviors that are designed to just
teach you to lower your level of
activation your nervous system
meditation is one form but the problem
with meditation is meditation involves
focus you have to pay attention to your
breath for instance sit there and
meditate that actually puts a high
demand on the metabolic systems of the
forebrain so it's work it's like reading
except you're reading your breasts and
your thoughts
non-sleep deep resting includes things
like it has a kind of corny name for
some it's called yoga nidra which means
yoga sleep you lie down you just listen
to a script you can find these on the on
youtube or elsewhere
10-minute ones or 30-minute ones take
you through a body scan some long exhale
breathing we talked about why this calms
the body or there are various forms of
hypnosis that really involve teaching
you to relax so non-sleepy breasts is
kind of a general term for
things that we deliberately do to teach
our body to down regulate in real time
and so
i highly recommend that if people have
trouble falling back asleep in the
middle of the night that they turn on a
yoga nidra and listen to that or they
use an app like reverie which i think
they have a free trial on there um there
is
a english speaking or is it a chant or
what's yoga nature got going on it means
yoga sleep it's existed for thousands of
years as you lie down it's the the
scripts are in english the ones that
you'll find on youtube and there's
actually an nsdr script put out by a
team guy and his company made for and
these are again zero cost tools you can
just listen to them um
you it takes you through a body scan a
lot of long exhale breathing the reason
he put that out there and the reason why
i talk about nsdr is that when people
hear yoganitra or they hear meditation
they think you know flying carpets monks
in lotus position and one of the
problems with science
end with some of the better practices
from uh different communities in in you
know asian and indian communities is
that a lot of it's vaulted behind
language you know science is guilty of
this too you start talking about
adrenaline and locus ceruleus and if you
don't put it in context being like uh
yeah that doesn't mean anything to me
yoga nidra it sounds like something
very foreign
at the end of the day non-sleep deep
breast practices are all about the same
thing we have a system in our body
called the autonomic nervous system this
is the system that when a bomb blast
goes off or you hear a loud noise
immediately put adrenaline in your body
the most amazing molecule right i mean
if you think about it you didn't need
sleep you didn't need a nap you didn't
need caffeine all of a sudden you are
alert you're done
you're you're there rather and
that's the so-called sympathetic nervous
system getting activated
broad system goes out
it's called simpa casimpa means together
and you have a chain of neurons called
the sympathetic chain ganglia that run
from your belly button up to about your
heart when some external stimulus or
some thought triggers
the sympathetic nervous system all those
cells fire up
at once they just pulse of adrenaline
into your body or they trigger the
pathways is that so when you're driving
and you almost get an accident and you
feel the adrenaline like
reaching out to your fingers like you
feel it coming that's what that's what's
happening literally emanates from the
center and it what's interesting is in
fish and in other animals all mammals of
all kinds but also in fish it actually
triggers the muscles of the of the the
thoracic muscles and the motor neurons
there to start punctuating to know which
direction to go animals that get into a
threat mode often have an undulation to
them that's the sympathetic nervous
system
you know a body in motion is more
available for movement in any trajectory
as opposed to being completely still
etc so then you have another system
which is the parasympathetic nervous
system it's like the other end of the
seesaw and it's neurons that exist from
the neck down to about the heart and
from the belly button down to the bottom
of your tailbone those are the ones that
so-called rest and digest system but
it's much more than that it's also the
system that allows you to
dilate your gaze reflexively right you
can learn how to do that under states of
high adrenaline if you like but
naturally when you're relaxed your gaze
dilates
reproduction
is kind of a balance between the two uh
the process of reproducing the verb
literally of sex not the biological sex
but the verb sex is a process of the
autonomic seesaw there's arousal which
involves a kind of balance in these
systems etc um kids look it up
not too young appropriately age kids
look it up but that's it it's it's
inherent to the to the evolution of our
species as a balance between activation
and calm
and so when
we are born we have an asymmetry in this
autonomic nervous system that asymmetry
is the following none of us need to
learn how to stress or react adrenal
that system the activation of the
sympathetic nervous system is automatic
in response to different thoughts and
stimuli
cold for instance being the universal
trigger of adrenaline why not use heat
well you can only use so much heat
before you damage tissues or kill people
you can use a lot of cold as they know
on coronado you can use cold a lot
before it be you have to be careful but
you have to get pretty damn cold for a
long time before you you die
but do be careful with this stuff
obviously now the parasympathetic system
is different we rarely learn how to calm
ourselves
we all are familiar with getting sleepy
and falling asleep that's the
parasympathetic nervous system taking
over
the longer we are awake the longer the
build-up of something called adenosine
in the brain and body and adenosine
turns on the parasympathetic nervous
system suppresses the sympathetic
nervous system when we sleep adenosine
is pushed back down
what is caffeine caffeine effectively
through some chemical steps
blocks the effects of adenosine
so if you wait so here's a little trick
if you that's i don't like the word
hacks because
hacks imply using something for a
purpose it wasn't designed for here
we're talking about
hardwired biology but if you wake up in
the morning and you didn't sleep quite
as much as you would have liked
that means and you're sleepy that means
you still have a buildup of adenosine in
your system let's say you immediately
reach for caffeine great you suppress
the action of that adenosine and you
will be more alert and guess what
happens then the caffeine wears off and
the adenosine binds to the receptors
with greater affinity and you have your
afternoon crash
so a practice that's very useful to
people is to delay the intake of
caffeine by 60 to 90 minutes after
waking allow the adenosine to be cleared
out because it's not just cleared out in
sleep it's also cleared out in those
kind of sleepy states of early morning
so allow it to be cleared out the other
thing that clears it out exercise
exercise so when you get up in the
morning you're kind of sleepy i don't
want to do this i don't want to do this
but you hydrate and train you clear out
the adenosine now i like to drink
caffeine before i train her during
training i'm weak like that
but
for people that have an afternoon crash
this can have
tremendous benefits of and maybe start
by pushing it out 15 minutes per day
most everyone that does this says oh my
goodness i didn't understand why in the
afternoon i'm crashing so hard
this will really really help
i'm curious do you drink coffee before
you train nope
that's for weak people right
uh
i don't like the taste of coffee but i
also don't drink any caffeine i don't
drink one of my one of my go-drinks or
anything like that and i just wake up
you know i drink water in the morning
and i go work out
and i've i've
thought about it you know i thought and
this
i thought about i always thought well
honestly i thought it seemed kind of
weak to like after you know to do that
right yeah so i didn't do it
uh but there has been times where i'm
thinking man like i'll see you know i'll
you know look at other people and
they'll be like drinking coffee isn't
working out first thing in the morning
and i'm thinking you know maybe i should
do it you know maybe i am wrong um and
i'm open to being totally wrong well
here's the thing um
if adrenaline is the most incredible
molecule in biology and i do believe it
is for its capacity to immediately grab
our attentional systems and our
readiness systems
dopamine is perhaps the second
place winner there but still a
significant one you know there's this
incredible experiment that's been done
in animals and humans that really
illustrates what dopamine does you take
two rats and they've done this with
people in naturally occurring situations
and you put rats next to some delicious
water they like water with sucrose in it
or a delicious food and you
and the rats will
reach up and drink that or eat that food
one of the rats it turns out doesn't
even have neurons that make dopamine or
all their dopamine is blocked by the
injection of a drug turns out they will
indulge in that food just fine just like
the one that has plenty of dope so just
to just to make sure i'm tracking so
you've got two rats yeah separate one of
them has their dopamine has been blocked
correct but at this point
they're both just eating the sugary
drinking the sugary water just
everything's fine yep tastes good and
they experience pleasure both of them
experience pleasure proof that dopamine
is not required to experience pleasure
now you do a simple experiment you
simply move
the location of the food or water one
rat length away from the rat and guess
what
the rat with its dopamine walks over and
eats the food it might even cross a
little metal plate where it gets an
electrical shock but you know it's
hungry and it wants to eat so it'll take
the zap and do it
the rat without dopamine won't even walk
one rat's length to get its dopamine
even if the food is laid out on the
floor for it
dopamine is not the molecule of pleasure
it is the molecule of motivation desire
and pursuit see this is interesting we
had an experiment that we talked about
on here i had a back in the day i had an
rv
and for whatever reason we had i had
taken the mint chocolate chip ice cream
and put it in the rv freezer for some
reason i forget why
and
you know when that when that stuff's in
the freezer in the house it was like oh
cool i'm gonna get it's right there
we're gonna go get it right but i guess
i wasn't dopamine fueled enough like
three four five days went by before i
was like all right i really want it so
i'm gonna go get it well it's
it is the molecule of drive the way to
think about dopamine it is that it is a
non-infinite
yet renewable resource non-infinite yet
renewable what do i mean by that well
this relates to the energy drink
caffeine question should you be doing
all this stuff
just as
adrenaline epinephrine is released in
response to psychological stressors
physical stressors cold water final
exams you know broken relationship
excitement
these are generic molecules right i mean
they're used to create activation states
in the body dopamine is the molecule of
motivation pursuit and desire
and it can be triggered by a number of
different things
however it is a
non-infinite yet renewable resource so
if you
have too big a dopamine
release
let's say from methamphetamine cocaine
damn we're going we're going there we're
going there
okay or or let's say
to be fair because i i you know know
people or from um being in a lot of gun
fights in in a short period of time
the period immediately after that will
involve a mirror symmetric decrease in
dopamine you don't go back down to
baseline you go below baseline
so
we all should guard our dopamine peaks
very carefully a little bit goes a long
way a lot goes even further but it also
takes you down deeper afterwards this is
the basis of addiction and this is the
beautiful work of anna lemke and rob
malenka at stanford and elsewhere
showing that it when it goes down do we
want it back right now ah so the the dip
afterwards is actually associated with a
molecule called dinorphin which is the
opposite of endorphin
and involves pain in the body
so for every bit of pleasure that we get
from pursuit and getting the thing that
we were pursuing
the crash that comes afterwards feels
painful
and all that we need to do in order to
return to a baseline of dopamine renew
that resource
is to wait and make sure that we don't
try and trigger yet more dopamine in
that time
so you asked about should i be taking
caffeine in addition to training and
blasting music i always say people
differ on this spectrum but be careful
about stacking dopamine training itself
is a stimulus for dopamine release cold
water is a stimulus for dopamine release
but if you start doing training
cold water
listening to your your favorite music
plus you're taking let's say some
stimulant doesn't obviously the stimulus
we've been talking about are terrible
but some of the the stronger stimulants
out there
used to be ephedrine back when i was in
college but now people taking adult
adderall
is that ritual now illegal right right
now illegal yeah
i had a guy work with unfortunately he
died but he you would you would see like
he was in my platoon you would see
he he he would take that he called it
rippy rip
actually you can tell if somebody has a
lot of dopamine and adrenaline in their
system just by looking at them their
pupils are big so somewhat paradoxically
when pupils are big your visual aperture
is narrow that just has to do with the
with the so-called accommodation of the
eye the optics of the eye so remember
big pupils means somebody is high on
their own dopamine and adrenaline could
be drug induced could be situational etc
small pupils are going to be a relaxed
state now of course it's also going to
be modulated by how bright it is an
environment because of the way these
systems work
but when you can see somebody wide-eyed
well dopamine and adrenaline also do
something else they actually trigger
activation of the brainstem cranial
nuclei that cause opening of the eyelids
they also cause an eyes up effect when
we get sleepy what happens our eyes go
down when we're awake eyelids are open
and eyes are up they might not be up
like this these relate to three
different cranial nerve nuclei for the
future med students you'll learn what
these are
so
it all makes perfect sense when when
because nature is beautiful and the
biology is laid out for us but if we
start stacking behaviors plus
pharmacology plus
you know mindsets that increase dopamine
great but what that means is that if you
get a really big dopamine increase well
then that afternoon you might not feel
the drive to do the work you might think
why am i sleeping in the after why am i
kind of less motivated or next day for
training without that pharmacology
you're thinking oh yeah that the workout
isn't i don't get quite as intense a
contraction with my muscles
exactly
well i'm just thinking about it because
you know a lot of times people ask me
you know i have a hard time you know
like i get fired up to do stuff but then
i don't actually do it you know that's a
common sort of thing for humans
and and now i can kind of track it a
little bit oh you got yourself super
worked up
and then you let that go or you you know
maybe you worked for a little bit of
time you know like right hey writing a
book right i've written a bunch of books
you're not like hyped to write the book
you might you're like oh man it's going
to be
and you that only lasts for seven
minutes of typing bro that's it it's
chop wood carry yeah yeah then it's like
oh this is just gonna suck and that's
just the way it is but now i realize if
you this is what i like about this if
you're aware
of the fact
that oh this is my dopamine crash and i
can't ex i shouldn't anticipate
continued hype through this situation i
need to push through it that's that's
good awareness to have definitely and
you know nowadays you hear especially in
silicon valley about dopamine fasting
you know people i don't even want to
look at somebody else's face i'm not
going to eat any you know tasty food i'm
not going to do anything that stimulates
dopamine sure that will reset what you
find pleasurable but let's be realistic
the better way to do things would be to
modulate
dopamine release control it make it work
for you and everyone's going to differ
so for some people it's got to be music
the pre-workout the you know
four cups of espresso and and you know
and someone screaming in their face that
they have to do it well for other people
we're quite require fewer of those
variables but everyone needs to learn
how they feel both before during and
after a behavior you know i think the
right amount of exercise is what you can
do consistently and train hard but that
also allow you to perform unless you're
an athlete and that's your your
profession to be able to do the other
things throughout the day that are
beneficial to you and of course some
people are training late in the day and
i have no problem with that i got kind
of attacked by the the um the uh fitness
anistas recently or whatever you call
them online because i said you know
training early in the days that's this
dopamine pulse like training late in the
day has been shown in these 19 studies
sure i'm sure for when your body
temperature is elevated later in the day
um you know lubrication of the joints
and you know mental acuity sure but for
most people who just need to get more
movement are trying to maximize focus on
productivity throughout the day early
day training is going to be probably the
better option but bet sometime is better
than no time but if you're training late
in the day
and you're getting a big increase in
body temperature and you're doing it
under bright lights and you're drinking
a pre-workout and you're wondering why
you can't sleep at night it's you know
you don't have to be sigmund freud or a
neuroscientist to understand that you're
basically just have your body you're
cranking your body temperature up hence
a lot of these technologies and here
this isn't a promotion we don't at least
not now don't have a relationship to
anyone i won't even name them there are
a lot of technologies now about making
your bed cool
this mat or that this you know to cool
down your butt your body temperature at
night so you can sleep so if you start
thinking about this in kind of a
rational structure it makes sense it
also makes sense why
for instance after a big win sometimes
we feel a crash
and we need some time to reset and that
lower depression sometimes people make
the mistake of going out and pursuing
more dopamine one of the areas that i
have real concern about just because i
hear about it so often and it wasn't an
issue when i was growing up is a lot of
young guys in particular approach me
because they're
based on the questions i'm getting
they're watching a lot of really intense
pornography
and that has we know their studies now
going on at stanford and elsewhere
pornography it creates a strong dopamine
rush these are very primitive pathways
that
in some ways can overwhelm the dopamine
system and then you know another thing
is happening
so a lot of young guys are getting all
this arousal from watching other people
have sex and then they're in the real
world scenario and it's like wait you're
no longer third person in this you're in
you're actually in this scene and it's
completely collapsing them and so i'm
not one of these anti-porn people i you
know i'm not here to judge i'm just a
scientist i'm reporting the i always say
i'm i'm not a doctor i don't prescribe
things i'm a professor so i profess
things you can decide what you want to
do with it or not but if you once you
understand dopamine that all makes
perfect sense they're getting this
enormous dopamine release from something
that is external to them and real life
you know may not mimic the intensity of
the combination of variables right
or people are exercising for a little
while and it's all exciting to them and
they're
and they're you're taking tons and tons
of pharmacology to do it and then they
kind of lose motivation well it remember
non-infinite yet renewable resource yeah
that's uh
being aware of these things i think is
so important because what you know if uh
if if i said hey i'm you're gonna walk
through my house and i'm gonna scare you
i'm gonna jump out and scare you at some
point
yeah i i probably wouldn't be able to do
it because you'd be aware waiting and
i'd jump out and go boo and you'd be
like oh yeah you know what i might be
able to do it maybe a little bit but
imagine if i didn't tell you right and i
said yeah come by my house and uh you
know just just let yourself in i'll be
there in a little while then i freaking
jumped out and scared you you'd be
scared because you're not aware of it
you're not aware of what's gonna happen
so having awareness i remember had a uh
fighter
who
had been a highly competitive wrestler
and he was going to fight in a in a big
organization
and he was sort of like
i was like hey are you feeling nervous
at all this was a couple weeks prior hey
are you feeling nervous he's kind of
blown me off a little bit
you know hey i've been fighting for i've
been i've been wrestling for my whole
life i've been competing i've been on
the national stage blah blah blah right
i'm not nervous
i said okay great i should have known
better
because when he went and fought now he's
in the ufc and he got nervous and what
really i think messed him up
was he didn't understand what was
happening
and then i remembered i used to talk to
like a new guy that was showing up on
deployment
and you'd see him before and up and he
could just see the look on their face
like they are scared
and what they're scared of is they're
scared of getting getting killed and get
blown up that's fine they're scared of
doing a bad job that's fine but what
really is making them nervous is the
fact that they feel nervous they don't
even know what that feels like because
they made it through training and
they've jumped out of airplanes and
they've you know scuba dived at night
off the coast and so they're they're
used to being afraid and they don't they
don't feel fear anymore so they don't
even understand what it feels like so
then all of a sudden they get knots in
their stomach their heart rates going
and they that's what they're scared of
they're like why am i feeling like this
and it's freaking out so when you say oh
hey you uh you feel like you got some
butterflies in your stomach right now
you know feel like your heart's going a
little bit and they're like and they
don't want to tell you the truth they're
like no no i feel fine it's like
[ __ ] i can see
and they go yeah and it's like cool
you're just you're just nervous it's
just your body getting ready for combat
it's no big deal everyone's gonna feel
like that and then they feel okay
so situations that you're talking about
where
if you don't know what it is
it it's like that enough can can can
make you fall
whereas you say hey listen after you get
a good big dopamine hit you're not gonna
feel fired up three hours later that's
when you gotta put in the work be aware
of the fact that you won't feel like
doing it because people think you know
what i just didn't feel like going
anymore it's like yeah of course you
didn't you got all your dopamine and you
already used it and you need to let that
thing rebuild but you can still go get a
good workout and you can go still
complete the task and go still write
some more you know for your book that
you're doing or do whatever labor you
got to do so i think it's very important
for people to understand what's going on
inside so they don't feel like it's
dude maybe i don't even want to do this
you know maybe i don't even want to be
here you know i remember you know i just
get get to because i trained jiu jitsu
at night
or in the afternoon and man when i was
in the team sometimes you come home and
you're like man dude i don't really even
want to do this right now and i would
just say yeah you do and it doesn't
matter how you feel you're just gonna go
do it so being able to overcome that i
think that's what's nice about what
you're informing us of
is people can now go oh i know what this
is this isn't me being a wimp this isn't
me
you know not wanting to do this it's my
own natural you know hormones that are
doing this thing making me feel this way
and i can just work through them
absolutely
extremely well put you know earlier i
mentioned
in the reference to sunlight i talked
about dopamine and testosterone
testosterone has a huge number of
effects in the body and it's sibling
molecule if if you will
dihydrotestosterone is perhaps the more
dominant androgen in humans
dihydrotestosterone tht okay uh you know
there are pharmacologic versions of this
right oxandralone anovar i'm not
suggesting people take those right what
i'm talking about is the dht you make
naturally very powerful androgen it's
converted from testosterone into you get
dht in a conversion of testosterone to
dht through a molecule called five alpha
reductase anytime you hear ace it's
almost always an enzyme ace is basically
you know cat you know proteinase
okay
so
dht uh it's going to cause some male
pattern baldness so this with your
widow's peak
your widow's peak yep yeah what was it
widow's peak sure uh tell you
my now elaborating widow speed that's
dihydrotestosterone causes beer growth
on the face and causes male pattern
balance has inverse effect on the scalp
and on the face like it has other
effects
strength etc
the testosterone molecule and the
dopamine molecule bear a very close
relationship so if somebody pushes
pushes pushes really hard wins wins wins
yes that will increase testosterone
winning increases testosterone losing
decreases testosterone in all venues
yeah so they look at this with with day
traders win win win win win more money
they get more tests out they're losing
okay now here's the interesting thing
i had an episode of the podcast with the
great robert sapolsky wrote why zebras
don't get ulcers the trouble with
testosterone etc let's talk about the
effects of testosterone and dht in the
brain the main effect of these androgens
in the brain
is to make effort feel good
because of the way that testosterone and
dht bind to receptors and activate
certain components of the amygdala we
always think of the amygdala as a fear
center but it's a threat detection
center and it has a lot of different
parts including parts that allow you to
be forward center of mass in response to
pressure
so
am i suggesting people take exogenous
testosterone no that's a personal choice
that people can explore on their own if
they want to do that but if you've been
pushing pushing pushing and winning
winning or just pushing really hard and
then you've experienced that crash
a lot of people need some time to
recover
in order to be able to come back and be
able to work hard again but here's
what's really interesting not only does
testosterone make effort feel good
effort increases testosterone so this is
the athlete or the student who's like i
don't want to do it i don't want to do
anything getting into some degree of
forward center of mass i always say i
think i picked this up from a team guy
it's very team guy language you can
either be back on your heels flat footed
or forward center of mass on anything
getting into that forward center of mass
mental orientation can start to trigger
some of the pathways related to these
hormones and these neuromodulators what
you don't want to do is start using a
lot of exogenous factors caffeine or a
lot of things outside of you in order to
try and create those states because then
you're going to further deplete your
dopamine and so on
when i think you went on rogan at one
point and i overheard a person i
listened to a portion of the
conversation where you said you had um
been working really hard and then you
went on vacation and then you got sick
yeah so this is interesting that's the
autonomic nervous that's happened to me
like
numerous times okay so so there's a very
clear explanation for for that in a very
simple remedy although it's not obvious
which is why many people experience this
many people experience studying for
finals and then it ends getting sick
taking care of a loved one
round the clock the person either gets
better or sometimes dies or whatever it
is
and then
the caretaker gets sick why is that well
we always hear that stress compromises
the immune system
nothing could be further from the truth
stress activates the immune system think
about how would your immune system your
spleen and your other immune organs of
the body know when it's under pressure
well
you could have some foreign bacteria or
virus in your body but when you are in a
mode of go go go the molecule adrenaline
triggers the release of killer b cells
and t cells from the spleen
it's when you relax now you need to get
your sleep but it's when you finally
experience that symmetric swing back of
the see sauce here go go go go go boom
and then you completely relax and you're
hanging out and all of a sudden you get
the sniffle and the rest of the thing
this is there's a beautiful study done
by that was done
in response to none other than wim hof
believe it or not there's a really
beautiful quality scientific study
published in the proceedings in the
national academy of sciences
where they had two groups of people one
group meditated the other group did wim
hof type breathing so what we call in
the laboratory cyclic hyperventilation
so inhale exhale inhale exhale 25 times
forceful inhales and forceful exhales
then hold your breath lungs empty for 15
seconds repeat for about three rounds
what does that do why do you heat up
adrenaline it's a generic thing it's
adrenaline you could have gotten into an
ice bath adrenaline you could you have
someone shouting your face
adrenaline it's just adrenaline what
what did they do they injected both
groups of people with e coli
injected them with e coli one group gets
nauseous vomiting and feels sick the
group that does this cyclic
hyperventilation wim hof also called
tumor type breathing
far fewer symptoms if any including
lack of fever
so why well they were able to combat
the
the attack of this bacteria so if you're
coming off of a hard bout of work
and you're starting to relax in the
vacation you would be wise to still get
into some cold water you would be wise
to still do some cyclic hyperventilation
breathing
certainly don't do those at the same
time a number of people actually have
died doing cyclic hyperventilation and
then doing breath holds because when you
exhale a lot of carbon dioxide carbon
dioxide is the trigger to breathe this
is really important if if you do
hyperventilation
and then you hold your breath you can do
a much longer breath hold than you could
if you just started off without having
done that why
that you don't take breaths because of a
need for oxygen although you do need
that you take breaths because of a build
up of carbon dioxide triggers these
brain stem neurons which have you do the
gasp reflex
okay well if you dump all your carbon
dioxide and you're not a skilled
uh free diver like markely or somebody
like that who really understands that
what happens is you're swimming along
like wow i can really hold my breath
down here a long time lights out
actually i'm aware of a few people in
the military community who who've
dabbled with
wim hof tumor type breathing and have
died and
not it's not good i think it's not
allowed basically it's not inc certainly
not encouraged from what i understand
so do it on land away from water
and
the idea here is that adrenaline
protects us you don't want it cascading
out of control so that you can't sleep
you want to use things like non-sleep
deep breaths and the appropriate timing
of light and exercise etc to be able to
sleep well at night to reset all these
systems
but
if you go too quickly from go go go go
to complete relaxation your immune
system your defense system will crash
too and so you're not going to be able
to fight off even the even the smallest
or the you know the pettiest of viruses
and bacteria that's when you get the
sniffle you get sick you're like i'm
finally resting what's going on
so you can taper out of those high
intensity phases there are actually you
know guys in the teams other
now that i think are aware of this and
are starting to think about this and for
various effects but in the mind
testosterone makes effort feel good
adrenaline puts us into a mode of
readiness dopamine puts us into a mode
of motivation and then there's the
mirror side of all this which are the
neurochemicals that broadly define
promote relaxation and parasympathetic
activation and those come under the
names that you probably heard them
before like serotonin oxytocin and the
hormone prolactin
serotonin and oxytocin are molecules
that make us feel good make us feel
soothed
not in response to things that we're
motivated to go get but in response to
what we already have so this might sound
a little woo but you know if you sit
there and do a gratitude practice or you
hang out with your dog and your kids or
you eat a meal right you're nourishing
yourself with food that you are not in
the process of having to kill first
you're just really in you know
thanksgiving um a few moments of
appreciation simple things
the feel good that you experience the
love and kindness meditations these
kinds of things
we know based on neuroimaging studies
and blood draws and things of that sort
promote the release of things like
serotonin and oxytocin
that nature has designed beautiful
systems of pursuit and
pleasure that
are designed to oscillate
and designed to keep us in pursuit and
pleasure cycles in relationships
typically the dopamine phase is the
early phase simultaneously in these
cycles oftentimes not simultaneously
typically dopamine and serotonin are
released
always there's always some floating
around our system at any moment but
typically dopamine and adrenaline are
associated with pursuit of things that
are outside the confines of our
immediate possession in our skin and
serotonin is more about the things that
we have the things you know get seeing
your kid holding your kid that promotes
the release of oxytocin and serotonin
feels amazing right these are the
molecules that led to our evolution as a
species so
i'm not diminishing one or the other but
they need to oscillate right in early
relationship
there are times when people aren't
sleeping very much it's like a mental
illness it's like it's a form of mania
you're so excited you don't need sleep
right people are able to to do all sorts
of things that frequency and intensity
that they find themselves two years
later in a relationship and they love
the person it's very warm and cozy but
well unless they're going off on
deployments and coming back they don't
have that reset of the of the system so
you know
the ability to miss somebody reset that
pursuit and desire system these are
powerful systems and they don't just
pertain to romantic relationships this
is also school i always you know i
always did summer school because i had
to do a lot of catching up to do based
on the
you know a lot of catching up
but you know there's some value in
taking a week off
and realizing you are truly resetting
all the systems for pursuit and i hear
from a lot of hard-driving folks who
like wow once i understood dopamine i
realized why i'm so burnt out people
think of adrenal burnout
guess what there's no actual medical
term adrenal burnout there's adrenal
insufficiency syndrome
that's a rare syndrome but you have
enough adrenaline packed away in your
brain and body to for three lifetimes
think about what people used to go
through i mean you talk about some of
this on your podcast you see the images
of people and you read the stories like
you can make it through finals kids
so
that what happens though is we're in
such modes of pursuit and overthinking
overthinking we need to learn how to
switch back and forth on a regular basis
what i call deliberate decompression or
non-sleep deep rest have a practice each
day of 10 to 30 minutes where you're not
on your phone and you're in kind of a
wordless state you're just either yoga
nidra or you're just relaxing or not
watching anything not taking in any
sensory information not meditating
not journaling just in a state of
just trying to blank your mind and just
watch how much stronger you come back in
terms of your ability to focus in your
motivation
that's one i love the phone and social
media has been very good to me and i
appreciate many of its features but one
of the problems is we tend to fill our
idle time with more sensory information
and that doesn't allow us to go into
this deliberate decompression it doesn't
allow us to
you remember i cut myself off but a
picture is worth a thousand words well a
movie is worth a million pictures now i
can scroll through millions of movies
very quickly and so the dopamine system
is just a little bit overwhelmed i don't
think we need to be off our phones all
the time we just take some time to just
deliberately decompress each day any
time of day
and you'll focus better so you're
getting hit with that dopamine on on
instagram so at first you are but here's
how you know
dopamine and it will give you a window
into addiction if you're if you're not
an addict you'll be able to sympathize
with maybe even empathize with addicts
of various kinds when you first get on
social media you're excited maybe you or
joe or somebody has a new podcast out
right you know you're excited oh i can't
wait to hear that's dopamine you're
motivated
but if you ever find yourself doing a
behavior and you kind of don't know why
you're doing it like this doesn't feel
any good anymore it's like that what is
that chris well now he's it's a funny
story there because the new stuff but
that chris rock thing where he's talking
about like you know when you're shanking
somebody and your heart's just not in it
like that he does this funny thing right
i think it was him you're like that like
yeah your heart's not in like why am i
here why am i what am i doing i'm not
even getting any pleasure but here i am
like a you know rap pressing a lever
well
that's the dopamine system has been
depleted
and so what you need is some time away
from it could be 10 minutes could be 10
days
and then it feels good again
true for relationships true for exercise
you know i believe in training hard and
training often but if you train too hard
too often you can't bring the intensity
that you need to get the stimulus to
adapt and pretty soon you're either
plateauing or getting worse
here's a experiment i did
with myself
uh
i went in my ice bath and i i had my pho
i was
[Music]
for whatever reason i've like wanted to
see something on social media on
instagram so i was like i'm just gonna
look it i want to waste some time so i'm
just gonna while i'm sitting in the ice
bath for you know five minutes i'm gonna
uh look at it look at social media so i
got i'm i'm on instagram in my ice bath
and normally you're in your ice bath and
you're like how long i've been in here
for you don't really want to look at
your watch you know it's like if i'm
going to torture someone when they're in
my ice bath i'm like you've been in for
30 seconds that's 37 seconds that's so
i'm going to tell them every increment
of time because you're not going to let
it all blur together
so you know i always hold off on looking
at my watch you know when i'm in there
i'm just gonna wait you know because
it's not gonna be as long as you thought
it was
so i'm in that mode i'm looking at
instagram so my hands aren't in it but
still it's like i'm looking at instagram
and
i go how long has it been it's probably
been
it's probably been at least i'm probably
at the three minute mark right now
i roll over look at my watch them at
like 5 20.
so
i got that that's how people look at
their freaking screen and all of a
sudden they look up and they've wasted
28 minutes on there because i mean i was
in it in cold water you know and time
went by a little bit quicker imagine if
you were sitting in a relaxing chair or
whatever you know that stuff's gonna
slip by you and and next thing you know
you've been looking at your phone for 22
minutes or a half an hour you know you
can write 500 words for a book in a half
an hour you know like you can do you can
do a lot of things in half an hour
that are going to benefit you as a human
being
instagram isn't one of them right the
algorithm is going to get you that's
right it's going to get you and and and
if you want to create content you build
the raw materials you you find and build
on the raw materials for that content
away from
the place where you distribute that
content i always tell myself that i love
reading scientific papers and books but
instagram can draw me in too i always
say the the gems exist outside of social
media and i want to bring those to the
podcast into social media
so the deeper i can read into the
library or to these papers the more i
can bring
you i'm glad you brought up time
perception because
dopamine and serotonin and the states
they are associated with so broadly
speaking dopamine and
adrenaline or serotonin and oxytocin are
associated with different perceptions of
time here's
the best way to think about this
is
if you've ever had a day that was really
exciting
or out think to an op that was
particularly
exciting or difficult or challenging
required a lot of focus it's amazing how
quickly you perceive that day going by
but then when you look back on it it
feels like so much happened
now think about waiting in the doctor's
office
it feels like it goes on forever
and yet you look back on it and it feels
like nothing happened
dopamine and adrenaline change our
perception of time we micro sliced time
but it seems like everything goes by
really fast and then we look back like
we did this and then we did that and we
did that thing for your when you're a 10
year old and it's your birthday like so
much happened so much dopamine
then think about the most boring phase
of doing nothing you look back nothing
happened why it's all about how these
neuromodulators shift our perception of
time our gaze and our understanding of
the outside world and so on
so you can imagine that if you're on
instagram and you're scrolling and
scrolling and not a whole lot is
happening
and
you go oh my god time all this time went
by but nothing happened well you're not
in a high dopamine state
when you're in a high dopamine state you
will know because life feels exciting
you'll almost feel a readiness in your
nervous system because you know some
people will even tremble a little bit
that's the readiness for action because
again these are generic molecules they
didn't evolve for social media or for
gun fights or for rolling jiu jitsu or
for taking final exams or studying for
them they evolved to either put us into
states of readiness and pursuit or
relaxation
and so once you understand that we all
have both systems in us
but
that some people the seesaw is just
naturally tilted a little bit toward one
side or the other other excuse me
then you're in a position to really
control it as opposed to it controlling
you and there's a term that i like to
use when thinking about this we all
think about stress but really there are
two kinds of stress
there's the i'm too activated i'm too
alert and i need to calm down
and then there's the i'm too calm and i
need to lean into action and i refer to
this as limbic friction your limbic
system controls these very basic states
of being alert or being stressed or
being calm
but your forebrain this incredible
real estate just behind your forehead
is what controls what we call top-down
modulation it's the look at the watch oh
it's 4 45. choco's already up like i
needed this but wait hold on if i get
into action adrenaline would come
thoughts actually allow us to overcome
our limbic tendency to just want to go
back to sleep or
if i'm very very stressed i can quickly
calm down i can just pass along there's
actually a physiological tool to calm
down it wasn't discovered by me it was
discovered in the 1930s there's a
pattern of breathing
that every person and every mammal does
when carbon dioxide builds up too much
in the bloodstream and it's called a
physiological side this is two inhales
through your nose
and then a long full exhale looks crazy
but believe it or not we all do this
once every five minutes or so this
podcast is like the uh documentation of
the release of that because i
i s i'll be reading something just super
stressful or even talking to someone
that you know was in a terrible
situation you can go listen to this
podcast and you'll hear like just
silence then you hear me go
you know like it's so obvious that i do
that to release the the stress that i
have from you know listening to someone
or or dragging some horrible story out
of someone
exhales
slow the heart down inhale speed the
heart up there's something called
respiratory sinus arrhythmia so for when
you inhale
basically what happens is your diaphragm
moves down right
it actually moves down there's actually
more space in your
cat the cavity that your heart sits in
blood flows more slowly through that
larger volume the heart got a little
bigger the brain sends the signal speed
the heart up when you exhale that
diaphragm moves up heart gets a little
smaller blood moves more quickly through
that smaller space brain sends a signal
to slow the heart down if you increase
the duration or the intensity of exhales
relative to inhales you'll calm down
increase the intensity or the duration
of inhales relative to exhales
you will become more alert through these
brain stem centers that were not
discovered by me but by this brilliant
guy at ucla named jack feldman who found
the two brain areas that are responsible
for this physiological size reopen all
the small sacs in the lungs so that you
can then offload the maximum amount of
carbon dioxide when you exhale so the
big deep inhale through the nose and
then squeeze in a little bit more air
reinflates the little sacs in the lungs
and allows you to offload carbon dioxide
on the long exhale that follows you do
this in sleep
people who have apnea don't do this well
apnea is very dangerous it actually will
shorten your life lead to all sorts of
issues
not good
people will use the cpap or they'll
learn to mouth breathe or do these kinds
of things you can also use physiological
size between rounds and jiu jitsu
to calm down if you want to calm down or
you can do more inhales if you want to
ramp up i mean fighters know this stuff
intuitively and they know how to use
breath but none of these are hacks these
are defined circuits that we all come
into the world with and the reason i say
they're not hacks is they work the first
time and they work every time because
guess what you're using them all the
time anyway we're just not normally
aware and so
you can
when you're speaking a lot oftentimes
you'll feel stressed because you're not
taking a few moments to do these double
inhales and exhales as i'm doing now but
if you're having trouble sleeping
do some long exhale breathing you'll
notice you'll calm down if so i call
these real time tools because they don't
involve stepping away from what you're
doing
the other cool thing about the
physiological side is that the nerve
that controls the diaphragm is called
the phrenic nerve and it has a little
branch we call this a collateral that
goes to the liver and a few other organs
if you're ever running and you get that
side stitch it's you think it's a cramp
that is not a cramp that has to do with
your pattern of breathing in the
movement of the diaphragm and the
phrenic nerve sometimes gets into a
pattern of firing that's not quite
optimal you're getting what's called
referred pain of the liver and the pain
inside the body is not as precise as it
is on the surface of the body
what do you do well we used to be told
oh you run with your hands over your
head or you need more water all you have
to do is a few physiological size and
you'll reset the pattern of breathing to
the correct motion so the next time you
have a side stitch or a cramp just do a
few double inhale exhales while running
and that referred pain will just
disappear
so you mentioned the
the limbic system so i'm sitting here
you're painting this picture when you're
talking about serotonin testosterone and
dopamine you you get this picture in
your head like wow every human being
should just be running at this optimum
thing where hey i'm gonna go get some
testosterone award reward for my
dopamine and then when i'm done with
that i'm gonna go hug my kids and it
seems like we should be in this perfect
cycle of where everything is great
because we're either in pursuit or we're
in gratitude and this is great
unfortunately we all know that that's
not the reality and people end up in
this weird thing where they they don't
go in
in pursuit and matter of fact they they
don't go in pursuit at all they don't
even get off the couch we we have people
that don't appreciate what they've got
and so so is that the limit what is the
opposing force to these two totally
positive things that we've got out there
of hey i've got this dopamine reward
system when i go out i'm gonna do some
squats i'm gonna feel great when i get
done i'm gonna see my dog i'm gonna pet
him i'm gonna feel great like it life is
great
what is the opposing force on these
things that trips us up
yeah very important question and um
fortunately or unfortunately we have an
answer which is that
we can
now access
dopamine release without any effort at
all
high
flavor high calorie density food right
it's probably rare in nature at one
point we had to work hard in order to
get game get grains get berries so it
was it used to be effort
dopamine
relaxation repeat
now you can get enough dopamine from
food remember the rat just sitting there
doesn't it it won't cross the cage
even because it has no dopamine but most
people are like the rat just sitting
there just popping just on the couch i
saw this on the plane and i'm not being
disparaging of anybody but i sat down
next to this person
and
it was and i was i was not shocked i was
actually just really dismayed this
person was sitting there kind of like
hooded eyes i don't think they had been
drinking alcohol didn't smell like it
just popping cheetos into their mouth
like a rat just
feeding from a dispenser just the whole
time just passively right so you're
getting this low level of dopamine lots
of calories lots of
with no activity yes they're phenotype
as we'd say in biology was as you would
predict and it was just really sad there
was no there was i think that when it's
it's fair to say that
dope
high levels of dopamine achieved without
effort
will destroy a person
whether or not that comes through a high
potency drug or a high potency food
if it comes within an intensity in a
frequency that's too high that doesn't
require effort it will destroy a person
so what else is there there's food we
can get a dopamine hit from cheetos
anything pleasurable
tv extremely pleasurable yes i would say
does tv work yeah i would say i'm here
i'm borrowing from anna lemke's work
she's again a medical doctor who focuses
on dopamine and addiction but also
behaviors
that relate to addiction video game
addiction for instance social media or
youtube addiction i can give you one
very salient example this
when we're getting you know let's say
that dopamine it doesn't work actually
work this way but let's just say with
arbitrary units can be released at
anywhere from zero to a hundred level
let's say methamphetamine is a hundred
because we know it does evoke a lot of
dopamine release let's say um a nice
pizza after a good long run
is uh 20.
what about a nice pizza after uh
watching a netflix show yeah is that i'm
saying is that
is there is that also going to be a 20
or is that only a 10 because you didn't
really earn it ah well it can be very
pleasurable but what's going to happen
is that you're still getting dopamine
and it's incremental right remember i
said earlier stacking dopamine is
dangerous it's not that you have one
reservoir or one kind of hydraulic
system putting a pressure for dopamine
and then you spend it all and it comes
back you have multiple things so if
you're listening to music and you're
eating and you're having a good time
that's great i mean that's life i mean
we want to encourage people not be total
stoics and they want to enjoy life but
what's going to end up happening if
you're just sitting there eating high
calorie food taking in a lot of sensory
information that has you really wrapped
with attention
there's really no incentive to be
motivated to do anything else at a
biological level so then someone's in
fact i was talking to my podcast
producer he had a friend in college that
was a spectacular student early on and
got really into video games and there
came the day to move out of their house
and everyone was packing up and moving
out and this guy didn't have his stuff
together and the trucks were literally
coming he's like and they realized he
actually can't do anything he's only
seems to be getting his dopamine from
this one behavior
i i have a close friend whose son
graduated from high school
was going to community college
and pretty soon developed what he
thought was a case of pretty severe adhd
and depression
obviously that can happen young guy i've
known him he's always been a swimmer and
an athlete very impressive kid good
looking kid always very sociable
and pretty soon he wasn't going his
community college classes he wasn't
working no relationship living at home
with the parents this is what they call
failure to launch all right pretty scary
at 20 much scarier 25.
he heard onolemki talk to on a different
podcast
about the dopamine system and he
realized that he's spending all his time
on youtube video games he got a little
bit into crypto and was kind of dabbling
there nothing and he went on a complete
fast of all these things
and i'm pleased to say that he's
complete now he's now lives with his
girlfriend he's got a job he's
completely off any adhd meds and i
realize some people do need these adhd
meds guess what adhd meds are ritalin
adderall vivants they all trigger the
release of dopamine
it's a way of getting dopamine and some
people really need that
but you can imagine if you're getting it
from all these sensory stimuli youtube
et cetera and listen i love youtube i
appreciate them but you it's a potent
stimulus you can find pretty much
anything on there yeah and so the key
you asked why are we so off balance why
can't we just do this naturally is
because naturally we just want pleasure
we really do as a species just seek
pleasure and avoid pain
all species do that
and now it takes a very deliberate
forebrain oriented person who really
actually associates their value and
their self-image with effort
and reward not just reward to get
through this jungle of you know
plants that can basically just grab us
and pull us down
and we see it everywhere and
it should not surprise us at all and so
is the key to completely discard with
any pleasures no the key is put effort
in front of pleasure
and you will have a and learn how to
relax and access these other systems of
serotonin etc and appreciation and if
you can do that you can completely
control the trajectory of your life but
pleasure without effort preceding it is
absolutely deadly
it's uh
you clued me in on this one echo
variable rewards
so like even when you're looking at uh
youtube right and you click on a video
it and it looks good it's got a good
thumbnail
right it's good clicking guys they told
us you know thumbnails with with crazy
eyes actually get more clicks okay so
there you go so you get lured in on that
but it's not quite as good as you want
so then but you see another one and so
you click on that one and it's not quite
as good but then you click on one and so
it's pretty good you know it had a good
freaking
car crash in it or whatever it is that
you wanted to see
and so then it you get that variable
reward
in instagram you get it in youtube and
and and where it's like you get a little
spike like oh there it is that was a
really good meme
or whatever that one made me laugh you
know you have to look at seven memes
that are dumb
and then you see a good one and then you
go well maybe the next one will be good
too and you want that little hit it's
freaking disturbing how does it do with
anticipation right or something like
that yes
you guys are are teaming me up with the
exact language so the best schedule for
maintaining motivation over time is
called random intermittent reinforcement
this is what the slot machines do this
is gambling the reason people go to
vegas go i like it to do a little bit of
gambling i like to sit there i like the
dumb gambling i like roulette i just
like to sit there and watch the wheel go
i don't like to have to think too hard
or look at the cards or anything just
put things on numbers eventually get
something and go you know sometimes i
win sometimes i lose but it's always a
set amount why do i like this
well it's boring boring oh and then boom
you hit you hit you get 18 to 1 on
something that's random intermittent
reinforcement is the most powerful
reinforcement schedule in all species
for all things
some people even all species all things
all species random
all mammalian species intermittent
reward yeah give a rat a reward for
pressing a lever every time it actually
will press that lever less often you'll
get its dopamine fix all right it's the
person next to me eating cheetos on the
plane they'll keep doing it but not with
this they won't work to do it
whereas if you give it to them every
fifth time animals and people learn
intuitively they're not necessarily even
counting they just know how fast they
need to press before they get it again
random intermittent reinforcement means
if you're not expecting a reward you get
more dopamine so you said anticipation
so there's something in the dopamine
literature
that is called
reward prediction error if you
anticipate a reward and it comes you get
some dopamine if you don't anticipate a
reward and it comes you get even more
dopamine from the same reward and if you
anticipate a reward and it doesn't come
guess what dopamine drops below baseline
hey kids we're going to go get ice cream
yeah yeah yeah you get to the ice cream
shop closed
not good you crashed them below now
you're negotiating trips to disneyland
right
if you
are walking by an ice cream shop you
turn to them you say ice cream
bigger dopamine release from the actual
ice cream
this is a very powerful modulator of our
behavior so anticipation is key because
remember dopamine isn't about the
pleasure dopamine is about the
anticipation of pleasure and this there
are beautiful experiments if people want
to learn more about this just put reward
prediction error the guy wolfram schultz
uh yes um was the guy who over in
germany who discovered a reward
prediction error he found that the
neurons in the brain that control
dopamine release are firing before you
get the reward then you get the reward
and goes up a little bit and it drops
and that drop is the pain that you feel
afterwards why to keep animals and
humans motivated to go pursue more
and a lot of
our behavior can be understood through
reward prediction error this also
pertains again human relationships don't
tell somebody a restaurant is so
incredible or a blank is so incredible
don't build yourself up to be so
incredible if you want to actually be
experienced as that incredible
anticipation is wonderful but then you
better bring it because if you don't
you are going to sink dopamine way lower
than you would have otherwise so
surprise is one of the wonderful
elements of the dopamine circuitry and
if you think about an animal foraging
for food or human foraging for food this
is what led to people you know looking
for game to kill well you're a hunter
right maybe you're a hunter as well i've
done any hunting but i've done some
fishing and you're kind of like oh this
he went to vaughan's pretty much
but i'm good he's pretty good yeah yeah
what do you hunt for just kidding and
it's a real stretch to call me hunter i
got into hunting a few years ago and
have been going hunting each year and uh
very very cool very
um
very rewarding uh very difficult very
very rewarding yeah it's um
you know because that's a very dynamic
system as are gunfights and whatnot it's
not just about hitting targets on a
range obviously
the other person or the animal gets a
vote too and so that's that we we crave
that as human beings and combat taps
into that and basic mating interactions
and the things that lead up to that you
know the the dance that is human
evolution of of mating and aggression
and all these other things uh you know
all tap into the dopamine system and we
experience winds and then we try and
make predictions about where we will
experience wins again based on our
previous history and yet what keeps us
it would be so boring if you always knew
the deer was going to be standing right
next to that tree looking at you right
one reason i like cam haines's videos
and i watch those is i love the
unpredictability of it i'm also always
amazed at how many objects are in front
of them and obviously a very skilled
hunter
so it's the uncertainty that that
certainly people in special operations
you know it's it's defined by
uncertainty the rules are
set and yet there's this huge set of
variables for which you need to be able
to adapt in real time that's going to
lead to more dopamine increase than
anything else yeah it's it's interesting
because the
the hunting thing like how does it
compare to combat i've had guys ask me
that
and
there's a really big difference
is that that you know that thing's not
gonna shoot back at you but if you go
and hunt like a grizzly bear
with a bow and arrow and you mess up
that thing absolutely will kill you so
that does go that does get very close to
the the same kind of uh scenario that
you're dealing with and i'm sure the
dopamine hit and i haven't hunted any
bear yet but that's got to be a next
level
absolutely i mean i remember
backpacking in glacier and running into
a bear cub pop you know eating berries
on the trail we took the bear bell off
you know those bear bells are really
annoying and the whole time we're
walking with these bear bells let's take
these bear bells off ignore the ranger
you know and we're hiking out and sure
enough there's a bear cub sitting there
and you go oh first you go bear cub and
then you go bear cub
so uh absolutely there's you know these
systems again are are oriented toward
our survival our reproduction our drive
when we meet people that are very driven
typically it's because they have systems
like yourself like yourself i mean then
these systems
almost always are designed
to overcome what i refer to earlier as
limbic friction it's rarely that someone
has just a system of making everything
easy
that allows them to be continually
motivated i think this is one of the big
misconceptions people think oh and we've
done episodes on the huberman lab
podcast like workspace optimization and
i always sort of hesitate to do these
episodes because it's true if you put
your computer screen up as opposed to
looking down at it you'll be alert for
longer because of what we were talking
about before eye positioning if you have
a standing desk you probably alert
because standing actually you know and
so on and so forth but
what you find is that people that
display
motivation over long periods of time
have systems that put them into limbic
friction and then overcome limbic
friction again and again remember effort
then reward
and many people are looking for the
tools the hacks and the tricks that are
going to take all the effort part out
what you do what you want to do is build
the effort and the limbic friction in
and then the reward in on a consistent
basis briefly again on the limbic
friction yeah so how where's that coming
from yeah so you have areas of the brain
in the old days people used to call them
ancient and then now people don't like
that but basically there are parts of
the brain that exist in humans and in
other animals like the hypothalamus
which is a cluster of neurons basically
above the roof of your mouth little tiny
real estate within the nervous system
but controls things like
motivation aggression
rage sex behavior temperature these are
clusters of new of what we call nuclei
little clusters of neurons that control
all these different primitive states so
much so that if i were to just tickle
one of those with an electrode i could
put you into a rage state like that
there's a wonderful video if people want
to see it it's a little disturbing for
people who can't handle this stuff from
david anderson's lab at caltech you can
put d you can put anderson lab
aggression mating into youtube
two mice
electrode in an area of the brain called
the ventromedial hypothalamus
stimulate one category of neurons in
there using some neuroscience tricks
and the animal immediately goes over and
starts to mate with the female animal
okay
turn those neurons off there are ways
you can do this instantaneously and
remotely turn on the neurons in the
ventral medial hypothalamus that are
distinct from those and the animal
starts to kill the other animal
put that animal alone in a cage with a
glove filled with air
stimulate these neurons it tries to kill
the glove
looks like a kid at an agnostic front
shows just swinging his arms
like that you know just rage although
that's a controlled rage
so
we have switches in the hypothalamus
then we have this real estate that we
call the prefrontal cortex which is
controls rational decision making
has access to the hippocampus with
information about the past the present
and the future
right when we're in states of rage it's
all about now states of stress it's all
about now states of fear it's all about
now the prefrontal cortex can draw on a
memory bank of experiences from the past
the present and future for better or for
worse and say
the last time we tried to cross this
bridge with our team things didn't work
out so well
let's stop
let's think
or we're under attack
you immediately want to respond what do
you guys call swift violent action but
sometimes i'm guessing there's a time to
like regroup
swift violent action in a more
successful way okay i'm just borrowing
language from your community
that ability to tamp down basic
physiological responses is controlled by
the forebrain
suppressing
the limbic pathways so there's a
friction between our rational mind and
these impulses
there's a famous case of the guy that
was working on the railways every
psychology student learns about this
spike through his forebrain it went
through orbital frontal cortex as
prefrontal cortex what happened well the
story goes that he became sort of
inappropriate so if he didn't like you
he'd tell you i don't like you he'd
swear at you he went to church before he
was a real good guy after that he was
you know screaming at people and caught
profanities and things like that um
there's a condition called clever busy
syndrome which relates to a different
brain area but also the forebrain where
animals or people will start to mate
with inanimate objects
right this is inappropriate behavior
according to the limbic system but they
don't see as inappropriate because they
their forebrain is shut down so limbic
friction describes the the tension in
this neural circuitry between the
forebrain and these reflexes and
remember it has two sides one is the
ability to suppress action and the other
is the ability to engage action when you
would otherwise want to be relaxed and
because that's because some of the areas
of the hypothalamus are involved in
relaxation so you want to stay in bed to
be honest you know for me i hope for
many people there's a strong pull to
stay under the covers and sleep longer
tell yourself that you know you heard on
a podcast that sleeps important and all
this stuff you dive dementia if you
don't sleep enough and you have to tell
yourself no
no it's the effort followed by the
reward that i'll feel later that's the
ticket and so that's an example of
limbic friction that you overcome where
the forebrain takes over now you're in
action you're in forward center of mass
or you're exhaust so that's overcoming
exhaustion or so the so the limbic
system can screw you in
both ways it could screw me in like i
lose my temper and attack you and i end
up going to jail because i because i
stabbed you in the neck because i lost
my temper
it can also screw me by
hey
you know you don't really don't feel
like going to work out right now and you
should just stay in bed because it's
nice and comfortable here yeah so your
limbic system yeah yeah well then you
can rationalize that sure end up there
but but that's a limbic system driving
me to just want to stay in bed or wanna
hey you know this freaking uh uh cotton
candy tastes great and i should just eat
more of it and just keep shoving it in
my mouth that's right limbic system in
action that's right and a lot of
treatments for phobias and anxiety
disorders that are related to cognitive
behavioral therapy are progressive
exposure so a person afraid of snakes
you give them a picture of a snake then
you have them imagine a snake then
they're looking at rubber snake then
they're holding a snake what are you
doing you're you're allowing them to get
into small incremental steps of forward
action they get them closer and closer
but you're to the anxiety but you're
also ratcheting down the anxiety what
i'm talking about and i think what the
practices that you've talked a lot about
really relate to is recognizing
that friction of being tired but
knowing that you should get into action
or that
feeling of being too amped up and
knowing you need to calm down
means going against yourself
in a way that is not incremental
sometimes can feel huge this is why i
think you know anyone who's going to try
an ice bath don't freeze to death but
you know start at 45 degrees and move
your limbs around and experience what a
lot of adrenaline is really like and you
know if you do it appropriately you
won't die and
you will come out of there you'll get
that dopamine rush and the thing to
think about is not how great it feels
you want to think about how hard it is
and then how great it feels those two
things need to be coupled in one's mind
and the power of mindset is something
that has been talked about all the time
the secret or on the you know in social
media but i have a colleague at stanford
seems like i only refer to experiments
at stanford but hey it's a good place um
if there is an analog to the seal teams
in academia can we borrow that sorry um
there are other good places too there's
some schools on the east coast i hear as
well the um i'm just kidding but i do
bat for the home team but they they're
they're experiments elsewhere of course
but my colleague ali crum
uh
her name is aliyah but she goes by ali
chrome is a professor of psychology
tenured professor of psychology former
division one athlete
trained clinical psychologist and
actually her dad is a martial artist and
has done some work with your community
incred and she has a few papers on seals
and i'll explain what those are she
studies mindsets
and the power of mindset and she studies
the physiology so none of this stuff is
wishy-washy and here's the interesting
thing
you take two groups of people
she's taken two groups of people one
group watches a movie about stress the
other group watches a movie about stress
the first group watches a movie about
stress and learns all the true
information about stress
disrupts your memory
it causes deficiencies in
decision making and blah blah all the
terrible things that stress can do the
other group
learns all the positive things that
stress can do can activate your immune
system can sharpen your focus can
enhance your memory if it's done in the
appropriate way etc
then you test people with a number of
things like memory tests you test their
immune system you do blood draws you
look at how much stress hormone they're
making guess what whatever you learned
and believe that's what happens
they've done the same experiment with
two milkshakes
okay you give one group of milkshake you
tell them this is a high calorie high
fat high sugar milkshake there's lots of
nutrients in it you give the other group
a milkshake you say this is a modest to
low calorie milkshake
then you have them drink the milkshake
you take blood draws and you look at the
insulin response you look at the amount
of ghrelin which is a hunger
a hormone that's secreted in response to
hunger it makes you hungry basically
and guess what it's the same milkshake
and yet you get higher insulin response
to the high calorie the thought that
it's a high calorie shake you get lower
insulin well you still get an insulin
response in response to the idea that
it's a lower calorie shake the ghrelin
response is suppressed so you get it
your hunger doesn't show up for longer
if you have the so-called high calorie
shake staves off hunger whereas if you
had the low calorie shake you're hungry
again earlier and ghrelin levels go back
up really all based on belief and there
are numerous things like this and so
ali's words are the best words for this
and i'm probably not going to get them
exactly right but
what we do
and the physiological consequences of
what we do is the consequence of what we
do what we eat how we exercise but also
what we believe about what we do now
this does not mean that you can just lie
to yourself you can't say oh this you
know you know four by four from in and
out is only a hamburger and it's not
gonna have a big insulin that doesn't
work
but what you can do to eat a protein
style
it's pretty safe or there's the flying
dutchman i've heard you know that one i
haven't had the vlad i think that's just
meat on on a piece of paper oh okay so
now all those carnivores are gonna be
you know going through that's why i give
costello my bulldog
um i think they still use that the uh
the off the menu menu so basically if
you tell yourself the friction that i'm
feeling
of not wanting to get out of bed and the
reward i will feel later actually is
building a system within me and that is
a true statement you will build that
system within you if you believe this is
just overcoming pain so that i can drop
those pounds so that i don't have to
feel terrible about myself well
you won't build that system and this is
the beauty and the mystery of the brain
which is that the forebrain can draw on
all these contextual things you can
really give meaning to what would
otherwise just be basic limbic
experiences now there aren't
an infinite range of ways to do this i
can't cut myself with this little you
know butter knife here and say
just kidding because i can't cut myself
with this dagger that my fingers barely
fill by the way someone's got some big
mitts i can't put it through my hand and
tell myself i didn't do that right there
are limits to this the laws of physics
still apply the laws of physiology still
apply but as we learn from the example
of the milkshakes
or the example about stress positive or
negative learning is about stress
there
is a range of physiologies that we can
experience according to something i
think this has important implications
too for things like ptsd
interpreting at the experiences of past
just telling oneself oh it wasn't that
big of a deal won't work but telling
oneself that there's no way to come back
from that
also is not true yeah
um
there's a couple things that i've been
i've been talking about for a while the
the one i'm gonna start with is this
idea i've been telling people for a
while hey listen you got tendencies so
we all have different tendencies you
might have a tendency let's say from a
leadership perspective that you're a
micromanager and you've got to be aware
of that tendency because if you don't if
you're not aware of it and you don't try
and counter it you're going to always
end up micromanaging maybe you have a a
tendency to be hyper aggressive and
you're too aggressive and you go and
make you try to run to the sound of the
guns without really taking a step back
so you have to understand what your
tendencies are
and then you've got to say
my tendency also might be right so now
i'm thinking about this from
and and i also say hey listen as a
leader
you got to watch the crowd and you got
to pay attention to make sure that the
crowd is going in the right direction
when the crowd starts to get fired up
about something like yeah we need to go
assault that building we need to go
solve that building
you should say to yourself
you should think to yourself the
contrary you should think okay wait a
second is that the right thing to do
right now because it's really easy to
get caught up in the crowd and it's now
i'm noticing a similar thing with our
limbic system like there's a chance that
your limbic system is correct absolutely
but you need to be aware of the tendency
of your limbic system and make sure that
what that freaking uh
little tiny part of your animal brain is
thinking you need to put it in check and
sometimes you go yep it's the right
thing to do right now i should get
aggressive i should go on the attack but
you need to run it through that check
first
the other thing is
when you're talking about milk shakes
and what what your attitude is i mean
this is just cl this is just so clear
when you you know from a leadership
perspective if we get told hey we gotta
go freaking do this this mission and
it's gonna be a real you know a real
tough mission it's gonna be the
weather's horrible
and and that's how you bring it to the
boys hey guys we got tasked with this
mission it's gonna be freaking horrible
the weather's gonna be bad we're gonna
be freezing if that's how you bring it
to the boys that that's gonna be the
attitude all day long if you come down
and you say hey listen
check this out
there's a mission coming down it looks
like it looks like it's a very tough
situation
they know that we're the only ones that
can probably be able to get this done
we're going to have this opportunity to
go out there and get this get this
mission done it's going to be hard but
it's going to have a big impact
attitude's 100 180 out right so we have
so much control just by what we're
thinking and then if you're in a
leadership position the way you present
things
it it's gonna it's gonna sway the way
people think now i'll also tell you this
if you get told to do something horrible
and you truly believe it's horrible and
you go down and say hey guys this is
gonna be if you basically lie to them
they're going to all know that you're
lying like you can't fool you it's very
difficult to fool a group of people into
you know positive thinking or what's the
the secret or the secret book right
that's where it's like hey it's all
coming up it's very hard to fool someone
into that but if you believe hey this is
what we're doing this is a huge
opportunity this can be a tough mission
but it's going to be worthwhile if
that's what you believe
other people are going to get on board
with that and you really are going to
have a totally different attitude going
into it as far as the uh
the ptsd thing you know one i don't know
when i heard this
but this impacted my whole
my whole thoughts on war
um
it was
i i want to say it might have been bob
dole you know bob dole was a world war
ii guy who's wounded you know he never
had um uh i think one of his hands
didn't work very well
but i remember hearing him say and i'm
pretty sure it's him please don't i'm
sorry if i if i'm getting some getting
this wrong but
he said
simply put he said war made me better
and that is the 180 out of what a lot of
guys get told right now war is going to
make you crazy it's going to make you
depressed it's going to make you an
adrenaline junkie it won't be any way to
satisfy and guys hear that and you're
going to have a hard time adjusting and
we're going to have to try and
assimilate you back into society because
it's going to be so hard because of what
you've seen whereas bob dole or whoever
this veteran was like a war is going to
make me better
and i always i've used that myself i've
used that when people have said to me
why no
do you fee was it hard for you do you
say when you look back and you've seen
you've lost friends it's like no
all that stuff look it was horrible
but
my perspective is better i i appreciate
life more because i know that life can
be lost very easily i appreciate freedom
more because i know the price that was
paid for it that didn't make me worse
actually made me better so i think we
have to be careful of that kind of thing
and you you can also then go down the
whole road of like a social contagion
where you've got people reinforcing
behaviors or reinforcing mindsets and it
starts to spread where now everybody's
thinking well you know if you went to
war you must be messed up and then i
think well if i went to war i guess i
must be messed up because that's what
that's what we're doing and this goes
across the board with you know you
mentioned the one guy earlier that was
uh cutting the bottom of his feet right
and you hear these horrible stories
that's a social contagion where
these outbreaks of of girls
primarily girls you know
12 to 16 years old
would be cutting themselves and it's
something that would oh that's what
we're doing it was kind of this these
things would spread and uh um you know
we talked about on one of our other
podcast uh
i think it was
bulimia right that started
a guy wrote an article about it there
had been some small number of cases ever
oh right i heard about this a little
while and then
he
he wrote an article about it and this is
i want to say in the 70s maybe and all
of a sudden they have
tens of thousands if not hundreds of
thousands of cases because people said
oh they they get this idea and look it
is a real thing and that he was
reporting or
you know documenting people this really
happened to but once people got that
idea it was like oh that's what we're
doing and you see this with a lot of
a lot of strange things that are
spreading right now
in in in america and worldwide where you
go hey that that's
that didn't that wasn't a thing not too
long ago right that wasn't a thing not
too long ago and now it is
a couple of reflections um some that
pertain specifically the seal teams but
what you're referring to is the fact
that nervous systems are profoundly
impacting each other so your example of
the group is getting really ramped up we
want to fight let's go you know swift
while in action now and you're stepping
back as the leader and saying wait
you're effectively acting as the
forebrain over a group that's
effectively acting as a limbic system
that's exactly what i was trying to say
yeah so
and so nervous systems
can be studied in isolation or in groups
it's harder to do that in the laboratory
although there are people that are
starting to put two people into a
scanner and having them interact and
seeing how the brain areas interact it's
harder to do for obvious reasons
ali krum's group actually did a study
which simply asked
do you think stress harms you or grows
you and measured physiologies cortisol
etc
and there was only one group
that
across the board answered stress grows
you and it was seals so she's done work
on military communities and she's done
work on civilians and that's a published
paper you can find it on her website she
runs our mind body lab at stanford
really a brilliant person who
i think it's the experience that the
reason listed off all her credentials or
some of her credentials
of athlete etc is that she really
understands the mind-body relationship
from a first-person experience it's not
just a a geek in a lab you know it's not
geek at all actually but
very very smart the other thing is that
is this notion of social contagion and
and we are
profoundly influenced by sensory
experience and one of the most intense
sensory experiences are the words and
actions of others some people are drawn
more toward or are
shifted more by other people's emotional
states we sometimes
hold up empathy as this ideal but
empathy is very dangerous
because empathy for the wrong in the
wrong context you know your kid freaking
out about an experience at school if you
freak out if you experience true empathy
you abandon your own emotional state
well you're not that's not effective
parenting or effective leadership so
empathy
is wonderful only in so far as it allows
us to
go in understand and then return to the
context and make better decisions and
that's a complicated set of neural
operations but again it all has to do
with
a
confidence and a
uh an ability to leave your own
emotional state go in and be comfortable
that you can get back out right so
empathy is is a razor is a double-sided
blade really interestingly uh you know
i'll i'll have the idea of empathy
raised with me a lot through through
leadership you know isn't it important
to be empathetic and
i've always made a distinction between
well what i really want to do is i want
to be better at understanding what your
perspective is so i want to truly
understand what your perspective is but
i don't really want to
actually feel what you're feeling
because now i've i might have messed up
what i'm trying to what what my
perspective is and by the way
i want to get as many different
perspectives as i can so that i can
fully see the problem and understand it
from the maximum number of angles so now
i can most easily find a solution
whereas if i dive into just looking
and feeling the way you're feeling
that's not good so yeah you can both get
drown and you know you can both drown
it's the jumping into the river to save
somebody and you can both drown i like
this notion of perspective because
inability to see throughout the lens of
other people is extremely important
obviously but
the ability to return to one's own
internal state is obviously the the one
of the hallmarks of great leadership as
you know
the
the idea of groups and how to
how bad things spread between groups
is that there's
there's this will explain a lot of what
we see on social media and in the press
there was a
set of controversial but nonetheless
important experiments done in the 1960s
by a guy named robert heath this was a
time when you could sign up for an
experiment have electrodes put into your
head and you could for a nominal amount
of money you could stimulate the
electrodes located at different
locations and tell dr robert heath what
you're experiencing this is three papers
some of which were published in the
journal science which is one of our kind
of super bowl we have the super bowl nba
championship and uh
you know stanley cup of science and they
are nature science and cell those are
the three top journals science is a very
good journal he published this paper
basically subjects were allowed to
stimulate a variety of different areas
of their brain in their own brain in
their own brain okay stimulate one area
and the person he'd say what do you ex
what do you feel and they'd say
a little drunk stimulate another area
what do you feel kind of giddy what do
you feel a little bit of anger etc and
then he would just tell people you can
stimulate any area that you want but you
have only 10 minutes to do it so they'd
play around on the keyboards too again
couldn't do this experiment now but
really cool
the area that all the subjects chose to
stimulate the most
far more more excuse me than other areas
is an area of the midline thalamus for
what for what it's worth and the
subjective experience that they all
reported
mild frustration and anger
you know what is going on here why would
human beings want to feel frustration
and anger well it turns out that this
medial thalamus area is linked up with
the dopamine system we may not like
limbic friction of the sort like
overcoming fatigue to go exercise or
stress and needing to calm down but
human beings seem to love the feeling of
being pissed off just a little bit and i
mention this not because i like this
result i i kind of hate this result but
i guess that just speaks to the result
itself which is that there's something
about it which feels motivating anger
feels good
at a low level because it puts us into a
state of activation and we like states
of activation and relaxation and guess
what it puts us in a state of activation
without us having to do anything we're
right back where we were before dopamine
hits without any effort being angry is a
dopamine hit without having to do
anything and people will sit there all
day
and i confess there are times you know
no one's ever put a negative comment on
our comment in my instagram i'm just
kidding
why do we orient to those well we could
say oh it hurts actually frankly
unless it's a you know something i
really need to pay attention i don't
really care right because typically
they're of a
of a nature that's not really meaningful
that doesn't come from a place of
understanding or you know i don't like
misunderstandings i do read comments but
you want people to understand things but
when people are just mean-spirited we'll
find ourselves orienting towards those
because being mean being a little angry
turns out to be a dopamine hit and i am
and i've become very conscious of this
because i think social media is a place
where we can all get drawn down these
paths where you can spend all day in a
battle in your head
that doesn't mean anything or worse you
can respond to things in a way that can
sink your whole career you see this i
mean
the
chair of the
psychiatry department at columbia
university was fired for a tweet that
was just a very insensitive tweet it
wasn't an anger based tweet but that
just tells me it was the tweet
there was a picture of a of a model and
he made a very insensitive remark about
her genetic lineage i just don't even
want to bring it up i don't want to
restate it because it was how long ago
was this it was recently people can
google it
i don't
i don't know what went through his mind
but here's what i know this guy's a
psychiatrist
he's one of the leading psychiatrists in
the world
and he couldn't contr think two steps
ahead for whatever reason
you know it's interesting we've been
given a hard time to to instagram a
bunch today but now you start talking
about now we're talking about twitter
because it is
it is crazy
that there's people
that are you can see it when you read
through what they're writing they are
feeling legitimate anger like i'm like
you like i'll read something like oh
it's kind of funny whatever you know
even when people are saying the person
feels powerless i can see it i see their
comment and i go gosh they must really
feel powerless in this world and i feel
sad for them but they are
pissed so they're getting a little
dopamine hit by creating just friction
in mayhem and i think a lot of people
show up i hate to demonize twitter but i
have to say instagram's a pretty kind
place on average i think there's a
certain category of people that show up
to twitter
to experience that form of dopamine they
are there to fight
but they're not there to fight outright
they're not going to meet you in the
parking lot they're not going to go
toe-to-toe on a data point they'd rather
go through and kind of find little
misunderstandings and then hijack
misunderstandings to try and elevate
their status within this so-called fight
and if you think about the range of
meaningless circular career and life
diminishing behaviors this would be at
the top near the top of the list this is
like the poor guy in the parking lot
who's you know organizing leaves in the
in the corner and you go he's lost his
mind you know it's really sad except
these are people who arguably still have
a mind to retrieve
so
this is yeah who knows arguably arguably
so you know when i saw those robert
heath results i thought gosh people
don't like to be angry people don't like
to be
pissed off and yet that low level anger
in frustration
has
direct links to the reward pathway and i
think we would all be wise to
know when we're drifting toward that
because we are all cape if listen if
this circuitry exists in us we're all
capable of it i believe the carl jung's
statement even though i'm not a
psychologist we have all things inside
of us well it's also i'm sitting here
painting myself very guilty because if
you think about like listening to
hardcore music this is this is music
that is fueled by anger and fuels anger
and it feels good like the first time i
ever heard like the crowmags
i was like oh this is what i want to
listen to now like this is it you know
the first time you hear agnostic front
you're like okay this is what i want to
listen to now because you get that
little you get that hit so that that got
me hook line and sinker man but you
channeled it into something so that's
that's anger and dopamine without effort
but then you took that and you applied
it to something you listen to it while
you train you orient towards a mindset
you know i
the examples are very nuanced and and
particular to ourselves so they're not
even worth sharing but they're they're
songs and things in my head that i hear
that allow me to show up a better person
and
i'm actually not the first to discuss as
the great neurologist oliver sacks wrote
about this you know he wrote the book
awakenings and he wrote
the man who mistook his wife for a hat
he was
looked at clinical abnormalities and
taught people about how the brain works
and based on how he breaks in these
beautiful books but he was also held the
california state record for back squat
check
respect about these books you're talking
about whatever i don't know about these
psychological things you're saying but
record in back squat exactly yeah this
is a guy who who was serious about his
physical training he talked about this
he talked about
anchoring to emotional states
through for him listening to classical
music then being able to access creative
works of writing being able to listen to
angry he talked even about things that
evoke anger and then being able to take
that anger and bring that to his ability
to work very long hours in the clinic to
help people that were on wards of
hospitals that no one would dare go down
let alone go in there and help these
people these are just imagine the worst
place to ever be placed
as a parkinson's patient or an
alzheimer's these are torture chambers
that he would go into and he would take
people out of the hospital he did
incredible humanitarian works so he
talked about channeling these these
reflexive tendencies toward good and
toward building a career and a life and
so i think listening to the chromags if
you if you can put you obviously put
that into something useful just sitting
there in your room and just listening
over and over endlessly and not leaving
and being angry at the world or looking
at what the columbine kids did just
being pissed off at everybody and then
going and just you know hosing a
cafeteria with bullets well obviously
it can go either way and so i think that
learning to harness these more primitive
states is very useful we can't eliminate
these states we can't pretend they don't
exist but you can funnel them into real
not just benevolent but really
human species growing actions yeah and i
think it's this is like a another just
to bring up this word awareness again we
got some awareness now of the dopamine
and what that crash is going to feel
like and now we can start to put that
into the calculus of how we're behaving
and now we're talking about the limbic
system and understanding and being aware
of what the limbic system is trying to
do and that it may or may not be leading
you in the right direction but you need
to use your your your own brain to
to put that thing in check and either go
with it or say no not right now so these
things to become aware of these things
very important and and
well you said this
kind of thing has only been around for a
limited amount of time most you know for
most of human history they've just been
just been this has been happening yeah
well the the effort to get the dopamine
reward has been there the um there was a
time in which violent battle was
adaptive and there are still times where
violent battle is adaptive and then
there are times when it'll completely
sink your life
right i mean i think that we're we are
in a very important time right now where
we can trigger activation of all these
neural circuitries
sitting at home we don't even have to
get out of bed
uh but we see i think the explosion of
mental illness the explosion of anxiety
and depression and adhd is absolutely
the consequence of
ready availability of pleasures without
effort
lack of understanding about how our own
basic physiology works
i have great respect for the fields of
psychology great respect
but thinking about your thinking is
useful
but knowing that you can
put a wedge in between your thinking and
your physiology is also useful not
better but also useful and so for
instance if you're somebody who suffers
from anxiety practice physiological size
long exhales if you're somebody who
feels a motivated think about how much
pleasure or or
sensory stuff and food and stuff you're
consuming without effort first start to
embrace this idea that effort followed
by reward
repeat effort reward repeat is
not it's not just something that i'm
saying it's been the signature pattern
of
life progression in individuals it's
been the signature pattern of the
evolution of our species
that was true a thousand years ago
that's true today and it's gonna likely
going to be true a thousand years from
now i mean i love the idea that
companies like neural link and stuff are
gonna develop little devices you just
trigger your motivation circuitry but
guess what dopamine is a non-infinite
but renewable resource if you just dump
all your dopamine because you stimulated
with an electrode you're you can we know
this from experiments in the lab you
keep triggering those brain areas you're
not going to be a motivated person 24
hours a day you're just going to deplete
all your dopamine so unless they have a
plan to also put dopamine back in the
system
there's no neurotechnologies that going
to overcome the technology
of the brain completely you can augment
it but you're not going to overcome it
you're not going to build a cyborg
warrior that completely discards with
the human element because everything
that you've talked about in terms of
leadership and self-control
all these four brain circuits and i've
been describing the forebrain as one
thing like
a break on the limbic system or an
accelerator on the limbic system but
it's really like spinning multiple
plates the ability to use your forebrain
it feels hard feels like
effort even if you're just sitting in a
chair because
you have to spin a plate over here and
then you have to spin and plate or you
have to think okay those guys are going
to go there then they're going to arrive
at this time then i'm going to arrive at
this time a lot of people just go ah
they they're like overwhelmed you have
to calm yourself as you know and
think okay then when they arrive and
this i mean what are these plates that
spin and give me a little bit these are
think about the four brain circuits as
working in parallel you don't have one
forebrain you have maybe five or six
four brain circuits a simple operation
would be lifting up this drink to drink
it
a more complicated thing would be trying
to think about doing this every time
ekko puts his hand on his chin
throughout the whole podcast while we're
having a conversation now i have to spin
multiple plates i have to keep things
going in real time it's a trivial
example because it's not important when
he does that but it allows me to
demonstrate that we can contextualize
anything we can say you know every time
that shadow moves to the left just a
little bit you know did that shadow move
i don't know if that shadow moved that's
a lot of vigilance but sure you can
occupy your whole forebrain with that or
you can do that while paying attention
to how many guys are out on the ground
or moving behind you so your forebrain
it goes under high demand when we sleep
we regain the capacity
to do that multiple plate spinning type
of operation and when we go into
non-sleep deep rest when we turn off
that effort we
reinstate that effort i'll just mention
one experiment there's done out of a lab
in scandinavia they had people just lie
down and do a yoga nidra type non or
just you could go online and do nsdr um
just do nstr made for it's a free script
you can listen to this do it for 30
minutes they found that
when people do that sort of exercise of
just deliberate decompression not
engaging their forebrain doing long
exhales the amount of dopamine in a
brain structure called the basal ganglia
was replenished that's very important
the basal ganglia are involved in
directing go actions
and no go
one way that people can get better
controlling their behavior in limbic
friction is i do this actually
i'm slightly embarrassed but also proud
to say 20 times a day
i find myself wanting to do something
like pick up the phone i've been wanting
to pick up that little paper clip this
whole podcast because i like it for
reasons i don't understand and not
allowing myself to do it for reasons
that are trivial but what am i doing i'm
engaging the no go pathway
so try and learn to overcome limbic
friction by forcing yourself to do
things that you don't want to do
try and force yourself to not do things
that you want to do even trivial things
and what you're doing is you're building
up these little circuitries and the
basal ganglia depend on dopamine
different receptors for go and no go but
dopamine the deep relaxation restores
your ability to do this remember
non-infinite but renewable so the more
plate spinning the more go no-go's you
perform throughout the day the more you
deplete the circuitry 30 minutes of a
non-sleep deep breath or a good night's
sleep whatever that means for you
reinstates those dopamine levels
so it's at the end of the day we're more
than a bag of chemicals but this stuff
has been baked into us
so check this out something i've been
teaching uh a decent amount lately and
it just
would be very interesting to see how
this overlays on your spinning plates so
we i've been i've been trying to teach
people like i got asked a question i was
up at a at a at an event and
at this event some of my guys that
worked for me in the seal teams were
there uh lafab and andrew paul and and
these guys happened to tell a couple
stories where like oh you know jocko did
this
he made this decision right here and it
was great and then you know andrew got
up and said oh this other time
jacqueline and so they painted me in
great light made me look really cool
and you know i was kind of you know my
eagle is inflating and then during one
of the breaks a couple of guys that were
there these are business guys they come
up you know said yeah
you know
you you have just such great instincts
it's so obvious you know as a leader
that you just have these great instincts
and i was kind of like yeah you know
it's pretty i'm you know i'm really got
really good instincts
and they kind of inflated my ego and i
felt great about myself and then i went
back we were out the woods and i went
back to my my little cabin
i started thinking to myself wait a
second
first of all
if if the only thing i have is good
leadership instincts and i'm just a good
natural leader and that's what i have
what good is it to me
to be able to talk to anyone else about
it if it's just something that i
naturally have that no one else can have
that doesn't make any sense and i said
and by the way i know for a fact i
didn't always have these things so then
i started thinking about well how do i
actually make decisions when um i've got
a bunch of chaotic things going on and i
sat down and i wrote down what my i do
in my brain when things are happening
when things are going on when there's uh
an enemy contact when there's a a
problem out on the battlefield or when
there's a business problem what am i
doing and i wrote down sort of these
these things that i think about
and
and i i ended up saying oh hey this we
went back later that night and i said
hey you guys asked me this question ask
me about my instinct well let me tell
you it's not instinct i am running a
loop in my head to check that i am going
in the right direction number one thing
i always think about is time how much
time do i have right now something's
going on and i have to make a decision
do i have 20 minutes to make that
decision do i have three minutes make do
i have to make a decision right now i
think about the fundamental laws of
combat that we talk about all the time
like hey
are we going to support each other if i
make this decision if is it going to
help us as a team if i make this
decision oh and by the way can i
communicate it simply okay if i can
communicate it simply great hey where
does this fall out on our priority list
what what number prior is this a higher
priority that we then we what we've been
doing do i need to shift priorities do i
need to tell everyone to shift
priorities or does this not fit the top
priority decentralized command can i can
i get someone can i delegate this
problem to someone else can i can i give
it to them so that i can then look up
and out and i had this so i went through
this list of things hey is this part of
the mission that we're actually trying
to do because sometimes you're on a
mission and you get distracted by
something else and all of a sudden you
get focused on that you you can't allow
yourself to do that and i have this
whole list of things of these thoughts
that i will go through and the most
important thing as i get done telling
explaining this list of things to people
is
you can't get caught
on any one of these things if you get
caught on
the time factor you'll never figure out
if this is actually part of the mission
if you only focus on hey is this part of
our mission you might run out of time
before you make a decision so
in my mind when you talk about these
spinning plates i get it and what i
realized and when you were when you were
talking about uh looking at a shadow and
paying attention to it you do have to
pay attention that you have to check on
it but you can't forget about everything
else that's going on so this is an
interesting dynamic when i when i hear
these that my frontal lobe has these
spinning plates
well i know
that i can't really pay attention to
them all at the same time so i have to
kind of check this one give it a little
spin check this one balance it check
this one balance it and if i get focused
on one another one's gonna get dropped
so that's what i do is i i i go through
and i look okay let me check this let me
check this let me check this and i keep
going around in a circle in a loop and
this can all happen in a half a second
you can do all these things over and
over again but if you get stuck in one
of these things you're going to fall
apart and this goes back to you've heard
the ooda loop
observe orient decide and act it's the
same thing you you you have to keep it
moving and if you get stuck on
trying to decide what to do if you get i
can't make a decision you're gonna fall
apart
if you get stuck in action which some
people think oh that'd be good you're
taking action no but if you are taking
action but you're not running the
feedback and seeing how this action is
affecting everything else that's
happening around you you have to do the
action then you have to go back and
observe how it's impacting the scenario
and then orient yourself to where you
are now and then decide if that was a
good action or not so this idea of
spinning plates is very interesting to
me because
they're out there i know that i know
that there's times when i have all these
plates spinning and i know that if i get
focused on one of those spinning plates
the i'm gonna drop some other ones and
then everything's gonna fall apart yeah
it's
what the examples you provide are really
key because
first of all it's high demand work
you know one can get comfortable
what we're referring to is spinning
plates
some people experience overwhelm trying
to do two things you know we we so value
this notion of focus and focus is
wonderful but we sometimes forget that
the brain does not have one spotlight of
focus the way to think about
focus is that we are old world primates
and we can do something called covert
attention so i can talk to you pay
attention to you but i can also pay
attention to echo i've got two
spotlights
i can intensify a spotlight it can start
to pay attention to some specific
feature of what you're saying or doing
and as i do that he starts to disappear
a little bit and then i can switch right
these are the attentional mechanisms of
the forebrain if you want to play that
game i assure you if we put you in a
scanner your prefrontal cortex will be
lighting up like crazy meaning high
levels of metabolic activity there
i can also take those two spotlights and
merge them to a single location
i can make them more intense i can
broaden them and i can make them more
diffuse
we don't have three spotlights we have
two
but we don't just have one and so if you
understand attention as two spotlights
maybe one that's right there and one
that's drifting
maybe two that can merge to a specific
location or if you need to when i when
we talk about spinning multiple plates
what we're talking about is toggling
back and moving those spotlights and
knowing that at one point as you
described
attention will truly be off some element
and which element it it is off of and
what it's on is crucial in in high
stakes high consequences scenarios like
you described it's vital to survival
so
we can learn how to do this however
learning how to sit down and read a book
without any distraction or
i actually like to put my phone right
next to me and do a bunch of no-gos
every time that thing calls me i just
give it a little oh no f you no
no and i you know you're practicing the
no-go pathway and reading a book the
other thing that's very useful for
developing focus is something that
people don't do often enough anymore
including me which is writing in
complete sentences
the ability to write and think in
complete sentences is hard work i have a
colleague at stanford carl deisseroth he
no doubt will win a nobel prize he's a
psychiatrist and a bioengineer and
incredibly
successful in science also his five kids
practicing clinical
psychiatrists and i i asked him you know
what is your
tool what in the world are you doing and
he says well at least once every 24
hours i sit down in a chair and i force
myself to stay completely motionless
and think only in complete sentences
for about a half an hour i tried doing
this for about five minutes it is really
tough i invite anyone to try and only
write in complete sentences for five
minutes when they journal as opposed to
[Music]
and you know we're texting we tend to
use you know descriptive clauses and we
tend to do fragments now and we're
starting now the brain thinks in kind of
fragments and symbols and that's very
efficient we wouldn't want to only think
in complete sentences but by writing
in complete sentences by forcing that
pain of writing or that pain of thinking
in a structured way
you are building up you are reinforcing
the neural circuits that support
the so-called spinning of multiple
plates the ability to move the spotlight
to a single location you're learning how
to harness the spotlight at one location
and so i think a lot of people
don't realize they can train these
circuits related to attention you might
say well how could writing complete
sentences help me multitask that doesn't
make any sense ah you're still taking
control of these attentional systems
it's like learning how to operate any
vehicle of course
it's not going to allow you to operate
that vehicle in every context and in
every way that vehicle could be operated
but you're learning the basic mechanics
of attention when you force yourself to
write in complete sentences to think or
speak in complete sentences this is why
i do the long podcast i do these two and
a half hour podcast by myself and it's
hard and i think oh this is hard but i
can't just say a half a sentence and
then just drop it because i know what
the rest of what i wanted to say it's
work but it feels good and this is the
other element which is that over time
the dopamine system can be woven into
the systems that control effort i guess
the notion of growth mindset is
you know learning to cup carol dweck's
beautiful work is learning to couple
the notion that effort is good for us
but neurochemically we can start to
experience friction and think ah this is
growing me you know in any other context
it would be corny but in this context
and because of a leah crumb's study of
navy seals i can appropriately say learn
to think about effort like a seal would
which is this is growing me in that
thought you are
releasing dopamine in response to effort
in other words the more friction you
always say good
more friction good
i actually think about that a lot i've
had some trying circumstances recently
uninteresting for sake of this podcast
and i thought god this is either going
to make or break us and i thought what
if i just decided that the more stress
now the better it's going to be and it's
instantaneous but then you have to keep
doing that and then when you wake up
sleep deprived you have to do it again
and when someone triggers you have to do
it again so i love the ooda loop and i
love that you raised for the first time
i heard you someone raised the ooda loop
not as something that's done once but
it's done over and over and over so it's
ooda loops yeah plural yeah and i think
we always hear about it as a unitary
thing but it's ooda loops like you're in
observation over here and you're in
action on this one yeah and so it's
multiple oodlers yep yeah and by the way
you're running like a tactical low-level
like real-time uh short-term ood loop
for what i'm gonna get out of this right
now but at the same time you're running
a bigger ooda loop or you should be a
strategic good loop that's looking at
like well how is this going to affect me
you know six months from now and then
you've got an even bigger one that's
going five years that's
all these different ooda loops going on
at the same time that you have to be
running yeah forgive me i didn't mean to
interrupt that's before i was just too
excited i got too excited i couldn't i
didn't suppress my forebrain the uh
interrupting is a forebrain limbic
friction
glitch
forgive me that's your forebrain
accessing
the library of past present and future
you know this uh when you talked about
here's another
interesting crossover
so
a lot of times when i talk about people
taking a step back taking a breath um
looking around it's the word i use for
them
for for doing that is detach you have to
detach from the chaos and the mayhem you
have to detach from your own emotions
well interestingly another thing i will
tell people when they've got a more of a
let's say a slow burning problem that
they want to figure out a solution for
one of the things i recommend they do
is they write down what the problem is
write down what some various solutions
are and what that does is it
it literally detaches you from the
problem because now you're having to
think through
really what this problem is and how
you're going to articulate it on a piece
of paper for yourself and then you're
going to look at it from a detached
perspective you're going to read the
words that you wrote and it really does
it really does
allow you to see a new perspective and
hopefully find a solution and another
thing i've been saying a lot lately is
the solutions to your problem
are not in the problem when you have a
problem the solutions are not in there
if the solutions were in there you just
it wouldn't be a problem you just solve
it you have to get outside the problem
you have to figure out how to take a
step back how to see it from a different
perspective because if the solution to
the problem was in the problem you would
just execute on that thing it wouldn't
even be an issue
so we have to
to take a step back and one of the best
ways to do that if you have the the time
and the opportunity to do it in usually
in what we call the military an
administrative situation meaning there's
no bullets flying
sit down write down what is going on
what the problem is maybe what some
ideas are about viable solutions but i
think it's even better just to
really detail what you see the problem
is because if you start trying to write
down solutions you're already you're
already trying to impose solutions on it
write down what the problem is
look at it take walk away from it come
back and read it again and you're gonna
start to see that you're gonna have a
better chance of finding a solution than
if you're
living inside the problem yeah i love
that i need to do it more often i used
to journal all the time one of the
problems with the phone is that it
includes the ability to write down a
quick note i'll use the notes function
where i'll put something into my voice
memos but it anytime i go back it's very
fragmented i think that writing and
writing in complete sentences or
diagramming is enormously powerful i
also there's something you said that i i
need to think about
in terms of this ability to zoom out we
don't really know what that is you know
that the feeling of being we wake up
every day and we know we recognize
ourselves in the mirror it's amazing if
you think about it and we never wonder
if we're somebody else if provided we're
not psychotic um
wait a second let me catch up with you
mentally here because i'm trying to
figure out why it's amazing that i
realize and recognize myself in the
mirror why is that amazing well we don't
really know where the notion of the self
sits in the nervous system and yet we go
through life always
experiencing things from a frame of
reference of ourselves a few people
experience out of body stuff
there's a big effort now of course to
use ketamine type therapies and
dissociative
anesthetics to
help people move out of trauma this is a
work that's being done in clinics and
i've never tried these things or been
part of these trials but every time i
hear a patient's report about it they
say i experience myself as getting out
of the car seeing myself in the car of
myself like you know normally we wake up
and we're in our body and we go
i think that's amazing but you know i'm
a neuroscientist i wanted to understand
what your perspective is yeah i get it
now yeah it's it's it's incredible
because it's and we don't know where
that sits there's no brain region or
brain circuit that's there's no clinical
syndrome
that people dissociate from self in that
way
maybe multiple personalities but that's
more rare than most people believe but
dissociative states are rare and so we
we go through life mostly from this
perspective of me me me me and one thing
that's been very helpful to
me at least has been
a colleague again carl dicero said you
know most of the time
we have no idea how other people feel in
fact most of the time we don't even know
how we feel we don't even know how to we
don't even have a language that can
explain feelings i don't know if how you
feel right now it relates at all to my
understanding of how you feel we can
start really drifting into the the weird
and abstract and as you've noticed up
until now i'm a pretty nuts and bolts
guy i like physiology
i love physiology of the nervous system
and hormone systems that's mainly what
i've worked on but i like actionable
tools i like you know in the military
right it's uh i have to assume that
before a gunfight you can't just say all
right guys be brave and go in with a
full heart right you need like this is
what happens when x happens you need
plans you need protocols and in science
and neuroscience there are now protocols
we've been talking about those but then
there are the more abstract notions of
the self and others and how to do that i
think that's really where the future of
neuroscience lies is in trying to parse
some of those deeper understandings i
don't have any knowledge to shed on that
all i can say is that
we all are very
self-oriented we all tend to approach
life through the lens of self and so i'm
struck again and again when i read your
book and when talking today your ability
to this notion of taking others
perspectives i think that's probably
hard work for most people and that
occurs to me as something that's
probably just as important to practice
as
writing in complete sentences
yeah i have a couple
triggers
that i use when you know when you
approach me with your plan
and your plan doesn't make sense to me
that that immediately tells me okay
he sees something i don't see i need to
try and get in his head i need to try
and figure out
what his perspective is when you're
mad you come into my office and i can
see that you're mad
i immediately i'm not thinking what's
wrong with him i'm thinking what does he
see that i don't see
and and yeah that's a a critical part of
not only just leadership but just
interacting with other human beings you
know if you if you know when i'm married
i've been married for a long time
when my wife i can see a look on her
face she's not happy
i'm i think what is happening what is
she seeing what's her perspective on
this that's making her not happy right
now because it's not going to benefit me
to have her continue down this path
and it's usually something that i can
make an adjustment on pretty quickly
and
allow her to see maybe what some of what
i'm seeing or allow her to see a little
bit of a different perspective so yeah
extremely important don't you ever do
some things like even as a as a
scientist where you're do running an
experiment and you get done and it kind
of like felt like it was uh
like it was just kind of happening like
you weren't
like you know they say i definitely have
felt that way i feel like you know if
i'm doing jiu jitsu have a good role
man i'm not in there i'm kind of
watching uh you you want to do that you
want to be able to detach do you have
that in the
in your business yeah that you know
people talk about flow states uh i'm
friendly with stephen kotler and so i
like to joke about flow that the the
most thing that the most that we can say
about flow at this point in history is
that backwards it spells wolf
meaning i don't think we really know how
that's generated in the brain um because
some people describe it as a sense of
losing time and being really in the
experience other people describe it as
being you know kind of third person in
the experience and so um this is more of
a call to action for more definition
about what flow is it probably probably
five different kinds of flow
i've certainly had the experience of
automaticity where i'm like who's
actually doing this stuff um you know
you get into these action patterns that
are so trained you're just watching
yourself you know for me to be really
nerdy stuff like
i i can dissect a retina like nobody
else let me put it that way if you need
me to take out an eyeball and put a
retina on anything get under a
microscope like i'm your guy
i've done it so many hundreds of
thousands of times and so from so many
different eyeballs everything from human
eyeballs right down to you know a
marmoset eyeball so
i'm the guy for that
but
typically i think
i'm not used to third personing quite as
much certainly situations i try and look
at situations i tend to do it by
assembling a small team so if they're
data i don't that don't make sense or
with my podcast team i love working this
small group of guys and we
we you know whiteboard what what do we
want to do how do we want to structure
things so i tend to outsource
my forebrain
one of the things that you see in and
i'm not describing myself here but in
creatives
they need handlers people that are very
creative
learn to put those spotlights into their
creative endeavor so much so that making
toast is work
and so they tend to as they achieve more
success dedicating more and more to of
the everyday things to other people in
an effort to try and get in that narrow
trench and so they're really taking
instead of um trying to spin multiple
plates related to multiple things
they're like let's get all the plates
spinning in unison
and just focus on this and that could be
very beneficial but it does tend to take
away that ability to outsource and uh be
a multitasker and so i think success is
a dangerous thing in that way because
the further up you go in science the
fewer experiments you're doing and the
more you're just focused on narrow
things and there sometimes people bring
me data and i'll say oh that means this
i'm like no that means that i'm like
well i've been doing this a lot longer
than you have and
i'm the professor at stanford then i
would think to myself wait a second
they're a lot closer to the data than i
am and so we sit back and look at it as
a group so i tend to do it through
groups but i'll be on the lookout for
this anytime you've described third
personing
or this notion of good growth from
stress great
now i know why you say that i think we
can put a neuroscience definition on
that because more stress equals more
growth
something that most people don't believe
in ally crumbs work research on the seal
teams
indicates if not proves that
they believe this more stress equals
more growth i think that's something
that i'm certainly trying to adopt more
and more in my life especially as i get
older we tend to get a little complacent
and set in our ways right uh no well not
you but
i we no not you either people in general
some some of us
tend to default towards the things that
feel good and move away from friction
but if friction is the lever for growth
and more friction equals more growth and
absolutely it does well then your
statement good makes complete sense
so
what do we what are we
doing food wise how how deep are you
into diet food um what are we doing
we get let's say let's let's go back to
you know we woke up in the morning we
got some we we got some light we did
some workout
we haven't taken any caffeine yet
we maybe we hopped in the cold bath
now
it start you know now the day's moving
along at what point are we eating
11 a.m
very similar to me yeah what are we
eating at 11 a.m i mean i'm laughing as
i in in size i say this because recently
i've you know
if you want to engage those neural
circuits for
um
battle online just talk about nutrition
or training oh yeah you know so people
are like this guy's a neurosign i'm
going to talk about what works for me
and i'm 46 and i'm happy that i can run
far
not too fast but i can run far and i can
lift objects that certainly are not the
heaviest objects in any environment but
i'm comfortable with my strength and
endurance
and i feel good
that's what matters to me and that i can
focus and i can work even after i train
so when i wake up i'm going to hydrate
90 minutes to 2 hours later i'm going to
drink caffeine
which is typically yerba mate pour over
yerba mate not the smoky ones turns out
the smoky ones are loaded with
carcinogens so as bad as smoking that
sounds bad it's really bad but i like
that stuff a lot i'm and i'm not just
saying this to uh make you guys happy
i'm loving these energy drinks i've been
drinking them for a few weeks now so
loving it um also because i don't
like sucralose oh yeah you did the
ingredient check i did the ingredient
check and it's not be i don't dislike
sucralose because i think it's going to
kill my microbiome i'm not trying to be
catastrophic about it i just don't like
the way it tastes
um but i think monk fruit stevia to me
are fine i'll occasionally have some
aspartame i'm not a big consumer of
aspartame but yeah the fact that it's
sweetened with monk fruit i like no
they're not paying me to say this i
really like this stuff although i'd be
happy to work with you guys i think i
want to just be clear um
the alpha gpc is something that i take
in supplement form unless i'm having
drinking something that has alpha gpc in
it they're good data on it alpha gpc
it's basically a choline donor increases
acetylcholine which is
a molecule released from the nucleus
basalis of my nert minor was the
anatomist that
helps enhance the intensity of those
spotlights to put sort of a general
description on it
um and the ability to engage those
spotlights so why we put it in there
so alpha gpc is something that uh you
know and there's some evidence that it
can offset some age-related cognitive
decline and those kinds of things so
there are a number of things in there
that i like so i'll drink some caffeine
i train in the early part of the day and
that i can just quickly say that if we
can talk about training separately but i
i hit the weights every other day
i do
i run on the days i don't train with
weights
and i do
all workouts for about an hour very
basic but i've been doing that for 30
years check okay i train
you know i can get into the details but
you know anyway the
the food thing is basically after i
train i can last about an hour or so
before i'm really hungry and then i'll
typically have some fruit and some
starch if i've trained hard if it's a
glycogen depleting workout you know
hit the weights then i'll have a big
bowl of oatmeal and some fruit and i
make sure i actually like throwing a
little bit of butter and some fish oil
in there and
um
uh you know some fats and a protein
drink at 11 and then around 1 30 or 2 i
want an a real meal
and on the days when i don't train with
the weights i typically don't have that
oatmeal protein drink meal instead i'll
have a real meal right at 11
or so and typically it's a piece of meat
a piece of grass-fed meat usually steak
i do not like chicken i don't know why
it just doesn't appeal to me i'll eat it
if i have to
i might have a piece of salmon but i'm
not crazy about salmon i'll have a piece
of grass-fed beef
like a rib eye or a
hamburger patty or two and a salad
and
maybe i'll have a you know a slice of
bread or something like good bread
usually not and then through the
afternoon i'm i'm good i typically will
work
anytime i'm not training or eating um i
try and just eat and not do work at the
same time but often times i'm eating
while i'm training while i'm i'm eating
while i'm working so i have lunch and
take care of some email and then in the
afternoon i will do
after lunch i'll typically lie down and
do an nsdr get a little nap wake up
sleep sleep where i'll go under into the
state of deep relaxation for 10 to 30
minutes
do that and then i can really do another
workout in the afternoon so i do some
work in the morning obviously i work out
in the morning i eat at 11
the post workout and then a lunch or
just the lunch if i didn't work out with
the weights and then i will do a little
bit of deep relaxation 10 to 30 minutes
get up from that hydrate i'll typically
take a quick walk outside so none of
that takes more than about 15 minutes
and then i try and drop into another
work bout
and throughout the afternoon
yeah yeah because i think of these as
90-minute bouts of work
the brain functions in what are called
trading cycles we have circadian which
means 24 ultradian which is 90 minute
cycles all your sleep is broken up into
90 minute cycles
all your waking states are broken up
into 90 minute cycles with some training
you can teach yourself to focus really
hard on something for about 90 minutes
but sometimes it's email sometimes it's
writing sometimes it's data analysis
sometimes it's podcast prep etc but
after about 90 minutes of intense work i
try and take a minute view a horizon
relax walk around i try not to look at
my phone
and then i'll go back into another bout
of work so i'm getting three or four
intense bouts of work throughout the day
and then
i'm not eating in the afternoon
throughout that afternoon i had one or
two meals already and then i typically
will eat dinner
depends um
7 or 8 p.m
and i tend to put more carbohydrates in
the evening i know some people gasp at
that but
come through i should i'm not saying
i'm not saying this to you guys but you
know if you do a workout of the sort
that i do in the morning i mean it sets
typically to failure i'm training not
real quick but you know if you're
depleting that glycogen i'm fine to have
a plate of pasta and i'd have a little
bit less protein in the evening because
i find it very hard to get good sleep
in in a low carb state see i you i will
if i wanna sleep or let's say maybe
something happened where i
didn't have a hard workout during the
day and i know i'm gonna have a hard
time falling asleep i might get a little
bit of that rice going up in the system
i have some spaghetti going up in there
because i'm doing that carb oh yeah damn
you know coma yeah well you know i'll do
that but we're not talking enormous
volumes oh
so some rice or some pasta some risotto
or something i'm fortunate that my
girlfriend's a really good cook so
she'll say what do you want and then
i'll tell her and and she'll cook it she
was a professional chef for a long time
and she's fast so basically says what do
you want to eat today and that kind of
thing and so that's what i get and um
i'm very lucky in that way the
the one thing that i make sure to do you
know what we can edit that out
you don't want to give up that kind of
leverage in this scenario
we can edit it out um
i'm
really big on that and that evening meal
being
mostly carbohydrates also vegetables i
happen to really like vegetables and
less protein so i might have a small
piece of fish or some you know broth a
soup or something like that and keep in
mind that then i'm not usually eating
anything until
11 o'clock the next day and i'm likely
going to train again in the morning or
run again in the morning and so i want
my glycogen topped off i'm not looking
to walk around at you know six percent
body fat or anything like that it might
i keep a relatively low body fat
percentage and have for a long time
i feel good where i'm at um you know
ebbs and flows depending on the season
but i have zero appetite for sugar and
that's a recent thing a few years ago i
just started
i stopped having the half glass of wine
just because everyone else was doing it
i stopped
having dessert
just because and i noticed that i didn't
like it and i just didn't make me feel
good and i'd much rather consume
calories from clean sources like rice
and meat and fish and vegetables
this kind of thing i do eat some fruit
i'm not huge on dairy but i'll have a
little bit of really good cheese really
good parmesan cheese or really good
fermented cheese one thing that's very
clear from the scientific literature
this is the work of justin sonnenberg
and chris gardner at stanford
that
fermented foods low sugar fermented
foods sauerkraut kimchi
low sugar kombuchas greek yogurt
unsweetened greek yogurt enhance the gut
microbiome these trillions of gut
bacteria that actually make the sort of
neurotransmitters that cross into the
blood-brain barrier and create the
substrate for things like dopamine and
epinephrine and etc
and can reduce inflammation markers they
call this the inflammatome it's like
looking at your genome they looked at
inflammatory markers in people that
consumed four servings which is not a
lot four two ounce servings of for low
sugar fermented foods per day compared
to increasing their fiber now i'm not
disparaging of fiber but what they found
was that people who ate a lot of fiber
either increased inflammatory markers
maintained or decreased it was all over
the place
mainly the effect of eating a lot of
fiber is you increase the number of
enzymes that you make that digest fiber
the people that ate a lot of fermented
food low sugar fermented foods
across the board reduce these
inflammatory markers i feel better when
i'm eating some kimchi sauerkraut etc
and we've started making our own meaning
she makes it i don't make it
and to do that we went to tim ferriss's
four hour
body book there's a recipe or for our
chef excuse me he describes in there a
way that you can cut up cabbage and
ferment it with some salt water you have
to do this properly because you can get
some harmful bacteria but if you do you
cover it with a cloth you put in the
dark you take it out you skim off the
bad stuff it's kind of fun and the
reason for doing this is that a lot of
live culture fermented foods can get
pretty expensive if you have an appetite
like mine i love to eat and i'll just
eat it by the bowl full and pretty soon
you're dropping ten dollars here and you
know if you're down in kombucha left and
right you know you're drinking some of
the most expensive fluid it's more
expensive than petroleum so
um so i we have big vats of kimchi and
this kind of thing and i like hot sauces
so she's figured out how to make
fermented hot sauces you can all do all
this stuff easily and so i'm always
eating fermented sauces and foods
throughout the day kimchi's okay
although i think
if you don't do it right it can be
pretty foul to be around the smell is
pretty intense
and yes occasionally i'll have a slice
of cobbler
but that's like once or twice a year i
just don't have an appetite for it i
really look forward to the post-training
meal a big bowl of oatmeal or yes
occasionally if i'm training at a gym
someplace i'll be like how do i get some
glycogen back in my system it's two
bananas and a few bagels yeah i've done
it before it might there's no cashed you
out exactly well on the internet people
like oh my goodness you know it's the i
don't know why this topic of nutrition
has people so up in arms um and i and
the extremes i've not tried the pure
carnivore thing
um i understand you can re-pack glycogen
with gluconeogenesis protein converted
to
other fuels
i've not tried the plant-based thing
because i would just be thinking about
cows all day and
and i like the animal but i would just
be craving meat my dad's argentine after
all
and i don't tend to do cheat days
anymore that kind of thing i shed that
in my
early 40s
but uh yeah that's it's pretty basic and
there's caffeine in the early part of
the day hydration is really key i mean i
think for the brain and for the body
hydration is key and then
we're not talking so much about
supplements but if there were one
supplement that's really been shown to
be useful for physical performance but
also
where most of the data point to is for
brain
fuel is creatine you know the the
forebrain system
depends on a phospho-creatine
type fuel in addition to glucose
and so i do five grams of creatine
monohydrate a day i will do the alpha
gpc in an energy drink or before
training a lot of people forget that
energy is not just caloric there's
neural energy dopamine norepinephrine
and we talked about the the meat if you
meat is rich with tyrosine tyrosine is
an amino acid red meat especially that's
the precursor to dopamine
carbohydrates and white meat turkey are
rich in the amino acid tryptophan which
is the precursor to serotonin and so as
i say this it probably all makes sense
that you can generate states of
alertness in states of
sleepiness depending on what you eat
i will say however if you eat an
enormous volume of anything you will
direct more blood to your gut relative
to your brain so if you have five rib
eye steaks or two ribeye steaks
depending on how big they are
yes you will have a lot of tyrosine in
your system you also have a lot of blood
in your gut and you'll be tired and want
to go to sleep so you can't beat the
system completely
but yeah that's pretty much how i eat
and i maintain some flexibility i mean
we're in san diego right now i miss
tacos taco tuesday in san diego is a
special experience occasionally i'll
have a white tequila margarita which i
love every once in a while i'm not a
super extreme guy on this stuff
and i would loathe
to be
ex pure carnivore or pure vegan sorry
paul saladino he's a butt you know he's
a friend and i have some vegan friends
like rich roll i just i don't want to
live that way and i'm probably going to
get assaulted for saying this but um you
know one group will come after me with
celery sticks and the other group will
come after me with
raw meat but all i can say is you know
do you do you
and i love those guys um i'll keep going
the way i'm going and we'll see how it
goes well yeah i like the fact that you
said you have vegan friends
[Music]
uh you know you you mentioned
you know sugar the habit of sugar and
you don't drink or don't take much sugar
anymore and you you know one of the
podcasts that you've done is about
habits making habits breaking habits
give us some high level
habit forming and habit breaking
neurological
strategies we can utilize
well we've already talked about how
dopamine puts you into an action state
and the serotonin system tends to bias
you toward a more sedative state or calm
state
maybe even a more creative state which
is associated with calm states
if you are trying to build habits
and you look to the neuroscience of
habit building you would be wise to put
certain habits at the early part of the
day in certain habits at the later part
of the day i call phase one of the day
from zero to nine hours after waking
that period of the day assuming that
you're getting that sunlight exposure
and a little bit of movement but even if
you're just getting some sunlight
exposure
is going to be associated with high
epinephrine high dopamine
slightly higher cortisol
certain habits we could call linear
habits
these are things that you know how to do
and you just need to do them
other habits and so those sorts of
habits would go well in that zero to
nine hours
period that i call phase one zero to
nine hours after working phase one then
phase two
and these aren't absolute phases but go
from about 10 hours till about 16 or 17
hours after waking we tend to be a
little bit sleepier we tend to be a
little bit calmer at least not
necessarily sleepy
it can be a little bit calmer it's clear
that other habits that have to do with
what we call non-linear brain operations
things like creative writing
brainstorming with a group brainstorming
with yourself analytic work that is
where there is no clear right answer
it's not plug and chug it's more
exploratory
go best in the second
phase phase two
i was thinking about you know rolling
jiu jitsu earlier i
can't even call it rolling jiu jitsu
i've only done it once but clearly
there's a lot of moment to moment
creativity and kind of sorting things
out whereas weight lifting it sets and
reps you're trying to complete a certain
amount of sets and reps you're trying to
cover a certain amount of distance
running linear versus non-linear
and then of course there's the 17 to 24
hours
which is phase three and during that
time you want to be engaging one set of
habits which is sleep
okay roughly it could be 16 to 24 hours
etc so try and put the habits you're
trying to form into the times of day in
which those will actually be easiest
this sort of violates the earlier rule
of
try and access limbic friction if
there's something that you're really
trying to adopt more exercise and that
exercise is running a certain distance
in a certain amount of time put that in
the early part of the day
if you're trying to do creative work do
in the second part of the day
if you are
trying to develop a new skill that's
exploratory second part of the day if
you're trying to learn a skill that has
defined steps already it's linear early
part of the day
people will just find that it's simpler
to do it in some in that fashion
the other thing is that if you look at
the science of goal setting
there are clear data there's a woman um
at new york university emily balcettis
or balsettus i think is
the correct pronunciation
and
she's described that
while we like to think about
envisioning success as the best way to
set goals and develop new habits it
turns out that at least the research
shows it's far more effective to imagine
the catastrophic effects of failure
it's you know it's it's the darkness
none of us want to embrace but fear is
the more powerful motivator but provided
you can still think clearly you don't
want to put yourself into a state of
panic so goal setting of if i don't do
this every day i'm looking at diabetes
and early death is going to be a much
more powerful motivator than imagining
you're going oh i'm going to be you know
10 pounds lighter and you know i can
you know bench press 15 more by
christmas this time of year it's great
to have goals it's
also great to have motivators that are
based on real world fear
fear
fierce that's what the data say
i i was having a conversation with a
buddy of mine that's uh
at a big medical company and
we were i was saying yeah you know when
when mike i was kind of i was kind of
professing guilt because when my kids
were younger
you know i they'd say oh you know can we
get some ice cream and i'd say sure you
want some type 2 diabetes to go with
that
but this dude no kidding would have like
needles
and hat like stick the kids so that they
could get used to getting oh you want to
have some ice cream cool go get the
needle we're gonna we're gonna stick
your finger so that when you have type 2
diabetes and you have to do an insulin
draw oh my goodness i was like i i was
like damn this dude won up to me i don't
get one up that often when it comes to
being stupid but he seemed to pull it
off that's intense the
i've yeah i can't comment on on
parenting the
we should also recall the dopamine
reward system the best way to reward
yourself for a job well done is
random intermittent reward we've always
talked up until now or we've been
talking up until now that you know
effort reward is the cycle reward that
cycle effort reward
but
if you want to keep remember dopamine
non-infinite but replenishable how about
not spend it at all how about use what
the casinos use in order to keep
yourself into a state of motivation so
if you
are
checking off the boxes i did this
behavior this new habit that new habit
then great do that but don't celebrate
every win
celebrate random intermittent
wins
right so celebrate how do you do that if
you're in control of it
well
don't reward yourself with external
rewards very often so make the training
its own reward so if it's i'm gonna
train and then i'm gonna have the
pancake breakfast great do it every once
in a while but don't do it every sunday
don't do it every workout
so it's not so much about the frequency
as much as it is how
the pattern the what we call the
schedule of reward
so you know and you can see this in
sports teams and some of the challenges
over the years of you know everyone gets
a trophy i mean nothing is more
undermining to the dopamine system than
that idea
i mean i don't know what happened with
that but
i and i don't want to punish anybody
because
i also don't know who it was but that
group or person who made that decision
that everyone gets a trophy
clearly did not read the literature
about how the neuroscience of reward and
the psychology reward works you actually
diminish the role of rewards in every
way and you take away the ability to
access the reward system in the future
you're creating not just you're not
creating soft versions of people you're
actually creating people
they're just like the rat with no
dopamine it's a really sad state we have
a name for that in humans it's called
parkinson's you deplete the dopamine
system people get shaky they can't move
that's in the motor system but people
with parkinson's also
experience extreme lack of motivation
and depression because of lack of
dopamine that's the characteristic
feature of parkinson's is lack of
dopamine neurons
so
you want to every once in a while reward
yourself
for reaching a goal one way to do this
and that we've structured on the podcast
but i can just describe really easily is
set three or four habits that you want
to create for yourself
in a list of six so find six habits and
decide every day you're gonna do four
but never compensate day to day there's
reasons for doing this you would say
let's say one day it's um
train if you're not you'll run if you're
not already doing that right if you're
not already doing that
you can list these off gratitude
practice nsdr and then let's just come
up with one i don't know eat a vegetable
we're just making these up so you're
going to list those out on your calendar
and then every day you're going to do at
least four but as many as five but if
one day you only get one you don't carry
over and do 10 the next day
that
if you understand the dopamine system
you'll understand why because what
you're trying to do is you're trying to
train up a circuitry for giving yourself
random intermittent reward for
performing these habits on a regular
basis so people will go do these heroic
workouts or they'll do a ton of stuff
and then they'll reward themselves and
they just undermine the whole process of
being able to do that consistently if
that wasn't clear
it's a little complicated but the way
that reward schedules work is you're
trying to teach the circuitry to work
regularly be rewarded only every once in
a while and at random
so if you were technically going to do
this i would have to make a
a bucket
with
a bunch of ping-pong balls in it
and most of the ping-pong balls didn't
have anything on them but then some of
the ping-pong balls had you know uh
a chocolate chip cookie perfect and then
every time i get done with my workout
i'm like hey i did the workout i did a
good job i'm gonna grab a ping pong ball
from the bucket
nothing
next day nothing next day nothing next
day chocolate chip cookie
that's what i would have to technically
do but i had to do the workout to pull
one of these things out of the bucket
perfect and how many rewards to put in
that bucket versus how many blank
ping-pong balls you know you could say
maybe one-third of them should have a
reward but remember it's random right
and so that exactly describes the way we
would do an experiment on an animal or
human in our laboratory and then with
humans we do it in a very particular way
we actually pay them real money
we have people do hard work for money
varying amounts of money
often
and you can
you can record from the brain you can
record from dopamine centers or other
centers what happens is people start
trying to create the most rational
strategy you get these maniacs that will
just try and get as many reps as
possible this is a not a discussion
about
learning and plasticity we may get into
that but
it's very clear that errors or the
anticipation of a reward and then no
reward while it leads to disappointment
it also increases attention and the
ability to focus on the next trial think
about this you're what do you guys call
behind glass you're shooting writing
like you're missing every time you miss
the next trial is the one you're paying
the most attention to when you hit you'd
think ah the next one i'm good no the
next one why would you be good
why would you why would you you just
succeeded why would your nervous system
pay attention to what happens next when
you succeed your nervous system goes oh
that happened that way
and it's a little relaxation it's a low
relaxation so errors we know cue up the
forebrain and it increases activity in
the prefrontal cortex here i've only
done this never i don't get behind glass
but i've thrown darts in a bar okay and
you're up there there are people
watching and you're we used to do this
in graduate school there's a little bar
in davis and we throw darts and you know
and you miss you're like
you know you're really it's almost that
little anger and the next one you're
completely dialed in but then you're
like bullseye bullseye you know off the
off the ah and when you make it the next
one you're not paying as careful
attention to your motor patterns so you
might get lucky but you're not learning
so errors are key to learning and the
proper ratio of errors to successful
trials for optimal learning is very
clear from machine learning and from
human learning it's the 8515 rule
how difficult to make a task
should be eighty-five percent of the
time you're performing it correctly
fifteen percent of the time you're
performing incorrectly more or less plus
or minus two percent if you wanna
optimize learning
eighty-five percent you get it fifteen
percent you miss yeah that's about the
right level of difficulty for motor
skill learning cognitive learning etc
any more than that is you're
putting too
much of a demand on the attentional
systems any less you're putting too
little demand on the intentional systems
that's what the machine learning shows
in humans that's what the
machine learning algorithm is based on
human learning that's what the animal
data show and of course there'll
be some variation on this but if people
are saying oh i want to teach these kids
spanish or i want to teach people how to
shoot well
make it difficult enough so that they're
about 15 error rate
or jiu jitsu i guess well jiu-jitsu
unfortunately when you start jiu-jitsu
you're getting 100 error rate because
you're getting tapped out all the time
that's why it takes a lot of uh effort
to get over the hump in the beginning
uh look we've been going for for a while
i do want to we you you've touched on
this a little bit
but before we before we wrap and i can
already tell
if you're if you're okay with it
hopefully we can do some more podcasts
in the future
i'd love to have you on my podcast i'd
love to yeah sit down chat with you guys
anytime let's do it um
let's get people ready for bed ready for
sleep you've already talked about we
what we're doing we what what our
temperature's doing how we how we
getting ready for bed at the end of the
day
after our three bouts of work
i've always called them back that's
legit i'm in you know you got to have
that it's a mindset thing right you're
like okay i i need to i need to get
ready to get in the game forward center
of mass yeah so if you sit down and try
if you sit down to any cognitive task
and or physical task and pray for focus
you'll be praying a long time yeah it
just doesn't work that way the brain
needs you need to recruit the attention
also we're doing this yeah we need to we
really need to recruit the attentional
systems and i i get um
uh
concerned about people trying to
leverage too many tools even though i
talk about a lot of tools
at some point you've got
the work you're there
caffeinated you're hydrated
as you would say go shut up and go
when i write books which i've written a
couple
i i write a thousand words a day
and it takes about an hour
and i
i rarely will write more than that i
almost never miss once i'm in the zone
and i got a book
i i won't miss but that's i like the
attitude of going in of hey this is
about like i'm about to go get it on and
i need to just bring the heat for an
hour and and i like that that's a good
idea yeah i learned it in graduate
school cutting there's this thing called
a microtome where you take a brain it's
frozen and you slice it off like a deli
slicer one little piece at a time and
you is this a hannibal lecter scenario
i got a lot of stories from the lab that
since you guys are not afraid of blood
and guts you know we can get into that
but you're putting these little thin
slices of tissue into these little wells
of liquid and it's very delicate work
and some of these specimens were very
valuable either because they came from
human beings that had interesting
experiences like the loss of one eye or
something or because
the tissue had been created through a
number of experiments that lasted months
if not years so it's really important
stuff and what was taught to me by one
of the perhaps the greatest neuro
ophthalmologist at ucsf jonathan horton
he said the moment that microtome blade
hits that tissue a nuclear bomb could go
off in the building and you're not going
to increase the speed of the pull
because the slower you can pull it the
better the quality of the tissue but you
can't stop and so i learned to just
lathe down through these brains and some
people put ice on it and go have lunch
come back and it never quite cuts right
when you come back to it so how long
would it take to do a slice before a
small mouse brain would take you know
maybe an hour you can get
why did we not make a machine that would
do it the machines can't adjust the
temperature and speed actually the way
you adjust the temperature kids don't do
this you lick your finger and you put it
on there and get it there's just a
texture of like very cold butter that's
just right it's a feel thing the machine
will crack the tissue it doesn't know
when it's screwing up
so i've cut through macaque monkey
brains that took me somewhere between
seven and eight hours
um
and it's a single pole as i said well
when you're doing it you're doing a pull
and then repeating and then okay got it
got it um
i've done that and i've done a
you can't do a whole human brain but
i've done a block of a human frontal
cortex of all things and human retina
where i think the the longest i've gone
is something like 11 hours of cutting
and in that case you know just to be
clear about how this works you've got a
little bit of food next to you you've
got your portable bathroom next to you
sometimes you have to urinate during
these things you
handle it and
you typically do this alone in a room
and you finish off that thing and you
get those things into tissue wells and
there's almost nothing as satisfying
there are things more satisfying is each
slice about
anywhere from 20 to 40 microns so a
millimeter is divided into a thousand
microns so a credit card's 200
approximately 200 microns thick so very
very thin you can see through it it's
translucent
and it's so much fun and then you stain
them and you put them under microscopes
and my career was built on this work too
so you're also thinking about
the you're collecting the the crops of
your of your farm so to speak it's it's
so pleasurable it really is you wouldn't
get any third person
personality what were you calling it but
you wouldn't get any detachment when
you're doing that kind of get in the
zone at occasion we didn't i didn't
really listen to audio books back then i
would listen to a lot of rants
uh listen to a lot of uh glenn gould as
a classical pianist if ever you need to
do work and you want to listen to
classical music and you're not really
into classical music glenn gould is just
perfect for that background brain state
um and just an amazing
piano player so i would do that um
and so i guess the point is that we can
train ourselves to focus and it feels so
good it reminds me of my bulldog chewing
on on
something and um you know i i'm gonna i
wasn't gonna reveal this when i got him
i got him from a guy named elvis so i
named him costello but there was a
moment because this was about the time i
thought about naming him jocko
because you guys both have big necks you
know so the uh anyway it's um
i got i got him earlier but there was
always this question do we keep costello
as his name because i didn't name him
and someone had said it and i was like
maybe we keep costillo anyway there was
a debate in our household at one point
um costello won out sorry
good but hey someone out there has named
their dog jocko and hopefully it's
because they have a thick neck
there's quite a few dogs out there named
jocko there's a couple kids out there
named jockle there's some police dogs
out there named doctor are there jocko
tattoos yes uh there are some chocolate
tattoos out there in the world yeah if
you if you talk about like people get
good
for a tattoo people get desperate
freedom for a tattoo those are pretty
cool um yeah so there's some of that
stuff going on anyway has anyone gotten
any uh
you know hubermann lab tats yet not that
i'm aware of but i will say this if
anyone gets a tattoo of lex friedman's
face i'll be happy to have a one-hour
zoom with you to discuss any topic in
neuroscience you want
so uh if anyone wants to get and if you
get a neck tattoo of lex friedman's face
then we'll do a two-hour zoom i was on
lexus i was on lex's podcast
i was on lex's podcast and it was an
interesting interaction we'll say uh and
he's just he's an awesome guy it was
just like i don't know it was a little
strange but
and somebody actually nailed it they
said this is like
the terminator
from the second terminator movie
interviewing the terminator from the
first terminator
because he was asking me you know
questions and i was giving him like one
word answers for whatever it took a
while to get like a flow going you know
it's kind of funny
he's a good friend of mine i i yeah so i
know i want to do it again i want to i
want to i got to do this podcast again
where we where we have a little bit of
because now i kind of know him and we've
had some other we've actually the last
time i talked him on the phone
we were actually just laughing our asses
off about a couple things that was one
of the things i told him hey i read this
comment about when you when you
interviewed me and he was just laughing
because he was so accurate it was kind
of funny maybe you guys should roll jiu
jitsu yeah yeah
you can just settle it out yeah yeah
yeah just what i don't think there was
any friction but maybe you guys just if
you rolled jiu jitsu then
no there wasn't there wasn't any
friction it was just
uh i think
he you know he he started off with some
questions like are you afraid of death
i'm like no
he's like do you want to expand on that
i'm like i'm not afraid of death
whatever it was but it was funny um it
sounded funny afterwards when i listened
to it i was like man why i don't know
what happened i listened to that podcast
i really enjoyed it yeah
like i said and and i i really like lex
and i really like his podcast and uh
yeah and the other funny thing is we
were kind of chilling like we met was in
l.a we're talking you know we're just
talking and and we sit down and that was
another thing it kind of
like we're just talking like whatever
and then all of a sudden he's like and
he doesn't he wasn't making eye contact
with me and he goes are you afraid of
death like just
we're talking about whatever news are
you afraid of death and i was like wait
no
and then
i guess that was the start of the
podcast echo's getting a kick out of it
straight to the defense so true that's
right straight to the deep end
tonight
yeah
you guys should do it again
who knows maybe i'm sure i'll get down
down to austin at some point and
um hook it up we'll talk to talk to lex
again
and hopefully i can be this is by the
way this is just like because i was just
i don't know i don't know what i messed
up but i'll do better i'll do better
next time i won't be uh i won't be like
a terminator robot i guess i'll try not
to be maybe but your response about the
death question will be the same
yeah my responsibility the death
question will be the same you know and
are you afraid of death no
definitely
no
non-sequitur there
yeah
uh so
back to sleep yeah to wind this getting
ready to wind this initial
podcast up what do we uh how are we
getting ready for sleep okay
view some sunlight in the afternoon
before the sun goes down why it adjusts
your retinal sensitivity in a way that
allows you to get to view a little bit
more artificial light at night without
disrupting your melatonin
beautiful study published in scientific
reports
shows this
it adjusts that sensitivity so that
bright light from screens
isn't going to really mess you up quite
as much i call it your your netflix
inoculation however
dim the lights in the evening especially
overhead lights these neurons in the eye
that we were talking about before that
set the circadian rhythm and generate
states of alertness they're more or less
in the lower half of your eye and they
view the upper visual field makes sense
they're there to extract sunlight so
if you're going to light your
environment which you should obviously
you need to move move about
put lights you know use lamps or table
lamps or if you want to get really
extreme stuff near the floor if you're
really into this you could get red bulbs
and because red shifted light is
actually going to be less disruptive to
your circadian rhythms in fact there's a
nice study looking at for shift workers
red light isn't going to increase
cortisol late in the day and shift work
is something obviously thank you shift
workers we realize that much of what we
talked about you can't access because
you're doing the important work at night
that all of us depend on i have a whole
episode on shift work that people can
get tools for that long discussion but
so dim the lights set them low in the
room red lights if you're really extreme
about it put on blue blockers if you do
that sort of thing but
or just dim the lights
cool the environment
in general it's not good to fall asleep
within two hours of eating a big meal
but you'd be if you can fall asleep it's
always good to get sleep so
you know that some people are really
neurotic about this like i won't eat
within two hours of bedtime fine but if
you get home from work two hours late
because of traffic are you gonna not eat
and then not sleep i mean just be a
human
eat dinner and then try and give
yourself a little bit of time before you
go to sleep
so in all seriousness i i would hate to
see people obsess too much hydrate but
of course don't drink a ton of fluid
before going to sleep because there's a
direct circuit from the bladder to the
brain stem this is why you wake up in
the middle of night because you have to
go to the bathroom
so don't over hydrate at night
and if you do a hot bath or a sauna or
something like that obviously hydrate
but remember that cool off
after that will help drop your body
temperature even further
then in terms of your sleep environment
there's a really nice paper that just
came out in proceedings of the national
academy of sciences showing that people
that sleep in a room where there are
ambient lights or there's lights on even
if they're pretty dim some of that light
actually gets through the eyelids and
disrupts
metabolism and morning glucose
management and insulin secretion so try
and keep your sleeping environment as
dark as possible don't obsess about one
little light or something but if you've
ever been the hotel with a bright blue
light it's really annoying
you know the one bright light in the
corner and here's the other thing some
people like me have really thin eyelids
don't ask me why some people have thick
eyelids so some people can see light
through their eyelids more than others
dang yeah it's a you know so
wear an eye mask if you want to but keep
it dark
so there are a bunch of different things
and if you are
the one really important thing that most
people are not aware of is that work
from chuck's eyesores lab at harvard
medical school has shown
wait harvard who is where's that is this
little school in boston they have a
couple campuses and they have good
people some good people came out of
there that's an amazing place
it's a tough place people are are
the training there there's a lot of uh
it's rigorous at many many places but
harvard's reputation of they they they
really like the old school academic
grind they do modern science but they
they really like they like to add
friction do you go out there ever yeah
yeah i've got a lot of friends at
harvard medical school and at the
undergrad campus and a good relationship
to all of them new york's got its
neurosci we call the new york
neuroscience mafia they all have tickets
to the opera they all are very cultured
and they do neuroscience boston they
just live
academics i mean the town of boston is
amazing i mean students everywhere
everywhere in boston someone is pursuing
something the punk rock bands in boston
work harder than anywhere else
it's just it's it's a they they like
friction they're
they're
you know built on friction boston yeah
bay area and stanford
especially
it's about because of the technology
sector it's about the future we care
about the lineage of the past of course
and our nobels and all that stuff but
it's really about what's next the
students want to start companies they
want to change the entire world other
places too but stanford there's a
there's this idea of the future is where
it's at the past you know an
undergraduate one said to me you know i
said oh yeah this guy downstairs for me
discovered the structure of rna and his
dad discovered basically rna it says
nobel prize i'm like does he have an app
you know and it's like what you know and
i mean that work is transformative and
you know many ways but it's just well
what how is it impacting the real world
that's one reason i really like being at
stanford it's about real world impact
now
so but they're harvard's great so
basically you want to chuck zeisser's
lab at harvard medical school showed
that
about an hour before your natural
bedtime you're going to be very alert
for about an hour
there are evolutionary theories about
why this would be that you're going to
tamp down
all your your village resources you're
going to make sure you're safe set
security set security
set security yeah it's that security
right you've got to go to bed you got to
set security i set security at my house
just like you're saying yeah right you
get get ready for bed at night it's like
oh go make sure that the external
perimeter is secured make sure the locks
are locked make sure the alarm systems
aren't make sure the dog is
rabid and ready to eat people
you know make sure your magazines are
loaded and you know you're good to go
booby traps are set yeah we are
vulnerable in sleep as uh
the vampire shift of ops uh
knows all too well right um hit em while
they're sleeping um
so
you want to respect that and not worry
about it a lot of people freak out why
am i wide awake it will pass and i wish
more people knew about this because
everyone experiences this
and then the other thing is
light inhibits melatonin and melatonin
is the molecule of sleepiness so viewing
bright light will quash your melatonin
that's why you want to dim the lights in
the evening and if you wake up in the
middle of the night and you need to go
use the bathroom that's perfectly normal
but don't flip on lights that are super
bright use a night light don't use
bright overhead lights don't go into a
super bright environment you will
suppress your melatonin now a lot of
people go to bed around 11 or 12 and
wake up around 2 or 3 and can't fall
back asleep
and one more prominent theory in the
sleep science community now is that
those people should have gone to bed at
8 30 or 9 p.m and that their melatonin
is running out basically
so play with your bedtime i for instance
have learned we were talking about this
before we started that a
going to bed for me at 10 p.m
i'm up at four feeling great
if i go to bed at 11 p.m or midnight i
can sleep till seven or eight and never
feel quite right and part of that's
because i'm waking up to two or three
times in the middle of the night so you
have to figure out where your optimal to
sleep time is and that will change
across the lifespan young kids sometimes
want to stay up later and sleep in later
and
need more sleep and as we get older
supposedly we need less sleep we become
early risers people obsess a little too
much about this you know morning person
late person thing i
you got to figure out when your best to
bed time is
if you wake up in the middle of the
night and you want to go back back to
sleep and you cannot i recommend
listening to that non-sleep deep breath
script to at least keep you from
scrolling through social media or
thinking about problems
you're better off doing non-sleep deep
rest than being wide awake when you want
to be asleep
okay and you're better off being asleep
when you want to be asleep obviously so
one way you can get better at sleeping
is
to use an app like reverie r-e-v-e-r-i
this is based on research at stanford
there's a sleep function in there they
will allow you to try it for free there
is a nominal cost after that and it's
hypnosis for sleep
and it's not someone hypnotizing you it
teaches you to relax yourself into a
state where then you drift off into
sleep and it's the the clinical data and
the scientific papers on this are very
strong so is it
if i
put on the app right now what's it gonna
do i'm ready to go to sleep what's it
doing does it tell me anything about
this yeah is it asmr what's it called
the asmr asmr like the the
microphone
yeah
i have this weird obsession with asmr um
so
there's a state of mind we call hypnosis
that
involves being very alert but focused on
internal state so normally it's hard to
be very alert with your eyes closed
and some people
can access this state better than others
and in this state
you are very suggestible
and some people can be more readily
hypnotized than others there's a
colleague of mine at stanford david
spiegel he and his father are md's his
dad's dead now but they developed this
field of of hypnosis for psychiatry and
for reprogramming the mind and pain
management trauma but also sleep etc
there's a simple test that we can do and
anyone can do if you can look up you do
this with rogan didn't you yeah if you
can maintain upward gaze and close your
eyes
you are highly hypnotizable if you have
a hard time maintaining upward gaze with
your eyelids closed you are less
hypnotizable it's a one to four scale
now keep in mind if this sounds wacky
how do they evaluate concussion based on
the size of the pupils relative to one
another by shining light in one or the
other eyes so the eyes as two pieces of
brain are the neurologists and in this
case the psychiatrist primary tools to
assess the brain without putting you
into a brain scanner so it sounds wacky
because it's like look up and then close
your eyes we can do it with you if you
look up and then
keeping upward gaze slowly close your
eyes
yup looks like you can do it
yup see how you sell the whites of his
eyes so what does that mean it means
he's highly hypnotized
now why that makes sense to me yeah so
you could try reverie and that will help
you fall back asleep that sort of thing
and if you wake up in the middle of the
night you know and you
the worst thing you could do would be to
look at any bright light or screen light
that would be a terrible idea because
you're going to quash your melatonin
you're going to start think bringing in
new sensory stimulation just think about
how unusual that is normally you
wouldn't bring in new sensory
information in the middle of the night
now you're accessing information from
nova scotia africa you know and texas
all at once and you're watching the lex
friedman podcast
you know
so
um those are the things around around
sleep that are really useful and then of
course there are some supplements that
if all you're doing all the other things
correctly and you're still not sleeping
well the supplements that a lot of
people benefit from are magnesium 3 and
8 th t-h-r-e-o-n-a-t-e or magnesium
bis-glycinate those forms of magnesium
help
speed the transition into sleep in the
depth of sleep
they are interchangeable with one
another bisglycin8 or three and eight
seem to be equally effective
some people also benefit from taking
something called apogen and api genin
it's a derivative of chamomile
50 milligrams of apogenin will help you
a lot of people kind of turn off their
thinking it's non-addictive it has high
safety margins obviously talk to your
doctor you know if that's important to
you um these things are readily
available i don't have a relationship to
apogen and company swanson makes it i
have no relationship to swanson
mag3n8
the cost varies tremendously where you
look i've seen it very expensive and
i've seen it less expensive i can't tell
the difference between the different
sources so my wish is that the expensive
companies will bring the price down but
i've noticed a ratcheting up and then
some people will take
oh and it's 144 milligrams of magnesium
for whatever reason they always chart it
out as 144. about five percent of people
will get some gastric distress from
mag308
but it is distinct from
magnesium malate or magnesium citrate
magnesium citrate is a terrific laxative
magnesium malate seems to be better for
muscle soreness and on and on there are
these magnesium jockeys out there that
get really nuanced about this but mag
three and eight or biscuit will help and
then there's theanine t-h-e-a-n-i-n-e
which
many people
take also before sleep 100 to 200
milligrams or so
it will give you more vivid dreams than
you would otherwise so if you're a
sleepwalker you have night terrors don't
take it but
you can take that theanine is now
showing up in energy drinks and in
coffee because it it's a slight um
it pushes back on the systems that cause
stress it reduces the jitter so you can
drink a lot more coffee if you're also
taking theanine but everything i just
described would be taking 30 to 60
minutes before bed and then if you want
to bring out the really heavy guns which
i haven't talked about before in a
podcast but there's some interesting
data and i've been
looking at and researching inositol 900
milligrams of inositol wow that's a
sedative i mean if there ever was any a
sedative it also is what's the deal with
inositol inositol is hitting these
gabaergic transmission systems
no it's a supplement that um it's you
know it's a in the vitamin pathway that
will reduce anxiety
900 milligrams of myo-inositol is the
form that you want to seek out if you're
going to try this i did it for a while i
slept very very well i replaced the
other stack with inositol again no
relationship to a nossital company the
problem was i felt so mellow in the
morning i didn't like it um for me anger
and by our podcast photographer he
doesn't do well with mag3n8 it disrupts
his stomach so he took inositol he
called me the next day he's like what is
that stuff i slept 10 hours so you know
different sensitivities but inositol
seems to work well for people that are
on a low carbohydrate diet and have a
hard time getting into sleep so i i
think we can expect that the inositol
market is going to start to pick up some
momentum soon because it really does
work quite well
and you know but better to me better
than than ambien or prescription drugs
you know always go behaviors first then
supplements if you need them and then
the prescription stuff if that's your
thing and you have a doctor that's going
to help you with that but my goal has
always been to rely on as few
prescriptions of anything as possible by
doing the right behaviors avoiding the
wrong behaviors and diet and supplements
when you were a kid you're going to that
therapist and they maybe thought you
were a little jacked up psychologically
did they put you on anything back then
nope and i'm so glad they did not do you
think the tendency now is that they put
people on stuff a lot quicker absolutely
that is right absolutely and there are
cases where this is vitally important
but i am so grateful that i went through
all that before the massive ssri phase
before
um the i don't think i had adhd if
anything i have a bit more of an ocd as
you guys can probably tell i get into a
pretty narrow trench and i you know
we'll just keep going until people say
stop
but
and always have been that way um but
when i was a little kid i had a little
bit of a grunting tick
and
my family physician was smart enough to
know just wait it'll pass those four
brain circuits of suppression are
starting to develop
nowadays they'd put a kid on tourette's
medication
so i am very wary of i mean you're
blitzing these neurochemical systems and
again there are cases where people
really need it suicidal depression
please get on an antidepressant and get
talk therapy um severe adhd please talk
to a psychiatrist and a psychologist get
the diet right too but i would
just
my wish for humanity is that we
someone told me i'm cutting myself off
on purpose a psychiatrist colleague at
stanford told me that
more than 75
of the psychoactive medication
that's consumed in the world is consumed
in the united states
it's us and we have no one to blame for
this except ourselves and it's not like
we have
like the extremely rough environment
that we're i mean we're in america you
know we created in here yeah yeah
what was up with the the gun school
suicide
because i did i did uh read a little bit
about that when i was doing a little
research on you and i just happened to
happen to click into that what was going
on with that like what was it 2017 they
had four suicides they have a really
high suicide rate well what's going on
with that
unclear but you know when i went to gunn
it was academically rigorous
our football team was terrible probably
still is terrible but there were some
good sports there so it wasn't a lack of
physical activity
music and orchestra stuff is pretty big
there
so
[Music]
we know that now the kids are under
significant pressure for academic
performance there's a there are train
tracks not far from there and a good
number of the suicides were by train
um it became a
you know a bit of a spreading phenomenon
social contagion a little social
contagion um
there
is the idea that
people were pushing their kids too hard
in terms of academic performance who
knows
we can only speculate
there was the idea that
um you know if you
create an environment that's such high
pressure and demand and you know i think
they've now forbidden the kids from
meeting before school to do study
sessions they were meeting you know 6 7
a.m and studying
you know it and i don't think we can
point our finger at any one thing or one
collection of things but yeah what what
a terrible situation and um
i think it's hopefully
resolved itself now over time uh someone
from gun actually um someone related to
gun a parent actually contacted me at
one point um
because they saw on their wikipedia that
i had attended there and
um
and asked what my thoughts were on this
and i said listen
i'm not a psychiatrist or psychologist
but i went to that school i certainly
had my my challenges at that time
give them tools
please you know tools matter talking you
know the tell a friend or if you suspect
absolutely you know call call people but
give people tools to understand when
their mind is drifting off course and i
think
most of the tools that we've talked
about today certainly the behavioral
ones they absolutely pertain to adults
and the kids
you know we i think if our young people
can learn how to self-regulate in both
directions ramp up and ramp down as
needed overcome limbic friction
recognize limbic friction understand the
dopamine reward system
i do hope i have this fantasy that it
will help them
know when they're on track and when
they're drifting off course
one one thing that i think is very uh
cool about your story is
look i mean i got four kids that they're
you know two of them in college now
that pressure of this academic success
being it's it's can be psycho and i
think it's cool you're an example of
someone that barely passed high school
took a little while to figure out what
you wanted to do was able to get on a
path so maybe to all the kids out there
if you're under some hyper academic
pressure right now
man you you
you can get there
you can get there um you know this guy
right here barely made it out of high
school and now he's a tenured professor
at stanford that's
that's that's pretty awesome that you
were able to do that and you know some
people some of these kids they don't get
into whatever college they wanted to get
into and they think it's the end of the
world right and and and look when you're
young of course you break up with your
girlfriend it's the end of the world you
know you you lose a football game it's
the end of the world there's all these
things when your world is small there's
a lot of things that look like the end
of the world but i think you're a great
example of the fact that look you got
time to figure out this stuff and i'm
the same way you know i joined the navy
i was a rebellious young kid didn't did
shitty in high school wasn't a great
athlete okay join the navy start going
down the path and start to figure things
out and the same thing as you work hard
so if you're a kid out there and you're
feeling the pressures that the whole
world's gonna fall apart because you
missed some random hurdle
about getting into college or whatever
you got on your sats which by the way i
don't even take sats anymore
yeah it's like i heard they don't have
physical education anymore either
uh
they do have physical education um they
still do have physical education
i would say it's probably not as
rigorous as it should be
i'm sure you've seen those videos of
like what there's some school in the 50s
or 60s that they put this regimented
physical education in and these kids you
see have you seen those videos i'm
talking about echo charles yeah the one
they're doing they drop to the push-ups
yeah they're doing push-ups but like
it's a troop and these kids all look
like freaking commandos
it's pretty awesome and
that's how it should be but yeah that's
i think you're a great example of hey
you can
you don't have to have a perfect path to
being very successful and doing what you
truly want to do and there's another
thing that kids get messed up on
they think they should know what they
want to do what they want to do with
their lives when they're 14 years old
and oh what do you want to be when you
grow up i don't know and they feel bad
because of that that's actually
perfectly fine take a little time to
figure it out now i will say this
and you already said this as well go to
school try and get good grades don't do
freaking drugs don't get in trouble
because then your options will be
broader when you do get older but none
of these things are the end of the world
and actually i'm talking about kids i'm
not just talking about kids you can be
38 years old and figure out oh you know
what i'm gonna i'm gonna get my [ __ ]
together right now and i'm gonna start
moving in the right direction i mean you
talked about a bunch of skateboarders
and i knew a bunch of hardcore kids that
didn't square themselves away
until they were 37 years old and so
we all have options out there and you're
you're not gonna you're not gonna nail
it man no nail's a perfect game
it doesn't happen no it doesn't and
you know if you can start early great
but develop great work habits but learn
how to toggle between work and rest and
i always say find non-destructive ways
to renew yourself
you know so many of the the forms of
renewal not just when kids are in
college or in high school but also i
look at the corporate world and this is
an issue that i actually had with
academia for a long time it was like how
are we going to rest after a hard work
of a hard week of work in graduate
school they're going to do beer hour and
you've got people just like tying one on
okay sure like i have nothing against
people having a couple cocktails if
that's their thing or beer or whatever
but people just finding absolutely
destructive ways to
learn to rest they don't learn anything
under that case so have non-destructive
ways to recover yourself that could be a
long jog or a hike on the weekends or go
swimming or go watch a movie or do
something creative draw i mean spend
time with people whatever it is
you know and i realize i'm coming across
this kind of you know it's it sounds a
little corny but at the same time
you will go further and faster than
everybody
yeah and and what's important about what
you just said and this is some tying
back to something you talked about
earlier with these
dopamine systems that we have
it's a cycle and you can get yourself
moving on the right cycle but that first
step is hard right that first you're
gonna get a reward when you go for a run
you're gonna get a reward when you get
done with squats you're gonna get reward
when you get done with jiu jitsu you're
gonna get a reward but that getting
there
you have to impose that first part
yourself you have to make it happen and
that's there's going to be you know your
limbic system is going to be giving you
friction about how comfortable you are
right now and maybe just another donut
will be just as good and that's kind of
a reward right now don't listen to it
take action go out and step into it and
you're going to start yourself onto a
cycle that is way more positive and it's
going to have much better results in the
long run
than listening to your limbic system
which is telling you to eat another
donut have another beer get some
immediate dopamine from something that
takes no effort whatsoever yeah or sit
back and just scroll to your death
check
uh listen probably a good place to wrap
it up
we're approaching um five hours
anybody that's listened to this that
wants to go deep look
there's probably some people that are
thinking oh he kind of went deep on some
subjects no you this was like andrew
huberman uh the the shallow zone right
cliff yeah this is the cliff notes
version
uh his podcast you can find work it's
everywhere right yeah anyway spotify yep
um it's huberman lab human lab podcast
he's gonna take everything that he
mentioned today for for for four minutes
or six minutes he's gonna talk about for
two and a half to three hours with a
bunch of scientific data to back it up
awesome to listen to
um
and you can figure out they're very
very efficiently titled hey this is the
subject of this podcast here's what you
can learn and i i touched on some of
these things today habits stress you
know hormones like you've got all these
different topics it's it's just awesome
information
also they can find you huberman you say
hubermann or
hubermannlab.com this is kind of a good
access point for everything you're
you're on youtube and facebook both of
those are andrew huberman
and then you're on twitter on instagram
sucking people into the algorithm
bringing out the anger and the hatred
collecting data on who's frustrated and
the anger system
both those are at so twitter and
instagram at huberman lab
echo you got any other questions of
course what do you got i'm gonna keep it
i'm gonna try to keep it short so the
variable reward what was the random
intermittent reward yeah so doesn't that
kind of
illustrate the value of playing hard to
get in like dating and stuff
it does wondering if you're here to ask
about this um
some people understand this intuitively
and they cat string people right they
you know they
don't reward everything um it's amazing
the tactics that people will come up
with in order to get the resp the text
response if they're not getting it
um
here's what we know uh a picture is
worth a thousand words
use your imagination some people realize
ah you know when i text them they don't
respond but when i send a photo of a
particular kind their response is
instantaneous
um people learn
people's response schedules very quickly
this harkens back to childhood and we
could do a whole episode on this as a
child one of your
primary
the brain's a prediction machine or it's
trying to make predictions that's what
it wants to do and uh young children
learn to engage in certain behaviors to
predict and control the caretaking of
their parents this is important it's not
manipulative it's vital
and
adults do it too and they do it in the
same machinery that's designed for
infant caregiver attachment is
repurposed in adulthood um so
when we want something from somebody um
then we tend to pay careful attention to
their movements and when they respond
and their non-responses and random
intermittent reward is what a lot of
people use to keep people
um along for the ride
um
now there's a there's a positive version
of this where um
to keep the uh intensity high in the
positive sense in relationship yeah it's
good to miss someone it's good to take
some breaks you don't want to
overdo the dopamine system because it
will deplete itself um time together
time apart is useful um
the cozy parts of love and the more
intense uh romantic lusty parts of love
are both vital to the the arc of a
relationship
but
one you could imagine how time apart
could reset some of the dopamine people
seem more attractive and exciting when
you've been apart from them for a while
and a lot of people kind of
suffocate their relationship with
serotonin so to speak too much time
together we'll give you all the warm
cozy stuff but will it's antagonistic as
we say uh to the dopamine system but
yeah people people manipulate using
these systems um
and that's unfortunate uh but
you know i'm not an expert in how to
counsel them on that yeah so
it is you might not be an expert on how
to counsel them on it but if people are
aware of it they can do a better job
combating becoming a victim to those
scenarios right and i always say you
know you should be very careful how much
you attach your dopamine to something
that is not under your complete control
you know if you give your entire
dopamine system over to somebody else's
responses or availability you're setting
yourself up for a pretty rough life even
if it's a great relationship
because either whether or not by
decision or by death or by circumstance
if that relationship were to go what are
you going to do so i think people tend
to get overly focused on how much
dopamine someone else can provide them i
think it's great i have a statement
about addiction which i think matches
the
scientific
mechanism very closely which is that
addiction is a progressive narrowing of
the things that bring you pleasure
whereas a good life is involves a
progressive expansion of the number of
things that bring you pleasure
so try and continue to derive pleasure
from with for instance time with friends
we all know the guy who's got the new
girlfriend and then disappears and then
comes back six months later it's like
hey you know yeah so i told you so you
know
it's okay to miss one another it's okay
to miss one another it's okay to not
text all the time when you're with
friends spend time with friends be
available for emergencies but spend time
with friends this cuts both ways women
with women men with men and assuming the
standard relationship model the you know
when you're with your guy friends be
with them right ladies when you're with
your girlfriends be with them and
you are
missing one another is great because
you're keeping that dopamine system
ready yeah so the i mean on a kind of a
more positive note you can kind of use
it as like in the courting phase we'll
say sure like don't just throw yourself
at somebody because you kind of jam
their system up a little bit right
yeah i mean you know at some point you
don't want to
game things too much right it's like
this gets into some deeper issues about
power and dynamics in relationships
right you know
is giving tons of gifts to someone a
sign that they're in charge or that
you're in charge well i don't know it
depends on your mutu your relative
finances right in one case you could be
the person saying i have resources and i
can take care of you forever in a sense
you're in the power position in another
case you're just showering them with
gifts in a desperate attempt to get them
to like you so there's a lot of context
to this that makes it tricky but i would
say that
giving to get is a very dangerous thing
get pure giving without the expectation
of a reward in exchange for that
is
great because then
both people get to experience that as a
positive thing and you know giving to
get it puts you in a very vulnerable
place
so essentially with great power
comes great responsibility absolutely
that's how guys get friend zone though
that's how you get friend zone you can
be like a what do you call like a catch
but you you give too much too quick you
get friend zone yeah i mean i confess
i've i have a few close female friends
that uh over the years most of my
friends are men and have a relationship
with a woman so that's got that's just
what how it's been organized
i don't i haven't developed um
many close friendships with with women
so friend zone is a bit of a foreign
concept to me um but i hear it exists
yeah it's like yeah basically the girl
doesn't have like sexual attraction to
the guy even though the guy is like the
perfect guy
but it's usually because the guy
positions himself below the girl like he
worships her too quick or something like
this and the girl's like oh he's not
like a challenge you know dating sounds
complicated put too much serotonin in
the scenario
i think it was tim ferriss our mutual
friend tim ferriss that's a long time
ago said you know the quality of your
life is largely
reflective of the number of really
difficult conversations that you're
willing to have and i love that because
i'm not very good at difficult
conversations who is that's why they're
called difficult but i think the person
concerned about being
should sit down with the person and say
listen here's what i really want
what
is the probability that's going to
happen in the next week and if it's a
well the 25 okay well
hit the rip cord and if it's a 75 or
i've been waiting for you to say this
like let's go you know i mean it seems
like direct communication is is lacking
in any scenario okay we're about to go
we're about to open up a whole nother
scenario here yeah i'm not sure i'm the
best person that's important wait would
you know if you've got the
let's say you got a girl that you're
trying to talk to and you think you
might be in the friend zone up
sort of assaulting her with the hey
where did where am i at that's
i'm gonna say that might not be the best
what i would probably do is assume
that we're just friends and behave that
way don't assume that you're gonna don't
assume that there's a chance you just
assume hey you know what she probably
doesn't really like me that much that's
the assumption you make back
off if if
she ends up
actually feeling that way then she's
gonna come and and let you know that
so your behavior should be oh she just
wants to be friends cool don't box her
into a corner with the with the andrew
huberman freaking direct assault hey
where are we at girl where are we at i'm
not even sure it has to be a verbal
communication i think it could just be a
you know is this relationship of a
romantic sexual relationship or is this
a friendship and you don't there are
numerous ways to have that conversation
but obviously it should be consensual
age-appropriate context-appropriate
species appropriate
no we don't have to go there
but um
but but
listen what you're describing to me is
foreign territory because i'm not i'm
just not of the
the ilk that is in the habit of having a
lot of uh you know
friendships aside from male friendships
he's like listen i don't know what
you're talking about this friendzone
thing never been there not a thing
i like it
i'm not saying that
i'm just saying it's hard for me to
imagine that that anyone would find
themselves in this position i mean also
be a scientist the data or the data
right i do believe if somebody wants to
do something they're basically going to
do it and if they don't they're not
going to jack you know jack
going back to a little bit more serious
now what you said about
um
you know you shouldn't give to get this
is something i brief leaders on all the
time if the reason you're
taking care of your team is so that you
can get something out of them they're
gonna see that and it's not gonna work
out well so very similar um very similar
thought pattern there
uh
andrew you got any closing thoughts
before we shut her down
just really want to say thank you for
having me here today it's a truly an
honor and a pleasure i don't say that
formally i say that sincerely and as a
listener of your podcast i'm you know
this has been a thrill for me i've
learned a lot from both of you guys and
uh well i'm not gonna roll jiu jitsu
because i don't know how uh maybe
someday and uh yeah thanks so much
well thanks for coming and
back at you you know as a listener to
your podcast it's awesome to be able to
sit down and drill down on some of these
things and you know really uh a really
important thing
i would say there's a theme that i've
that i've taken away from
from your podcast but then that i
absolutely reinforced today i talked
about a little bit the fact that the
things that you're talking about really
allow us to bring awareness to what's
happening
in our bodies in our minds
physiologically and therefore
we actually have more influence than we
think
over
what our thought patterns are and the
way we behave which ultimately
allows us as people to take more
ownership
over the way we feel
the way we behave and those are really
important things and i think just
understanding the nature of our own
physio physiology better
is a huge step forward in people living
better lives so
thank you for coming down and joining us
and and thank you for taking that
information and passing it on to people
for free you know you you do this stuff
for free your podcast is is free and
you've invested obviously a ton of time
to try and learn these things and and
the fact that you give it back to people
for free is
just a testament to the kind of person
you are and i appreciate it and i hope
you keep getting after it man thanks for
coming down thank you
and with that andrew huberman has left
the building
he rolled out echo did you gather any
good information yes a lot of stuff
going on a lot of stuff going on you can
see there's probably going to be
follow-on podcasts yes
bro you could have taken like one of
those questions that you kind of like
said and like do
four hours just on that
not to mention the stuff that you
probably wouldn't even understand that's
like another what 12 16 hours program
let's face it check no
great guy great information
definitely cool to talk to and you know
even just when he was leaving you know
we'll definitely get some stuff done
do some more stuff in the future um
yeah man
i really i really do
the the point that i was making kind of
throughout the podcast and that i kind
of closed out with like look just being
aware of these things makes you better
off
then you realize that you can influence
the way you feel the way you think the
way you sleep the way you have way more
influence you don't have to wake up in
the morning go
sleep good night i don't know why you
don't need to do that you know
you don't need to go i don't really feel
like working out you don't need to do
that you can say oh i know why i don't
feel like working right out right now
because i expended a bunch of dopamine
on something early this morning but you
know what it doesn't matter this doesn't
mean i'm a bad person just means i need
to go and get it started
take ownership of what's happening yeah
so i thought that was well worth the
price of admission oh if you're if
you're at the tail end of a four
something hour podcast right now i think
that right there was worth the price
that you just paid maybe you 2x it yeah
maybe you listen to it at 2x speed right
now
[Music]
it's possible what do you think what
percentage of people go 2x speed when
they're listening uh well depends on
what portion you know
sometimes i suspect that sometimes
they do 2x sometimes they do one x
um
with this one i don't know man this is
the kind word right you don't want to
listen to a 2x yeah you want to get
that's going to go some of that stuff's
going to go over your head i think
you're going to want 1x on this one yes
for sure i would say a lot of our
podcasts actually are 1x scenarios yeah
it's true
i was surprised though as you probably
could tell that the that he wasn't as
familiar with the idea of the friend
zone
because i think this is just this is my
hypothesis yeah my neural biological
hypothesis that
the
science perspective yes sir
the friend zone is a direct result but
hey wait was the friend zone a thing
when you were a kid yeah oh okay see it
wasn't called the expression no okay but
it was a thing oh yeah that you were in
yeah
i think he was just kind of to be honest
i remember one instance where i was in
the front well put it this way i had
like one foot in the friend zone
and one foot
out of the friend zone
where i was surprised on how little
influence i had over the scenario
and then thinking back i was in the
friend zone yeah so because i was this
person man if i if i understood this
variable reward scenario you might be
better a little bit better i would have
had more influence over that but it's
true i think it's a direct result of
this um of not understanding the
variable reward if you're just like oh
yeah um
freaking i'm just gonna do everything
that i think this girl wants me to do
that in and of itself creates a lack of
variable reward that's right
yeah
we're considering this to be a problem
so she's going to keep you around for
that whatever the serotonin
but there's no real there's no real
dopamine because
yeah of that of that phenomenon just
flooding it with serotonin it's too much
too much not enough dopamine so stay out
the friend zone just tell the friend
zone bro
especially someone like you that's
apparently spent a lot of time in the
friend zone
that was a long time ago uh hey
thanks for listening
we we sorry it went long but you know
what that's the way it happens sometimes
if you want to support the podcast uh
and you want to support yourself you
want to get you you use down for the
who's down for the discipline go yeah
and down for the discipline and if you
notice with knowing
no one really made a thing out of it but
he mentioned theanine right when he was
like and he said oh i like theanine i
like it um some people mix it with
coffee so you don't get the jitters and
all this oh i was about to say wow well
i didn't want to interrupt yeah yeah
plus then it sounds like you're trying
to hard sell something yeah well
actually we do i don't want to be that
guy exactly but yes we have the ultimate
formulation for
energy
energy
for the ultimate formula we kind of have
the ultimate formulation yes sir and
think about it and he said he straight
up takes alpha gpc takes it as a
supplement except when he's drinking the
goat because alpha gpc he mentioned the
thingy and all the benefits whatever hey
look we kept it cool we're not going to
make a big deal out of it but it just
happens we kind of got you covered on
all
that one so that's awesome uh
if you want to get some of that go to
jackalfuel.com you go to wawa and get
some of it you can go to vitamin shop
and get whatever
you can get mulk by the way which is
which is
look i i'd love to tell you hey you need
additional protein and you do i get it
but you also need something that tastes
hella good
get yourself some mole get yourself some
joint warfare some super krill
i've been noticing you've been saying
hella good lately really like that's
like the third time you said in the last
three days two days really yes sir
hmm
is it it's kind of an older like an 80s
expression isn't it if i'm not mistaken
it's just northern california expression
for sure hello because in maine we say
wicked good yes
yeah those of us that know about maine
yeah we know that yeah but i think
that's a hella good is like
like when you first said it i was like
wait what is the reason for that
i don't know
it still remains a mystery nonetheless
you're correct yep it is hella good
vitamin shop wah wah jocklefuel.com get
yourself some supplementation that's
gonna make you bigger faster stronger
smarter smarter whole nine yards there
you go and balanced uh chemically too
yeah because we didn't talk that much
about the sugar well we did talk about
the crash right you get all these
crashes you start doing all this stuff
to your brain chemistry you get these
crashes
no reason for this you don't got to deal
with that kind of stuff anymore no
darkofield.com check out originusa.com
you're probably going to need a ghee
right because we're training jiu-jitsu
hey look
i would love to tell you you could wear
that ghee down to the market out to the
club
you can't
know you can
it's probably going to get you
friend-zoned
don't let that happen
no you might have a a a female let's say
you're a male and you might have a
female that's real into jiu-jitsu which
is super cool maybe she's down you know
maybe she's wearing a geek maybe we're
wearing ghees out maybe that's what
we're doing just do it sometimes how
about that but
that might not be the case you might
need it you might need a pair of jeans
right we got your jeans too made in
america made in the united states of
america
diy
do it yourself
you know
only because andrew kind of mentioned
this diy mentality that you get from the
punk rock the hardcore scene it's kind
of like do it yourself right that by the
way that's why jocko publishing exists
that's why we have jocko fuel because
we're making stuff we don't go hey you
know we'd really like to do this so
we'll just you know
no we're doing it that's what we're
doing
i don't want to
split hairs here but
this might be small tangent but i think
it's important
diy
has like a contextual
element to it it's short for do it
yourself yeah but so put it this way diy
doesn't mean do it yourself and do it
yourself is d y i y but not all d i y
means all the things that do it yourself
mean okay so what do you think so d i if
you say d because i'm already
ready to move on
this is the technicality that may or may
when you say diy into if i say hey if if
jocko you say hey can you give me some
water and i say do it yourself okay so
let's do it that is one of the many do
it yourself diy means like usually it's
done not like as a favor but like as a
um production kind of thing
and then you just did it yourself like
kind of makeshift okay it has a
makeshift like kind of quality kind of
feel to it
it's insane
you're good yes sir okay let's go to uh
jacquasstore.com
so jaco store which started as a
diy scenario
um but it's not anymore it's a well uh
you know varying levels of matte uh
oiled machine
sure right now we've got some good stuff
on there got some discipline equals
freedom shirts and hats hoodies merch if
you will but it's good quality stuff
it's not just some cheap stuff it's good
quality
arguably the most wearable
clothing that seems to be the consensus
kind of around yes
many people when i say man i mean for
real like countless not the guy like
three like countless people have said
it's my favorite favorite shirt not just
because of the design and the
representing on the path but because of
how it fits what about when they get a a
shirt locker shirt same it's all the
same and they think man there's only a
few people that have this shirt like
andrew was talking about
he was talking about the thunder trucks
shirt oh it's limited that's why he
saved he still has it to this day
he has it to this day you get a shirt
locker shirt you're kind of in that in
that arena exclusive and limited yeah
that's true um
so what that is if you don't know it's a
subscription scenario you get a new
shirt every month here's the thing about
that shirt that he was talking about
what did it say something about
something something and i'm sponsored by
thunder trucks and i only got this
t-shirt it's lousy t-shirts on this
lousy tv okay so this is why i remember
that because there are other shirt
companies that do you know like the kind
of shirt companies that make fun shirts
like that are knockoff like a
they almost borrow like the concept in
the design from like coca-cola but it
says cho instead of coke it says choke
you know like that idea
like there's a few
that i saw that had that same thing it
said i'm something something something
like something real impressive and then
it said but i only got this lousy
t-shirt yeah it was like that's how i
remembered it yeah that's uh that was
the thing you know i ran the boston
marathon and all i got was this yeah
i went to bulgaria and all i got was
this lousy t-shirt yeah yeah there you
go yeah but yes some shirts are
exclusive yeah that's just something
all those things that we just said are a
little bit lame right unless it's from
thunder trucks and it's limited and then
all of a sudden it comes it becomes
kind of rad you're kind of kind of hype
uh
subscribe to this podcast and don't
forget about the jocko underground we've
been rolling those out talking about
some detailed information giving lots of
q a so there's a there's a way to access
us for questions if you want to ask a
question we can answer it on
jacquelineground.com
go and check that out if you want to
support us diy
right because you can't you can't let
the man control everything that's true
you know what i'm saying you can't give
power to the man
no you can't you don't want to you got
to create your own platform over on the
side in case you have to escape out the
side hatch yeah so we're ready
jockowunderground.com you want to kick
in a little eight dollars and 18 cents a
month it's cool we appreciate it we'll
be ready
so that's that youtube channel
subscribe to the youtube channel
don't forget about origin usa they have
a youtube channel
uh
flipsidecanvas.com dakota meyer making
cool stuff to hang on your walls got a
bunch of books i've written a bunch of
books
if you want to check those out check
them out you can get them anywhere you
get books
you can also check out
jackopodcast.com
and you can go to books from the podcast
and you can find all the books there
so
that's for books that not necessarily
that i've written but books that we've
covered on the podcast
there's like an email thing to sign up
for too on the podcast jackopodcast.com
no that's on jacob's store chocolate
store yeah the podcast's pretty
straightforward as far as information
surrounding the podcast
just go to the website
check
uh good to go we also have
echelonfront.com
this is a leadership consultancy we work
with all kinds of
companies and we teach the leadership
principles some of them you heard me
talk about today but if you have
problems in your organization they're
leadership problems i'm here to tell you
so if you want help with that go to
echelonfront.com for details we also
have some live events we got the muster
coming up we got battlefield we go and
walk gettysburg we go and walk little
big her big horn get the lessons learned
from those so check that out
ashlandfront.com also we have a training
academy
to be better
to be better in life extreme
ownership.com you want to take ownership
of your life you want to and if you want
to ask me a question live
go to
extremeownership.com we got a bunch of
courses on there it's going to make
every aspect of your life better it's
going to make you better
so check that out extremeownership.com
if you want to help service members
active and retired
gold star families check out
americasmightywarriors.org that's mark
lee's mom mama lee great organization
also heroes and horses.com check that
one out and and don't forget
for andrew huberman
you can find him at
hubermannlab.com and
on youtube and on facebook he's at
andrew huberman and then on twitter and
on instagram he's at huberman lab
and as far as echo and i go we're both
on twitter we're on the gram
or on facebook why
echoes out with charles i'm at
jacqueline look no matter what you're
going on there for just just watch your
back because the algorithm is going to
sneak up bro we learned we learned a lot
about that today that dopamine hitter
you're trying to get that dopamine
hitter next thing you know
you you're a dope
so be careful
and thanks once again to andrew huberman
for coming on really again he's putting
a lot of great knowledge out there and
we definitely appreciate it so thanks
andrew for driving all the way down here
to make this happen and i look forward
to returning the favor in the future
and of course thanks to the service men
and service women out there on the front
lines
who make it possible for us to sit back
here and get educated and learn and live
our lives thank you for what you're
doing also
thanks for the service of our police and
law enforcement firefighters paramedics
emts dispatchers correctional officers
border patrol secret service all the
first responders out there
you all do what you do so that we can do
what we do and we appreciate it
and
to everyone else out there everyone else
out there
uh
look
there's a lot of ways to get better
we learned today that you can become a
you you should have become more aware of
things you should realize you have more
influence you realize you have influence
over the way you feel the way you think
you can take ownership of that
learned a lot about that today
and you know what
knowledge and learning and understanding
are great
but you know what else they don't mean
anything without action
so yes
learn and educate and enlighten yourself
but also don't forget to go out there
every day
and freaking get after it
and until next time
zecko and jocko
out